SB FIFTY NINE THIS IS ITEM.
NUMBER FOUR IN YOUR POCKET
[inaudible]
SENATOR ALLEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU A MEASURE
MEMBERS SO I THE INTRODUCTION OF
AUTONOMOUS PASSENGER VEHICLES ON
TO OUR ROADS AND WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
REVOLUTIONIZE THE WAY THAT WE
GET AROUND AND HOW WE RESHAPE
OUR COMMUNITIES NOW IT'S
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY.
I AND THERE'S A LOT OF POTENTIAL
BENEFITS READY COULD DRASTICALLY
REDUCE COLLISIONS AND ENHANCE
TRAFFIC FLOW.
THAT'S ALL VERY PROMISING -- BUT
OF COURSE IF NOT FIVE FULLY
DEPLOYED -- THIS NEW MOBILITY
REVOLUTION COULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACTS
POTENTIALLY INCLUDING
EXACERBATING CLIMATE AIR QUALITY
PLANNING CONGESTION CHALLENGES.
ARE THE REASON WHY I SAY THAT IS
THERE'S BEEN SOME RECENT STUDIES
THAT HAVE FOUND THAT -- BECAUSE
A VIS POTENTIALLY MAKE TRAVEL
LESS ONEROUS THEIR WIDESPREAD
ADOPTION COULD ACTUALLY INCREASE.
VEHICLE TRAVEL ARE.
BY A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT.
I THERE WAS AN EXPERIMENT WAS
CONDUCTED BY PROFESSORS AT UC
DAVIS AT BERKELEY GEORGE ATTACK
THE MIMIC LIFE WITH ANY V.
BASICALLY PROVIDING.
YOU KNOW EACH PARTICIPATING
HOUSEHOLD WITH A SHOW FOR AND
THE EXPERIMENT SAW THAT
HOUSEHOLDS TRAVEL EIGHTY THREE
M..
PERCENT MORE MILES PER WEEK WITH
MORE THAN A FIFTH OF THE VEHICLE
TRIPS CARRYING NO PASSENGERS.
I WHEN THEY HAVE YOU KNOW THE
OPTION OF OF A COMMERCIAL FOR
TRAVEL [inaudible]
SO.
YES THE POINT IS I THERE IS
INCREDIBLE PROMISE ASSOCIATE
WITH A VIS BUT THE QUESTION IS --
IF IT'S NOT DONE RIGHT IT COULD
ACTUALLY MAKE PROBLEMS WORSE.
AND SO ARE.
YOU KNOW.
ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
BILL IS LOOK AT THIS ISSUE WE'VE
LOOKED A LOT OF SAFETY ISSUES.
WITH THE REST AB THAT'S BEEN
WHERE A LOT OF THE FOCUS IS
SPEND BUT THERE'S A WHOLE SLEW
OF BROADER SOCIETAL IMPLICATIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH WITH THE ROLL
OUT OF AB SO.
THIS CREATES AN INTERAGENCY
GROUP TO TO DELIBERATELY PLAN
FOR AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IN A WAY
THAT SUPPORTS OUR PLANNING.
ARE SENATE BILL THE GOALS WITH
THE MIND TOWARD AVOIDING
POTENTIAL NEGATIVE IMPACTS ME
WORKING STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING INDUSTRY GROUPS AND
AUTOMAKERS AN ENVIRONMENTALIST
TO REFINE THE MEASURE AND INSURE
THAT WE DELIVER THE PLAN.
WILL NOT SIGNING WHAT COULD BE A
A REALLY TRANSFORMATIVE
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY AND SO.
I'M VERY COMMITTED TO TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS EYES IS BILL
PROCEEDS IS REALLY COMING OUT
THIS ISSUE AT A THAT.
KIND OF A VALUE NEUTRAL
PERSPECTIVE.
I AND WE'VE GOT A BOOST SO.
OKAY IS DONE HERE NO.
OKAY SO WELL RYAN I SHOULD
CHARGE FROM CAL START IF YOU'RE
SPARKS BEGIN -- SUPPORT ABOUT.
ORDERS.
YEAH GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M RANGE YOU
HARD ON BEHALF OF CAL START.
WE'RE A CLEAN TECHNOLOGY
CONSORTIUM HAS BEEN WORKING FOR
THE PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
TO ADVANCE THE GROWTH AND AND
AND DEVELOPMENT OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHETHER THIS STATE IS READY OR
NOT AUTOMATED VEHICLES ARE HERE
AND THEY'RE POISED TO TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA'S ENTIRE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
AND HOW CALIFORNIANS USE IT.
CAL STARTS ENCOURAGED ADMITTED
VEHICLES THE TECHNOLOGY COULD
SPEED THE GROWTH OF YOUR MISSION
VEHICLES ENCOURAGE CARPOOLING
GIVE NEW TOOLS TO PUBLIC TRANSIT
AND REDUCE ACCIDENTS WHICH ARE
MOSTLY CAUSED BY DRIVER ERROR.
BUT SINCE IT IS SUCH A NEW
TECHNOLOGY WE ARE JUST GUESSING
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT EXACTLY
IS COMING EXCEPT THAT THE
EFFECTS OF A DRIVERLESS FUTURE
WILL BE PROFOUND.
COMPLEX.
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS INDUSTRY
EXPERTS AND PUBLIC OFFICIALS.
ARE TRYING TO DEVELOP A CLEAR
VIEW ABOUT THE FUTURE AUTOMATED
VEHICLES THE BENEFITS A CONCERNS
MUCH LIKE THAT MUCH LIKE WAS
DONE LAST YEAR -- ON ON THE
SUBJECT.
BUT IN ANY COMMITTEE HEARING ON
THE SUBJECT LAST YEAR.
BUT THERE ARE STILL MORE
QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS.
HOW WILL AUTOMATED VEHICLES
AFFECT VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IN
LAND USE HOW AUTOMATED VEHICLES
AFFECT INDIVIDUALS USE OF
ALTERNATIVE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION SUCH AS PUBLIC
TRANSIT BICYCLING AND MORE?
HOW DO WE PROMOTE SHARED TRANSIT?
SHARED PASSENGER ABILITY AND ON
BALANCE AUTOMATED VEHICLES HELP
OR HINDER CALIFORNIA ACHIEVING
ITS CLIMB ECKELS.
WE WANT TO GIVE AUTOMATED
VEHICLE TAX TECHNOLOGY THE BEST
CHANCE TO CREATE THE MOST
BENEFITS FOR CALIFORNIANS IT
SUCCEED IN THE LONG RUN.
WHICH WHICH WE CAN SUPPORT TODAY
BY ESTABLISHING A CONSENSUS VIEW
ACROSS THE AGENCIES IN THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT WHAT THE KEY
ISSUES ARE AND THE GOALS FOR
THIS TEST THIS DESTRUCTIVE
TECHNOLOGY. FOR THESE REASONS WE
BELIEVE THAT I MADE A VEHICLE
TASK FORCE IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO CREATE SUCH AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION RESPECTFULLY
URGE I ABOUT [inaudible]
MORE.
THE ARE YOU SMARTER.
OTHER AYE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS ALSO A
CO SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
BROWN AND ASSOCIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MARK.
UP WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE ANY.
THE ANY THEN LET'S WRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
YOU HAVE NONE [inaudible]
YEAH. TO THE REPORT LET'S SEE
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A MAN DOWN.
BACK TO YOU ARE SENATOR.
DO YOU LIKE.
TO CLOSE YOUR THIS IS JUST AN
ISSUE WE ALL KNOW IT'S COMMON --
AND TWENTY PREPARED SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY BUT
WHEN THE QUORUM IS PRESENT.
THANK YOU DID YOU HAVE MOTION
[inaudible]
WE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SORRY
OKAY.
I THANK YOU.
JOHN I WANTED TO BE THE FIRST
ONE GOT A BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FOR THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
NUMBER ONE WHEN WE HAVE YEAH.
OKAY SO I SEE SENATE JACKSON IS
HERE AND SHE IS AS THIS SB FOUR
TWENTY FOUR THIS HAS TO DO WITH.
A SINGLE USE MULTI USE COMPONENT
TOBACCO PRODUCTS AS ITEM EIGHT
IN YOUR AGENDAS MEMBERS.
SENATE JACKSON YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY.
WELL GOOD MORNING LONG TIME NO
SEE MR HEY NO.
CRAZY WEEK LONG LONG HEARING AS
A BUT APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB.
FOUR TWENTY FOUR WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH A COMPREHENSIVE
TOBACCO PRODUCT WASTE.
PROGRAM TO GREATLY REDUCE
EXISTING AND EMERGING WASTE
STREAMS ASSOCIATED WITH TOBACCO
USAGE.
THE TOBACCO PRODUCT WASTE
COVERED BY THIS BILL.
INCLUDES NACHOS SINGLE USE
FILTERS.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CIGARETTE
****.
OUR THAT WE SEE UBIQUITOUSLY
LITTERING OUR STREETS OR
SIDEWALKS ARE GREEN SPACES ARE
BEACHES.
OUR LAKE FRONTS.
BUT ALSO.
WOULD ADDRESS PLASTIC TIPS THAT
ARE USED AS SINGLE USE PLASTIC
TIPS.
THAT ARE USED FOR THE
MANIPULATION OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
AND SINGLE USE ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES THAT ARE INCREASINGLY
PREFERRED BY TOBACCO USERS.
AS WELL AS MULTI USE DEVICES OF
SEVERAL SORTS INCLUDING
VAPORIZERS.
TOBACCO PRODUCT WASTE IS AMONG
THE MOST VEXING PROBLEMS THAT IS
FACED BY MUNICIPAL AGENCIES.
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES CLEAN AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTED.
COSTING MILLIONS TO CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
IMPACTS FROM THIS WASTE ON
COMMUNITIES AND THE ENVIRONMENT
ARE SEVERAL.
THE TOBACCO COMPONENT OF THIS
WASTE LEECHES TOXIC CHEMICALS
INTO OUR WATERWAYS AND OUR
MARINE ENVIRONMENT.
CREATING A SIGNIFICANT HAZARD TO
WILDLIFE THE WASTE IS ALSO A
HAZARD TO CHILDREN AND PETS WHO
MAY UNKNOWINGLY INGESTED
IMPROPERLY DISPOSED PRODUCT.
WHEN ENCOUNTERING IT OUTDOORS?
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE SEVERAL
PLASTIC AN INCREASINGLY
ELECTRONIC COMPONENTS TO NEW AND
EXISTING TOBACCO PRODUCTS THE
CARRY THEIR OWN HARMS.
A TO WILDLIFE IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
PLASTIC COMPONENTS INCLUDING
CELLULOSE FILTERS IN CIGARETTES
THANK DECADES TO DEGRADE.
BECOME MICRO PLASTICS AND CREATE
A DANGEROUS MIX OF TOXIC IN HAT
HAZARDOUS TOBACCO AND PLASTIC
CHEMICAL POLLUTION.
SOME JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE
STATE AND ACROSS THE WORLD ARE
MAKING EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS TO
GET AT THIS PERVASIVE POLLUTION
PROBLEM.
BUT THOSE EFFORTS HAVE LARGELY
FAILED IN NO SMALL PART TO THE
PERVASIVE NATURE IN DIFFICULT
COLLECTION.
OF SINGLE USE COMPONENTS SINGLE
USE ENCOURAGES USERS TO DISPOSE
OF THEIR CIGARETTE FILTERS BY
SMASHING THEM UNDERFOOT.
THROWING THEM ON THE SIDE WORK
THROWING THEM ON THE SAND BEACH.
AND OTHER.
OUT WAYS OF JUST SIMPLY LEAVING
THEM IN A FORM THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO RECOVER.
OR SINGLE USE INVITES USERS TO
CASUALLY TOSSED THEIR VAPE
CARTRIDGES WHEN NO WROTE
RECEPTACLE IS AVAILABLE.
ORDER TOSS AN ELECTRONIC VERSION
OF A CIGARETTE LIKE THE ONE
WOULD.
TOSS A TRADITIONAL CIGARETTES.
THIS MEASURE SB FOUR TWO FOUR
ADDRESSES THIS PERNICIOUS
PROBLEM THROUGH A TWO FOLD
APPROACH FIRST THIS BILL BANS
SALE OF SINGLE USED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN MOST CASES MULTI USE TOBACCO
SUBSTITUTE ALREADY EXIST ON THE
MARKET AND ARE AVAILABLE FOR
PURCHASE.
SECOND THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT
ALL MULTI USED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
BE REGULARLY RECYCLABLE.
BY EITHER A LOCAL OR STATE
RECYCLING PROGRAM SIMILARTO
WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR WHEN WE
PASSED A BILL.
TO HAVE THE PRODUCERS OF OUR
PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS A DRUGS
IN CHARGE CREATE TAKE BACK
PROGRAM SO THAT WE COULD REMOVE
THEM FROM OUR WASTE STREAM AND
FROM.
OUR SOCIETY AT LARGE ONCE THEY
HAVE EXPIRED OR NO LONGER SERVE
ANY USEFUL PURPOSE.
SO IF UPON A COMPONENT IS NOT
REGULARLY RECYCLABLE.
THEN THE MANUFACTURE THE PRODUCT
MUST SET UP EITHER A COLLECTION
OR MAIL TAKE BACK PROGRAM FOR
THAT COMPONENT.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY OR EPR
EPR PROGRAMS AS I MENTIONED
ALREADY EXISTING CALIFORNIA. FOR
SEVERAL DIFFICULT TO HANDLE
PRODUCTS USUALLY ADMINISTERED BY
CAL RECYCLE.
MATTRESSES OF OTHER PRODUCTS OF
THAT NATURE TIRES.
I AND THEY YUM.
THESE PROGRAMS -- ARE AS I
MENTIONED ADMINISTERED BY RESELL --
CAL RECYCLING RUN BIKE
MANUFACTURER FUNDED STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAMS.
THIS INCLUDES THE PHARMACEUTICAL
DRUG IN SHARP INDUSTRY AS I
MENTIONED WHICH STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL BE
COLLECTED THROUGH A SIMILAR
PROGRAM THAT WE ENVISIONED FOR
THIS.
AND THIS WAS A AS A RESULT OF A
MEASURE THAT I WAS ABLE TO GET
PASSED LAST YEAR AS BE TO TWELVE
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND THIS IS A FOLLOW UP ON THAT --
A PROGRAM OF FOLKS OF IF YOU'VE
BEEN ON A BEACH CLEAN UP OR ANY
KIND OF CLEAN UP DAY YOU'LL NOTE
THAT CIGARETTE ****.
ARE PERVASIVE.
AND IN FACT THERE WAS JUST A
CLEAN UP DONE IN THE LAKE TAHOE
AREA THAT ACCUMULATED WHAT WAS
IT SEVEN IN A SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND SOUNDS.
OF CIGARETTE **** I MEAN THIS
THIS PROBLEM REALLY IS A
SIGNIFICANT.
ONE THERE IS A WAY TO DEAL WITH
IT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DOCTOR TO
JOANNE BRASH HO IS THE SPECIAL
PRODUCTS MANAGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT.
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF THIS BILL [inaudible]
JACKSON -- THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JOANNE FRESH.
IT WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS WHICH ACCOUNTS I ALSO
WORK FOR THE NATIONAL STORAGE OF
ACTION COUNCIL -- WE'RE
NONPROFIT ADVOCATING FOR A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY ALSO LECTURE AT
UC DAVIS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
TEXTILES ON TOPICS OF INDUSTRIAL
ECOLOGY.
I'M HERE TODAY AS A SPONSOR OF
THE BILL TO URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR SB.
TWO FOUR TWO FOUR TOBACCO
PRODUCT REYES HAS CAUSED LONG
TERM DAMAGE TO OUR ECOSYSTEM AND
OUR COMMUNITIES.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE BEARING
THE COST BURDEN TO REMOVE
TOBACCO WASTE FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT.
BUT CANNOT REMOVE ALL THE
CHEMICALS AND MICRO PLASTICS.
REACHING INTO THE WATER KILLING
WILDLIFE AND ENDANGERING PUBLIC
HEALTH.
REVIEWED RESEARCH INDICATES
RISING LONG AND CARCINOMAS.
SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OF
ACETATE FILTERS WHICH ALTER
TOBACCO COMBUSTION INCREASING
SMOKE TOXICANT.
AS CITED IN THE JOURNAL OF
NATIONAL COUNCIL CANCER
INSTITUTE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN JUST RECENTLY.
CURRENTLY THERE IS INSUFFICIENT
END OF LIFE MANAGEMENT IN PLACE
FOR PROPER HANDLING OF TO BACK
AWAY.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE SAN
FRANCISCO SPENT NEARLY TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON CIGARETTE BUT
CLEAN UP ALONE.
IN MARCH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
THE DOWNTOWN STREETS TEAM ARE
AUDITED A TWO MILE STRIP WHICH
IS ALREADY CLEANED THREE TIMES A
WEEK THEY'RE ALREADY PAYING FOR
REGULAR CLEAN UPS AND THEY STILL
FOUND OVER ONE THOUSAND
CIGARETTE BUT IN JUST THIS SHORT.
STRIP OF UNINCORPORATED ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
I ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO LOOK AT
THE GROUND TODAY AS YOU LEAVE
THE CAPITAL AND NOTICE ALL OF
THE CIGARETTE BUT HERE ON OUR
OWN LITTLE SLICE OF EARTH HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
COSTS WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PHASE IN THE DEPLOYMENT OF
CAPTURE DEVICES. TO MEET THE
TOTAL MAXIMUM DAILY LOAD
REQUIREMENTS AS SET BY THE STATE
WATER.
THIS BILL BANS THE SALE OF
SINGLE USE PLASTICS IN TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THAT DO NOT MEET STATE
AND LOCAL RECYCLING SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
ELECTRONIC SMOKING DEVICES BE
REUSABLE.
AND THE PRODUCERS PROVIDE TAKE
BACK PROGRAMS FOR PROPER END OF
LIFE MANAGEMENT.
WE AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROVIDES
INCENTIVE TO ELIMINATE THE WET
THE WASTE AFTER SOURCE.
WE ASKED PRODUCERS TO TAKE THEIR
FAIR SHARE OF RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THESE HARD TO MANAGE PRODUCTS.
AS LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALONE CANNOT
HANDLE THE BY THE COST BURDEN OF
TAP TOXIC TOBACCO WASTE.
POSING SIGNIFICANT.
HEALTH RISKS TO HUMAN AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YES.
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR SECOND
WITNESS I NEED TO CORRECT THE
RECORD HERE MY NUMBERS WERE OFF
AND I DON'T WANT TO BE ACCUSED
OF HYPERBOLE -- THE IT WAS JUST
THIS MORNING ON PUBLIC RADIO
BEFORE A CUP OF COFFEE I HEARD
THIS SO MY NUMBERS WERE LITTLE
OFF.
BUT I HEARD A THAT VOLUNTEERS ON
EARTH DAY IN AN EARTH THEY CLEAN
UP IN SOUTH LAKE TAHOE THAT SO.
OTHER THE NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF
THE LEADER THAT THEY COLLECTED
CAME FROM THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY POUNDS OF TRASH NOT
SEVENTY FIVE WHATEVER I SAID BUT
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY POUNDS OF
TRASH NO SMALL AMOUNT OF TRASH --
WAS CIGARETTE **** THEY COUNTED
OVER SX THOUSAND PIECES
SELECTED BY CHEST SIXTY
VOLUNTEERS SO.
I WANT TO BE ACCURATE ON THAT
BUT IT'S STILL PRETTY HORRIFIC
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHENMEMBERS I'M
GENEVIEVE AVEDON AND I REPRESENT
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION THAT CONSISTS OF
ELEVEN NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
DEDICATED TO PLASTIC POLLUTION
SOLUTION.
INCLUDING HEAL THE BAY SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION AND OTHERS.
UP PLASTIC POLLUTION AFFECTS
EVERY STREAM RIVER PARK IN
STREET IN CALIFORNIA IT STARTS
WITH FOSSIL FUEL EXTRACTION AND
CONTINUES THROUGH MANUFACTURING
TRANSPORTATION YOU SUCH AND
DISPOSAL.
PLASTIC THE RECENTLY BEEN FOUND
TO EMIT POTENT GREENHOUSE GASES
AS THEY BREAK DOWN AND WITH THE
PLAN 40% INCREASE IN PLASTIC
PRODUCTION OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
UNLESS WE MAKE MAJOR POLICY
CHANGES TO SIGNIFICANTLY COUNTER
THIS PLASTIC PRODUCTION WILL
ACCOUNT 420% OF GLOBAL FOSSIL
FUEL CONSUMPTION.
MOST PEOPLE THINK CIGARETTE ****
ARE COTTON AND QUOTE
BIODEGRADABLE BUT THEIR PLASTIC
FULL OF TOXIC CHEMICALS WHICH
HARM WILDLIFE AND IMPACT WATER
QUALITY.
ADDITIONALLY MICROPROCESSOR BEEN
FOUND IN TAP WATER BOTTLED WATER
TABLE SALT FISH SHELLFISH AND
AGRICULTURAL SOILS ALL OF WHICH
POSE A POTENTIAL THREAT TO HUMAN
AND ANIMAL HEALTH.
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
CIGARETTE **** ARE THE NUMBER
ONE MOST LETTER THING ON THE
THEY'RE FULL OF TOXIC CHEMICALS.
AT CLEAN UP DATA INTERNATIONAL
OCEAN CLEAN UP DATA SHOWS THAT
DURING THE GROUP'S TWENTY
EIGHTEEN COASTAL CLEANUP MORE
THAN TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
CIGARETTE **** WERE PICKED UP
WORLDWIDE.
TOPPING FOOD WRAPPERS AND
PLASTIC BEVERAGE BOTTLES.
THE SAME EVENT PICKED UP EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
CIGARETTE **** AND RELATED
LETTER FROM COASTLINES IN THE US
AND A HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN FROM CALIFORNIA MORE
THAN FROM ANY OTHER STATE.
IN CONCLUSION CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO DO SOMETHING THAT WILL
ACTUALLY WORK TO FINALLY ADDRESS
OUR THIRTY YEAR OLD POLLUTION
PROBLEM BY ELIMINATING FILTERS
ON CIGARETTES.
WE THUS WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB FOUR TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY SO
FOLKS WHO WANT TO WIN IN SUPPORT.
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BRING GARCIA ON
TO HAVE A RETHINK WASTES IN
SUPPORT OF A HAVE A HAVE TO
RETHINK WASTE OKAY GREAT.
AND ALSO SIERRA CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT YOU.
GOOD MORNING JUST MULLIN FOR THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IT'S LIKE IT DOES ON BEHALF OF
STOP WASTE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY.
THEY WANT TO VOICE OPPOSITION
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
OUR SERVER YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- SENATOR
WHAT CASKEY.
AS CENTER OF YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
HARMONIZING THIS BILL WITH WITH
THE EUROPEAN UNION DID I MEAN
THEY THEY PASSED THE PRETTY
EXTENSIVE -- A BILL TO OUTLAW
CIGARETTE **** BUT THEY'RE
EFFECTIVE DATE IS LIKE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR FOR IMPLEMENTING
EXTENDED PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
THIS IS.
THIS IS ALL DUE IN JANUARY.
IT SEEMS RATHER ABRUPT.
WELL I'M THE REASON THAT WE ARE
SENDING AN EARLY DATE IS WE ANT
TO GET THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY TO
THE TABLE -- IF WE FOLLOW THE
PATTERN THAT WE DID GETTING THE
PHARMACEUTICALINDUSTRY TO THE
TABLE -- WE SAT DOWN AND
BASICALLY I THE QUESTION IS
SIMPLE THIS IS WHAT WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH HOW DO YOU PROPOSE
DOING IT.
AND WITH THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY WE ESSENTIALLY LEFT IT
UP TO THEM TO FIGURE OUT THE
METHODOLOGY THEY WERE GOING TO
USE WE GAVE THEM CERTAIN METRICS
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE TO
OBTAIN.
AND THAT BILL BECOMES EFFECTIVE
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO OF AGAIN
IT'S A QUESTION OF BRINGING
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE HAVING THEM
SIT DOWN RECOGNIZE THE PROBLEM
THE URGENCY OF IT.
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN BEST
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL AND CERTAINLY
I SUSPECT THAT IT WILL WE WON'T
BE.
THERE -- BY JANUARY TWENTY
NINETEENTH BUT WE WILL HOPEFULLY
HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE WITH A
REASONABLE START UPDATE.
AND HAVE THE INDUSTRY TAKING
THAT RESPONSIBILITY FOR OF
FIGURING OUT HOW TO ADDRESS A
MESS THAT WE AS POLICY MAKERS
DETERMINE IS NOT ACCEPTABLE IN
OUR STATE I I JUST I JUST KNOW
THE EUROPEAN SPENT.
ON THEIR PLASTIC RECYCLING SPENT
FOUR YEARS FIVE YEARS TRYING TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING AND JUST
ENJOY IN OCTOBER OR NOVEMBER
THEY GOT A DEAL THAT THEY HAVE
AND THAT.
PRESUMABLY BECAUSE THE STAFF
REPORT TALKS ABOUT OUT OF STATE
COMPLIANCE AND IT APPEARS THAT
IF THE U. THEY IF.
IF THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY AND THE
PLASTIC FILTER INDUSTRY HAS TO
DO THIS IN EUROPE IT SEEM LIKE
THIS WOULD BE A WAVE.
THE PARALLEL COULD DISCUSSIONS
AND YOU HAD SAID THAT WOULD MAKE
EMINENTLY GOOD SENSE THE SENATOR
AND MY HOPE IS THAT THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY WILL.
RECOGNIZE THAT IN THAT WE CAN
HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND COME
UP WITH THE SPECIFIC SOLUTION
RIGHT NOW WE ARE.
ABOUT TO HAVE MEETINGS WITH THEM
THE BRING THEM TO THE TABLE -- I
FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THOUGH THAT.
SHOULD DO WE AS A LEGISLATURE
MAKE CLEAR THAT THEY HAVE GOT.
TO HELP.
AND IN TAKE SOME RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THIS ISSUE.
THAT THEY WILL COME TO THE TABLE
IF THEY KNOW THEY HAVE TO AND
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE
ASKING IS THAT WE MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THEY'VE GOT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I AM VERY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THEM TO ACHIEVE THE BEST.
APPROACH TO RESOLVING THIS
PROBLEM AND HAVING THEM.
ESSENTIALLY TAKE THE LEAD IN
FIGURING OUT HOW TO DO IT THAT'S
WHAT WE DID WITH THE
PHARMACEUTICAL ISSUE -- AND A
BEGIN WITH THE E. F. THE
EUROPEAN UNION HAS A SYSTEM THAT
WORKS I'M VERY INTERESTED IN HOW
WE CAN APPLY THAT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M NOT.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
LITTLE DETAILS BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THIS INDUSTRY BETTER BUT THE
RESULTS ARE RESULTS THAT I AM
HOPEFUL THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
WILL MAKE CLEAR.
THAT ARE THE POLICY THE STATE
AND THAT THEY WILL THEN
IMPLEMENT THEM.
IN AND IN A WAY THAT WORKS FOR
ALL OF US.
AND THEN MISTER CHAIR THE LAST
QUESTION THIS.
ART NAY SENT LEGAL MARIJUANA
INDUSTRY THAT -- WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF THIS IS THIS LEGISLATURE'S
NOT SHORT ON NEW REGULATIONS ON
HOW WE BELIEVE WE CAN REGULATE
POT.
YOU KNOW AND AT AND AND DO THAT
THIS EXTENDS TO THOSE.
A SINGLE USE THIS IS NOT BONGS
AND PIPES THIS IS.
NO THIS IS SINGLE USE REGARDLESS
OF WHAT THE PRODUCT IS THAT'S
BEING SMOKED WITHIN IT SO IT
WOULD HAVE FLOOR IT WOULD APPLY
TO SINGLE USE.
MARIJUANA CIGARETTES.
ARE I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT THEY
WOULD LOOK LIKE BUT ARE A IT
DOES APPLY TO THE RECEPTACLE.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT IS BEING
SMOKED WITHIN IT.
OKAY I'M I'M JUST.
HI I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY COME TO
THE TABLE.
WELL I I THINK.
YOU KNOW I DON'T.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THE INVASION
SMOKING POT.
IS A TOBACCO TYPE PRODUCT OF
DIFFERENTLY THAN.
THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY ITSELF I
MEAN.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THIS BEFORE BUT
BETTER TO START THEM RIGHT AT
THE BEGINNING I WOULD SUGGEST.
THEN HAVE THEM CREATE SOMETHING
AND THEN WE SAY NO THAT ISN'T
GOING TO WORK TO HAVE THEM IN AT
THE GROUND LEVEL I THINK IS.
IS HELPFUL TO THEM AS WELL.
SO THEY RECOGNIZED THAT SINGLE
USE THIS THE DISPOSABLE OF
MARIJUANA BOX OR WHATEVER
THEY'RE GOING TO CALL THEM.
ARE NOT ACCEPTABLE EITHER.
I'M I'M WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT
IS THAT THERE'S BEEN A SOMEWHAT
OF AN OVERLOAD WITH THE STATE
LEGISLATURE I'M PASSING VARIETY
OF BILLS TO REGULATE THIS
COMMUNITY THAT HAS NEVER BEEN
REGULATED.
AND I'D THE IDEA OF THEM
PARTICIPATING IN THE EXTENT OF
PRODUCE RESPONSIBILITY WHICH IS
ON THE INTELLECTUAL LEVEL I I
GET BUT I JUST JUST SPOTTING THE
ISSUES STAFF IS -- BUT IT IS
JUST ONE OF THOSE.
AND AGAIN -- IF THEY COME TO THE
IF THEY'LL COME TO THE TABLE AND
TELL US.
WHAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE WITH
THEIR NEEDS ARE IN A PROPOSAL TO
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM I'M
COMPLETELY OPEN AND AND ACTUALLY
INTERESTED IN?
IN THEIR THEIR PERSPECTIVE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GREAT ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS [inaudible]
YEP SUPERVISOR.
THE PERSON.
WHO POSSESSES THE?
CIGARETTE WITH A FILTER ON IT
NAY BOUGHT IT IN ANOTHER STATE.
YOU KNOW THE BODY YEAR SUPPLY
THAT'S POSSIBLE.
SO THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT THE
POSSESSION OF A SINGLE USE
FILTER IN THOSE OR CIGARETTES
BASICALLY THE FILTER TIP.
YES HOW SOME OF THESE BANDS
PRODUCT FROM YOU WELL WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE MANUFACTURER.
THAT'S REALLY THE BEST AND THE
MOST BROAD BASED WAY TO DEAL
WITH THE PROBLEM IS THE
MANUFACTURER OF THE PRODUCT.
SO SOMEONE HAS POSSESSION OF
THEM I DON'T THINK WE'VE
ADDRESSED THEIR POSSESSION I
DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR WE JUST WANT. TO
CLOSE OUT THE USE OF THIS
PRODUCT IN THE MANUFACTURING
PROCESS.
I GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING SENATOR
JACKSON IS THAT THEY COULD JUST
STOP.
PRODUCING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND YOU CAN JUST RUN
ACROSS THE BORDER TO GET IN THE
NEXT GO WHERE.
IF IF THEY'RE NOT GONNA COME TO
THE TABLE AND HAVE A DISCUSSION.
SO I'M NOT SURE THAT THE PAST
MIGHT NOT BE THERE AND I AM
CERTAIN ISSUE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON IT.
BUT IF YOU'RE A MAJOR CIGARETTE
MANUFACTURER AND YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE.
THE WAY YOU -- MAKE A CIGARETTE
WITH THE ATTACHED FILTER ON IT
THE HOUSE OF THIS PLASTIC
COMPONENTS.
NON BY BY AGRADABLE -- THEN
YOU'RE. TO CHANGE YOUR ENTIRE
WAY YOU MANUFACTURE CIGARETTES
TO MY SAY FORGET I'LL JUST
SOLOMON MEXICO AND OTHER STATES
AND THEN PEOPLE WHO STILL SMOKE
I MEAN IT MIGHT BE A DETERRENT --
YOU KNOW IN YOUR HAND DIRECT
BENEFIT A DETERRENT TO SMOKING.
THEN PEOPLE HAVEN'T BECAUSE
THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT POSSESSING.
THE EMILY K. IF I BUY THEM --
LET'S SAY I GO OUT OF STATE GET
THEM AND I GIVE THEM TO A FRIEND.
DOWN THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW I KNOW GUILTY OF
CONFIDE HAVE.
SHARED IT WITH THE PLAN I THINK
DOUBTS IN THERE BUT NOT JUST
POSSESSING IT MYSELF.
AND I I'M I'M ONLY ASKING THE
QUESTION I'M ASKING YOU TO FIND
AN ANSWER TODAY.
THAT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
DISCUSSED WITH THOSE WHO
MANUFACTURE CIGARETTES THE MAJOR
ON TOBACCO COMPANIES AND HOW. TO
GET THEM TO THE TABLE TO DISCUSS
THESE THINGS REALLY IMPORTANT
ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY I AGREE -- AS FAR AS
THE THE USUAL WELL I WON'T SELL
IN CALIFORNIA WERE SUCH A LARGE
ECONOMY -- THOSE ARGUMENTS WERE
USED BACK AT WITH THE AUTOMOBILE
STANDARDS THAT WERE CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA IS A MAJOR SADLY WHEN
IT COMES TO TOBACCO BECAUSE WE
KNOW IT'S AND HEALTHY.
BUT I IN IN THE EUROPEAN UNION
IS THERE ALSO A GETTING IN LINE
ON THIS SO -- MANUFACTURERS ARE
USUALLY PRETTY SMART THEY SEE
THE FUTURE AND CERTAINLY IF IT'S
BEEN PRESENTED DIRECTLY TO THEM
SO MY HOPE AND EXPECTATION IS
THAT THEY WOULD START --
CHANGING THE WAY THEY
MANUFACTURE THEIR PRODUCT AND
AGAIN.
YOU DON'T KNOW UNTIL YOU TRY AND
OF COURSE THE GOAL HERE WOULD BE
A IT CERTAINLY WOULD HELP THE
NATION AND THE WORLD IF WE COULD
GET RID OF THESE THIS HORRIFIC
POLLUTION IT REALLY -- LIKE
PLASTICS IS REALLY KINDA TAKING
OVER THE PLANET SO -- AGAIN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM WE DID
THIS WE WE BASICALLY I WANTED TO
BRING THIS BILL.
A KIND OF PLAYING OFF THE
SUCCESS WE HAD WITH THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY -- WHICH
WE WERE TOLD WOULD NEVER HAPPEN
AND SO -- BUT IT'S MY HOPE THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS ANOTHER VERY
SIGNIFICANT A PROBLEM HERE -- IN
OUR STATE IN OUR COUNTRY. FOR
TE ENVIRONMENT AND HEALTH AND
WHAT HAVE YOU BY.
TAKING ON THIS CHALLENGE WHICH I
THINK WE CAN ACCOMPLISH I'M I'M
OPTIMISTIC BASED UPON WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE PAST SO.
WITH THAT I WOULD THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
YEAH RIGHT YEAH GREAT WELL THANK
YOU SO WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
YET -- WE WILL CERTAINLY TAKE UP
YOUR BILL AND YOUR YOUR BILL OF
ENJOY THE D. PASS RECOMMENDATION
SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN THIS
AREA OF A SEASON THAT I CARE A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT AS WELL.
I'M JUST THE LOGISTICALLY.
THIS IS GOING TO JUDICIARY BUT
IS OUR TIME TO I MEAN WHAT HAS A
WORK OF THEM IT.
IT'S LIKELY THAT THERE WILL BE A
WAIVER.
OKAY OR IF NOT WE WILL TRY TO
HEAR IT.
WAS SOME KIND OF ASSISTANCE IS I
THINK IT'S BEEN.
OFF OF THE FLOOR WHAT.
I'M TOTALLY NOT SURE ABOUT I'VE
HAD ENOUGH OF JUDICIARY FOR THE
WEEK YOU KNOW.
WHERE WE'RE BACK AGAIN OKAY BUT
WE WE MAY HAVE TO COME BACK FOR
A OFF THE FLOOR HEARING?
YEAH IF IT IF WE DON'T GET A
WAIVER WILL BE WILL BE BACK OKAY
YOU CAN BE SURE WE WE VOTE
DEVELOP THE FAMILY ATMOSPHERE.
RATING IN LATE IN THE EVENING
FOR RIGHT TO SHERRY I HOPE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO BUT IF WE DO WE
WILL OKAY THANK OU THANK YOU SO
MUCH DO APPRECIATE THANK YOU FOR
THE ADVOCATES.
OKAY WELL NEXT YEAR FROM CENTER
MITCHELL.
IN CENTER MITCHELL AS YOU'RE
PRESENTING ITEM SIXTEEN IS SB.
SIX FORTY SEVEN ARE THE
COMMITTEE DOES NOT HAVE ANY
SUGGESTED AMENDS FOR YOU SENATOR --
BUT THE COMMITTEE DOES ASK FOR
YOUR PROGNOSTICATION ABOUT THE
CLIPPERS WARRIORS GAME TONIGHT.
AND WOULD LOVE TO GET YOUR YOUR
READ ON THE ON THE SITUATION OUR
HOPE IS THAT THE BILL.
WELL I THINK WE'D PREFER A
PROJECT FOR US OCCASION FIRST --
CLIPPERS ALL RIGHT THERE YOU GO --
I HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
COMPOSITION OF THE COMMITTEE
FIRST BEFORE.
RIGHT NOW ALL I HERE WAS WITH ME.
I THINK I'M SAY.
A GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT TO YOU SENATE BILL SIX
FOUR SEVEN THE SAFETY JEWELRY
ACT THE BILL AIMS TO UPDATE
CALIFORNIA'S.
METAL CONTAINING JEWELRY Là TO
BETTER REFLECT THE CURRENT AND
WIDELY ACCEPTED SCIENCE ON THE
TOXICITY OF LEAD AND CADMIUM IN
JEWELRY.
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT UPDATE
IN CALIFORNIA'S METAL CONTAINING
YOUR RELY IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AND WOMEN FROM THE
HARMFUL REST ASSOCIATE WITH LEAD
AND CADMIUM IN JEWELRY.
IT'S COMMON KNOWLEDGE THAT
EXPOSURE TO LEAD CAUSES REAL AND
PERMANENT HARM THERE ARE VOLUMES
OF STUDIES IN THE MANY SOURCES
OF LEAD EXPOSURE IN THE LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES.
WHAT IS LESS WELL KNOWN IS THAT
LEAD IS A COMMON INGREDIENT IN
JEWELRY?
AND ALSO THAT CADMIUM IS ANOTHER
TOXIC METAL COMMONLY FOUND IN
JEWELRY CUT.
COSTUME JEWELRY.
CALIFORNIA'S METAL CONTAINING
JEWELRY Là PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND WAS BASED ON
SCIENCE THAT WAS AT THAT TIME
WELL ESTABLISHED.
SINCE THEN THE SCIENCES IMPROVE
AND IT'S BECOME ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THAT CALIFORNIA'S LAW IS
OUTDATED AND INADEQUATE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANADA
THE EUROPEAN UNION AND THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION ALL ENDORSE
A MORE RIGOROUS STANDARDS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL REFLECTS A THOUGHTFUL
MEASURED UPDATE TO THE LAW THAT
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION THE
EXPOSURE TO CHILDREN AND ADULTS
THE IMPACT ON THE INDUSTRY IN
THE FEASIBILITY OF THE LIMITS.
SB SIX FORTY SEVEN STRENGTHENS
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD AND CADMIUM
JOE WE LOST BY ESTABLISHING
SCIENCE BACK STANDARDS THAT HAVE
DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS IN BOTH
NORTH AMERICA AND EUROPE. ONE
THIS BILL ADOPTS THE FEDERAL
STANDARD FOR LEAD IN CHILDREN'S
JEWELRY WHICH IS ONE HUNDRED
PARTS PER MILLION.
ESTABLISHES CADMIUM STANDARD FOR
PAINT SURFACE COATING OF
CHILDREN'S JORI PURSUANT TO THE
ASTM INTERNATIONAL STANDARD
WHICH IS LESS THAN.
SEVENTY FIVE PARTS PER MILLION.
IT AMEND THE DEFINITION OF
CHILDREN CHILDREN FIORI TO
CONFORM WITH CANADA'S DEFINITION
WHICH IS FIFTEEN YEARS OF AGE
AND YOUNGER.
AND FINALLY THE APPLIES THE
EUROPEAN UNION LEADS ALWAYS
FOUNDED OF LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION FOR
ADULT JEWELRY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY IS MORRELL.
DE BERNARDO REPRESENTING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFICE.
AND HERE AND THROUGH THE LITTLE
WHO WAS WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP WAS ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARIO DIBERNARDO I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOBBY ABBAS THERE IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THE HEALTH EFFECTS OF LEAD AND
CADMIUM ARE WELL DOCUMENTED.
AND WE KNOW THAT -- CHEAP
JEWELRY SUCH AS COSTUME JEWELRY
AND CHILDREN'S JULIE I'VE BEEN
KNOWN TO CONTAIN LEAD AND
CADMIUM.
AND THESE TOXIC METALS COULD
MIGRATE INTO A PERSON'S BLOOD
SYSTEM IF THEY ARE MOUTH OR
INGESTED.
SO FOR CHILDREN -- THEY CLEARLY
CAN DEMONSTRATE ANYONE WHO'S A
PARENT KNOWS THAT CHILDREN.
ARE CAPABLE OF FREQUENTLY
CHEWING ON THEIR OWN CHILDREN'S
REALLY OR THEIR PARENTS JEWELRY
THEY'RE ALSO STUDIES THAT SHOW
THAT -- ADULT TO A VISUALLY NOW
THEIR JEWELRY SHOW HIGHER LEVELS
OF BLOOD LEAD LEVELS.
AND I MEAN IN PARTICULAR FOR
WOMEN'S HEALTH -- THEIR IMPACTS
ON REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH THERE ARE
STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT IT COULD
LEAD -- TO LEAD EXPOSURE CAN
LEAD TO EARLY MENOPAUSE OR
HEALTH ISSUES POST MENOPAUSE.
AND SO THESE ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES AND MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS -- SEEING THE FLOW
OF ESPECIALLY FROM CHINA --
CHEAP JEWELRY THAT HAS HIGH
LEVELS OF LEAD AND CADMIUM
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS HAVE
ADOPTED STANDARDS TO REGULATE
THIS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BROUGHT --
THE CASE AGAINST SEVERAL JEWELRY --
RETAILERS MANUFACTURERS -- TWO
DECADES AGO.
AND THAT CASE LED TO THE STATE
ADOPTING ITS CURRENT STANDARDS
FOR CHILDREN AND ADULTS JEWELRY
STANDARDS -- SUBSEQUENTLY BASED
ON STUDIES AND MORE INFORMATION
THE US CONGRESS CANADA IN THE E.
U. ADOPTED STANDARDS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY MANY WAYS STRICTER THAN
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT IT
LOOS AT THOSE STUDIES AND
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS OF
FEDERAL STANDARDS AND
INCORPORATES MANY OF THOSE
STANDARDS INTO CALIFORNIA'S LAW
TO UPDATE IT.
SO THAT WE ARE HAVING AS MUCH
PROTECTION HERE AS CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ARE IN OTHER AREAS OF
NORTH AMERICA AND EUROPE.
SO WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR A HELLO I'M SUSAN LITTLE WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THE
BILL ALONG WITH THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
JUST WANT TO REMIND THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE'VE DONE
QUITE A BIT OF WORK IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS TO REDUCE OF LET X.
CHILLS CHILDHOOD LEAD EXPOSURE.
AND PARTICULARLY ENVIRONMENT
WORKING GROUP BRAND OF A WHOLE
SERIES OF BILLS LAST YEAR.
LAST SESSION REGARDING THIS
ISSUE AND WANTED TO SET.
TO ALSO.
REMIND FOLKS THAT JEWELRY IS
STILL CONSIDERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH BE
ONE OF AT CHILDREN'S ACCESS TO
GE TO LET A JURY IS ONE OF THE
MAIN.
RISK FACTORS THAT PEDIATRICIANS
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHEN DECIDING
WHETHER NOT TO LEAD TEST
CHILDREN THIS IS STILL A
DOCUMENTED WELL KNOWN --
EXPOSURE PATH THAT CHILDREN HAVE --
IN REGARDS TO LEAD AND THIS IS
THIS BILL IS AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
JUST GET RID OF THAT EXPOSURE
PATH AND MAKE SURE THAT CHILDREN
DON'T HAVE ACCESS. TO LET A JURY
IN THE HOME -- OR THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWELRY THAT WILL
CAUGHT THAT WILL CAUSE THEM HARM --
I ALSO WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT THE CENTERS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAVE
RECENTLY DONE SOME TESTING OF
JEWELRY.
AND FOUND A FROM THAT THEY
GATHER FROM MAJOR DEPARTMENT
STORES AND AND RETAILERS NAY
FOUND THAT THE MAJORITY OF THEM.
SHE 80% WERE ABLE TO MEET THE
STANDARDS OF THIS BILL.
AND SO WE THINK THAT'S VERY
REASONABLE TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THIS IN THIS REGARDS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S
HEAR FROM OTHER FOLKS WANT TO
WEIGH IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I'M DOCTOR MONA PATEL A
PRACTICING PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
RENDON DAWSON IN SUPPORT OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
HEALTH REPORTER WITH SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THE SEVENTH FLEET BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JUST NONE FOR THE LOCAL IN
BRANCH Là HEALTH DIRECTORS IN
SUPPORT WE SUPPORTED THE
ORIGINAL BILL MANY YEARS AGO AND
WE GLAD TO SEE THIS UPDATE THANK
YOU.
AND ONE FINAL JUST THAT CENTERS
FOR A TUESDAY THE CLEAN WATER
ACTION IS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
GREAT WELL OUR THE IT'S OVER SEC.
OTHER OPPOSITION ANY FOLKS ONE
WAYS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY IRA AND IT WAS IN THE
RESTAURANT POSITION -- OKAY TO
THE ITEMS BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS SPOTS --
THEN I WOULD ASK [inaudible]
SOME.
THE STAFF REPORT [inaudible]
FIVE SAID.
LEAD IN CANTON -- EXPOSURE
CANNOT HAPPEN FROM SKIN.
THROUGH THE SKIN IT'S IT'S GOT
TO BE IN THE MOUTH WAS THE
CANADIAN STUDY OR THE EUROPEAN
STUDY.
SHOW THAT THE TWEENS HAVE THIS
PROPENSITY TO PUT.
THIS JEWELRY INTO THEIR MOUTH
AND THAT'S WHY THEY MOVED TO
STANDARDS OF FIFTEEN YEARS.
I MEAN I KNOW THERE'S A NERVOUS
CROWD THE SO THE CANADIAN.
REGULATIONS.
FOCUS ON THE MARKETING
DEMOGRAPHIC -- FOR TWEENS AND
YOUNG TEENS -- THE FEDERAL
STANDARD THE US CUT BACK THE
CONGRESS ADOPTED AND IN THE
UNITED STATES HAS -- JURIES --
CHILDREN'S JEWELRY THRESHOLD OF
AGE TWELVE SO CAñADA LOOKED AT
THE U. S. STANDARD OF AGE.
TWELVE BUT FOUND THAT THE SINCE
THERE IS THIS BUTSINCE THE
INDUSTRY MARKETS TO THIS TWEEN
YOUNG TEAM GROUP THAT RANGES
BETWEEN. TEN AND FOURTEEN BE
EASIER TO DECIPHER WHAT IS
INTENDED. FOR THE AGE GROUP THAT
THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS WERE
ADOPTED BY -- BY FOLLOWING THE
INDUSTRY STANDARD AND LOOKING AT
THEIR HARD LINE OR THEIR YOU
THEIR MARKETING PRACTICES OF
TARGETING PEOPLE UNDER.
FIFTEEN AND THAT MAKES IT EASIER
FOR ENFORCEMENT -- A LITIGATOR
BOB UP A PLAINTIFF.
COULD MORE EASILY PROVE THAT.
JEWELRY IS INTENDED FOR THE
TWEEN OR YOUNG TEEN MARKET BASED
ON THE MARKETING AND AN
INFORMATION LIKE THAT -- RATHER
THAN JUST.
A NUMBER THAT DOESN'T NEATLY FIT
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY'S
MARKETING'S.
RIGHT IN WITH IT BESIDES THE
MARKETING THAT MAKES SENSE WAS
THERE SOMETHING ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE GO THROUGH LIFE PUTTING
STUFF IN THEIR MOUTH SO I JUST
PUT THAT OUT THERE BUT IS IT IS
IT THE THE TWEENS THAT WHERE THE
JEWELRY THAT THEY'RE NERVOUS.
NERVOUS SIR I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY SAY JUST -- I GUESS I THINK
THIS.
MORE INCLINED TO PULL IT UP AND
JUST AND AND SUCK ON IT OR DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT I GUESS WAS
THERE -- OTHER THAN THE MARK THE
TARGET OF THE POPULATION TO WEAR
THE JEWELRY WHICH IS SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS AGE BRACKET THAT SAID
THAT THE YOU KNOW HAVE OFF A
PROPENSITY LIKE A THREE YEAR OLD
BUT STUFF IN THEIR MOUTH.
I WILL THERE ARE STUDIES THAT
THAT FOCUS ON OR INCLUDE --
OBSERVATIONS ON ADULTS MAPPING
TOOL OR A AND SO I MEAN.
THERE IS CERTAINLY WITH CHILDREN --
AND WHERE YOU DRAW THAT LINE IS
UP FOR DEBATE AND AS THERE'S A
SPLIT IN JURISDICTION.
CHILDREN HAVE THE DAY ARE ARE
CONTINUING TO DEVELOP AND SO
THAT'S WHY -- THERE ARE
HEIGHTENED STANDARDS FOR
CHILDREN WHO ARE DEVELOPING AND
CERTAINLY CHILDREN THAT.
ARE YOU KNOW IN THEIR YOUNG
TWEENS AND YOUNG TEENS ARE ARE
CONTINUING TO DEVELOP SO -- SO
THAT THE THE INFORMATION
SUPPORTS THAT.
IF YOU WANT THE MOST PROTECTIVE
STANDARD FOR THOSE THAT ARE.
ARE DEVELOPING STILL THE FEW
MOVING BEING A BEYOND FIVE AND
SIX YEAR OLDS AND WE'LL GET AGO
AT LEAST THE FEDERAL STANDARDS
TWELVE THE CANADIANS YOU SEE AND
THIS IS THE MARKETING THE
TARGETING.
I IT MORE ELASTIC IF I HAD ONE
MORE THING SO IF YOU GO TO
MACY'S.
RIGHT DOWN THE STREET HERE AND
GO TO THEIR COSTUME JEWELRY
DISPLAY ON A COUNTER.
THE LOOK THE JEWELERY TYPICALLY
INCLUDES A LABEL THAT SAYS NOT
INTENDED FOR TWELVE AND UNDER
AND THE U. S. AND CHILDREN.
FIFTEEN UNDER IN CANADA AND SO
THE INDUSTRY'S ALREADY ADAPTING
TO THAT FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
STANDARD IT'S AN ODD LABEL TO
SUGGEST THAT US CHILDREN ARE
SOMEHOW DIFFERENT THE CANADIAN
CHILDREN.
THIS BRINGS THIS WOULD BRING IT
IN LINE WITH THE PRACTICE THAT
THE IN THE OBSERVING.
WELL I HAVE A SIX MONTH OLD WHO
JUST.
EVERYTHING YOU DO EVERYTHING
IT'S WITHIN HIS REACH WILL WILL
AND FIND ITS WINDOWS MOUTH SO
I'M I'M INDIVIDUAL FINEST AS
WOMEN DO WHEN WHEN WERE HOLED UP.
FOR OUR NEXT ALL THE TIME THE
GLASSES IN AS A YOUNG AS
ROADMASTER AS RECEIVING THE
FIRST THING THEY DO WITH THE
GOLDEN VALLEY RIGHT.
YEP.
YEAH I HAVE A VIDEO OF IT HERE.
ALL RIGHT SO -- SO I'M I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL -- AND
YOU KNOW IF THERE'S ANY THAT
WITH A FREE QUESTIONS WELL WE WE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM COULD YOU
TELL US ABOUT YOUR WONDERFUL PAN.
YES IT'S ZORA NEALE HURSTON --
COOL.
WONDERFUL.
WHILE IT'S COSMETIC I DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S LEAD IN IT BUT ARE
NOT GOING TO PUT IT IN MY MOUTH
ALL RIGHT WILL KEEP.
OVER FIFTEEN WILL GIVE THE BABY
AWAY FROM YOUR TO ITSELF ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU SO WE DON'T
QUORUM YET BUT WE WILL -- WILL
CERTAINLY TO GET THIS BILL IT
DOES ENJOY IT DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION FROM THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND THANK YOU FOR TAKING ORDERS
REPORT ISSUE.
THANK YOU ALSO PLEASE SEND OUR
THANKS TO THE AG -- FOR FOR HIS
WORK IN THIS AREA [inaudible]
TO GREAT.
I'M JUST REMEMBER SENDO WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A RECESS AT NOON.
FOR ONE HOUR BOB HOPE WE MADE
YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS WE PROBABLY
WON'T BE FINISHED WITH IT AND
THE BY THEM WITH ALL THE COME
BACK AFTER THAT AT ONE I SB FOR
THE MCGUIRE BILL HAS BEEN PULLED.
FROM THIS COMMITTEE THEY'VE
WORKED OUT SOME SORT OF DEAL
WITH -- CENTER WIENER ON SB
FIFTY AND THAT'S BEFORE TAX
CENTER WIENER IS CURRENTLY
PRESENTING THAT BILL.
OVER IN -- SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE AS WE SPEAK
[inaudible]
SO I'M.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING ISSUE AS
WELL AND THEN ARE THERE THREE
ITEMS ON CONSENT ITEMS.
SEVEN ITEM FIFTEEN AND I'M
TWENTY ONE SUCH AS BEFORE --
FIVE SB SIX THIRTY THREE AND I
SPEAK SEVEN TWENTY SIX OF YOUR
HERE FOR EITHER ANY OF THOSE
BILLS AND THOSE ARE ON CONSENT
AND SO.
WE WILL BE HAVING.
A FORMAL HEARING ON THOSE BILLS
THAT'S FOUR OH FIVE ARCHULETA
SIX THIRTY THREE STERN AND SEVEN
TWENTY SIX CABALLERO.
OKAY I SEE CENTER GALGIANI HAS
ARRIVED AND SHE'S GOING TO BE
PRESENT.
ITEM FOURTEEN YOUR PACKETS THAT
IS SB.
SIX THIRTY TWO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WILDFIRES ARE
A MAJOR THREAT IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY IN RECENT YEARS AS
THE LANDSCAPE RESPONSE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DECADES OF
FIRE SUPPRESSION. TWELVE YEARS
AGO THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION PROPOSED A
PROGRAMMATIC ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT FOR A VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAM AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE FIRE PREVENTION
STRATEGY.
THE KEY OBJECTIVES OF THE
PROGRAM WERE TO PREVENT LOSS OF
LIVES AND PROPERTY.
REDUCE FIRE SUPPRESSION COSTS
AND PROTECT NATURAL RESOURCES
FROM DAMAGING WILDFIRE THROUGH
THE USE OF APPROPRIATE
VEGETATION TREATMENTS.
I'M THERE FOR ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS TO SB SIX THIRTY TO
THAT DIRECT THE CAL VEGETATION
TREATMENT.
PROGRAM TO BE COMPLETED AND
CERTIFIED NO LATER THAN JUNE
THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY MY STAFF AND THE
SPONSOR HAVE WORKED WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THIS BILL AND
I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS.
AND WE APPRECIATE -- YOUR
SUGGESTION OF AMENDMENTS TO SB
SIX THIRTY TWO THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO MOVE FORWARD AND ENSURE
THAT THERE'S A PROGRAMMATIC E.
I. R.. FOR VEGETATION TREATMENT.
AS AMENDED THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET ITS GOALS OF
TREATING A HALF MILLION ACRES OF
NON FEDERAL LAND EACH YEAR.
AND PREVENT AND MINIMIZE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AS WELL
AS SAVING LIVES WITH ME TODAY
ARE MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA'S TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE
VOTE.
PHONE RECORDS.
THANK YOU EVAN CALIFORNIA HAS
COMMITTED TO A PROGRAM OF
REDUCING WILDFIRE FUEL LOAD IN
ORDER TO REDUCE FIRE RISK.
AND PROTECT LIVES AND PROPERTY.
LAST YEAR IN SB NINE A ONE THE
LEGISLATURE SAID IT WANTED TO
SPEND TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
ON FORCE MANAGEMENT PROJECTS.
AT THE BORDER FOR STREET
RECENTLY RESTARTED A PUBLIC
PROCESS TO DEVELOP A VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAMMATIC THE I. R. --
THIS WITH THE HELP OF THESE
VARIOUS PROJECTS OF FOR FIRE
PREVENTION.
A TO HAVE A CONSISTENT
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS.
WHEN THE DOCUMENT THAT THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY IS WORKING ON WHEN
IT IS CERTIFIED SPECIFIC
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROJECTS
WILL BE ABLE TO TEAR OFF?
A THAT HE AYE ARE IN THERE --
ANALYSIS THIS REDUCE COST AND
TIME WHILE ENSURING THAT ALL
ENVIRONMENTAL RULES AND
REGULATIONS ARE APPLIED.
WHEN WE STARTED WORK ON THIS
LEGISLATION WE WANTED TO SEE THE
ER DOCTOR?
FAR TREATMENT PROJECTS MOVE
FORWARD.
SO WE INCLUDED LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF FOR PROJECTS
THAT WERE INITIATED AFTER THE E.
I. R. WAS CERTIFIED.
BUT BEFORE ALL LEGAL CHALLENGES
WERE EXHAUSTED.
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
COMMITTEE STAFF THE STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR.
WE CAME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
IT WOULD BE BETTER TO TAKE ONE
STEP AT A TIME.
BEFORE LEAPFROGGING TO
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
LET'S GET THE VTP AYE ARE
ADOPTED AND CERTIFIED. TO THAT
END WE SUPPORT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THE USE THIS BILL
REQUIRE THE BOARD OF FORESTRY TO
ADOPT AND CERTIFY.
THE VTP AYE ARE BY JUNE OF NEXT
YEAR [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANKSFOR
THE WORK AND WE HAD QUITE AN
INTERACTION -- SHAPE OF THAT --
YOUR THOUGHTFUL APPROACH SO OF
FOLKS WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN COMMITTEE ABOUT TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND MEN WOMEN WORKING
IN THE INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANDREA HOW A SIERRA PACIFIC
INDUSTRIES WE SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOHN ANDERSON WITH MENACING
KNOWN HUMBLED REDWOOD COMPANIES --
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
YES -- CAMP I'M REPRESENT FORCE
MANNERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FORSTER'S
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
CHRIS NOW WITH THE CIVIL JUSTICE
SOCIAIS TION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE PRESS.
YOU KNOW WHEN.
OKAY ALL RIGHT YOU CAN DO TO YOU
KNOW WHY NOT ALL RIGHT WHY DON'T
WE OKAY SO LET'S SEE IF IS ANY
OPPOSITION PEOPLE WONDER IS
CONCERNED.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
YOUR MEMBERSHIP OVER THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL VERY HAPPY TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION THE BILL
BASED ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT
OTHERS COMMITTED TO THANK SOME.
SENATE ALSO SEE A CALIFORNIA
WILL WE WILL ALSO BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION BASED OFF WITHIN
MINUTES.
THANK YOU.
BRENDA WITH YOU AT THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE -- FOR THE AMENDMENTS
WERE HAPPY TO REMOVE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
CRAP GOOD GOOD THANK YOU THANK
YOU EVERYBODY -- II THINK THIS
WILL THIS WILL BE THE START OF A
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW WE HANDLE.
A VERY DIFFICULT CHALLENGE THAT
WE HAVE AS A STATE SO.
OKAY I ANY FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTS ARE FOLKS WANT TO WIN.
SO WE'LL BRING THE THE ITEM BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE -- QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS COMMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
OKAY I THANK YOU WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING CLOSELY WITH YOU MOVING
FORWARD ON THIS -- IMPORTANT
ISSUE IT WE DON'T OF A QUORUM
YET BUT WE WILL CERTAINLY TAKE
UP THE BILL.
WHEN WE DO?
YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOU TO YOU
BOTH [inaudible]
FOR FLEXIBILITY [inaudible]
I KNOW [inaudible]
APPARENTLY SKINNER
THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING.
I JUST TEXTED YOU [inaudible]
YES.
I KNOW TOO MUCH THIS IS THIS IS.
NO NO WAY TO RUN A I SOMETHING
WHAT ARE WE RUNNING HERE ALL
RIGHT SO -- CENTER BOARD THIS
WEEK WE DO APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE -- TO PRESENT ITEM
SEVENTEEN IN YOUR AGENDA IS
MEMBERS THIS IS SB.
SIX FIFTY NINE AND THE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN -- WHEN READY --
MEANS THANK YOU -- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS BILL
TODAY -- SENATE BILL -- SIX FIVE
NINE HAS CERTAINLY HAD DOES SOME
AMENDMENTS WERE -- VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
AND HAVE INDEED ACCEPTED THEM.
AND SIX FIVE NINE ITS FORM IT
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE COURT TO
AWARD ATTORNEYS FEES TO A
PREVAILING PARTY.
THAT IS A RESPOND IN OR REAL
PARTY IN INTEREST WHEN THE COURT
FINDS THE PETITIONER USED
ACTIONS.
TACTICS ARE CLAIMS MADE ON
REASONABLY OR IN BAD FAITH THAT
ARE FRIVOLOUS OR INTENT TO CAUSE
UNNECESSARILY.
UNNECESSARY DELAY.
THIS LANGUAGE OF PROVIDE FOR A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT STANDARD FOR
AWARDING ATTORNEY'S FEES FOR
THOSE INFILL HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS.
ARE THAN WHAT IS CURRENTLY
PROVIDED FOR IN EXISTING LAW.
AS WE ALL AWARE CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCING HOUSING CRISIS MANY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS STRUGGLED
TO FIND AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS AND A
BEARING THE BURDEN OF INCREASING
CONSTRUCTION IN LITIGATION COSTS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY PROJECTS ARE
FORCED TO DELAY CONSTRUCTION IN
BATTLE IN COURT WHEN A LAWSUIT
IS FILED UNDER SEEK WHAT.
IN THE GOVERNOR STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS WE HEARD HIS CALL.
FOR A SEEK WORK REFORM.
THIS LEGISLATION IS NOT INTENDED
TO DISCOURAGE GROUPS OR CREATE A
CHILLING EFFECT. TO PREVENT
LEGITIMATE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS GOING TO BE VERY CLEAR
ON THAT.
IT IS NOT TO CREATE A CHILLING
EFFECT IN IN NO WAY -- MODIFIES
SYKORA.
INSTEAD OF THIS REQUIRES THAT
THE COURT OR AUTHORIZED THE
COURTS TO WARD REASONABLE
ATTORNEY'S FEES. TO THE
PREVAILING PROJECT APPLICANT IN%
SCENARIOS WERE UNDER
REASONABLENESS AND BAD FAITH ARE
FOUND TO EXIST BY THE COURT.
BY ENSURING ALL PARTIES ARE
ACTING IN GOOD FAITH THE STATE
CAN HELP CURB THE NUMBER OF
LAWSUITS THAT HOLD THAT HOLD
INFILL HOUSING PROJECTS.
IN BECAUSE COSTS TO SKYROCKET.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB.
SIX FIVE NINE OKAY SO TO CLARIFY.
WHERE WE AT WITH THE IMMENSE I
LEAVE WITH ACCEPTED THE FACT
THAT THERE'S AUTHORIZES OR NO
LONGER REQUIRING?
YEAH NO LONGER REQUIRING WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOU AND
YOUR STAFFS -- WORK ON THIS --
WE WE THINK IT MAKES A BETTER --
TO AUTHORIZE HAS DEFINITELY
REPLACE REQUIRED OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO VERY SIGNIFICANT -- BUT STILL
MEANINGFUL BILL BUT SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE FOR THE FOLKS WHO WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT OKAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR FOLKS WANTED [inaudible]
SPEAKING SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY HERE'S LATEST [inaudible]
FOR RIGHT BUT THIS IS OUR THIS
IS WHAT WE PERCENT OKAY WITH IT
WITH WITH MINOR EDITS
[inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
THIS.
WITH THE DIFFERENCE.
WE HAD A ARE WE ARE WE DO WE AS
YOU REQUESTED CERTAINLY TOOK
AWAY OUR CLAIMS OKAY YEAH THAT'S
FINE OKAY AND THOSE ARE AT SEVEN
YEP THAT'S TO AUTHORIZED.
AUTHORIZED FROM WHAT FROM
REQUIRE RIGHT OKAY PERFECT YET
MAKES SENSE.
OKAY THAT'LL MAKE SENSE.
I FOLKS YOU WANT TO SPEAK IS
SUPPORTED ON OKAY [inaudible]
YES.
FOLKS YOU WANNA RAISE OPPOSITION
OR CONCERNS.
YOU UNDERSTAND IT THERE'S NO
LONGER REQUIRE.
THE AWARDING OF FEES.
I DO OKAY [inaudible]
GOV I'M.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RISK
MANY BRENDA WIKI WITH THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
COMMITTEE INTO THE OUT THERE FOR
FOR THE AMENDMENTS -- I THINK
THERE ARE TREMENDOUS IMPROVEMENT --
I NEVER.
IN ANY ITERATION OF THIS BILL
THOUGHT THAT IT WAS PARTICULARLY
APPLICABLE TO THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY OTHER.
LAW FIRM TYPE -- ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE ABLE TO ASSESS THEIR AT
THAT HAVE A ORGANIZATIONAL
MANDATE. TO TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ABLE TO FULLY
ASSESS THEIR CASES.
OUR CONCERN IS ALWAYS THAT THIS
WAS PROBABLY GOING TO BE THE
MOST DISRUPTIVE FOR AND MOST --
DISSUADING TO THE LOCAL.
LOCAL GROUPS TO THE SMALL -- TO
THE TO THE LOCAL.
LANDOWNERS WERE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND AND THE SMALLER GROUPS IN
THE CITIES AND AND LOCATIONS
WHERE THESE -- WHERE WHERE THE
SEATS MIGHT BE BROUGHT THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
THE MOST -- DISSUADED BY THE
THREAT OF HAVING THE
REPERCUSSIONS THAT WERE
INITIALLY STATED I FEEL LIKE
SOME OF THAT MESSAGES STILL EVEN
WITH STILL
CARRIED INTO THIS BILL AGAIN.
NOT FOR MY ORGANIZATION OR THE
OR THE IT'S CALLED THOáT THE
LARGER LEGAL -- ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS BUT DEFINITELY
STILL OF THE MESSAGE STILL
CARRIES -- TO THE SMALLER
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP COMMUNITY
GROUPS THAT STILL MIGHT WANT TO
BRING THE USE THAT MIGHT NOT
FULLY UNDERSTAND.
ALL THE REPERCUSSIONS IN THE
LIMITATIONS ON THIS BILL AND
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE CAUTION I
WOULD STILL LIKE TO BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IT DOESN'T ZERO CALIFORNIA WILL
HONOR SOME OF THE COMMENTS OF
CVD -- WERE ALSO KIND OF
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BRIGHT LINE
ROLLED OUT OF INFILL DEVELOPMENT
INFILL DEVELOPMENT AND STODDEN
BARMAN REPERCUSSIONS AND EVEN
THOUGH -- SOME MAY THINK THAT
IT'S A MERITORIOUS TO BRING
LITIGATION AGAINST INFO
DEVELOPMENT HOLISTICALLY -- THEY
STILL HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL
REPERCUSSIONS THAT -- MIGHT NOT
HAVE TO GO THROUGH AN EXEMPTION
PROCESS AND SO.
COMMUNITY SMALL COMMUNITY GROUPS
CAN BRING THOSE CASES
MERITORIOUS LEE AND STILL NOT
UNDERSTAND THE REPERCUSSIONS OF
NECESSARILY HAVING TO BRING
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS -- EVEN HEN
THERE ARE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT
REPERCUSSIONS ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS AND IF OF THIS ONE IF THE
SENATOR WANTS TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE EFFECT OF
THOSE IT ATTORNEY FEES STATUTES
ALREADY THEN THAT SHOULD BE IT
BUT WE DON'T THINK SB SIX FIVE
NINE IS NECESSARY.
TO KIND OF A BRING THAT
CONVERSATION FORWARD THANK YOU
FOR THAT YEAH.
WAS THERE A MERRILL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE POSITION OF WITH THIS
BILL AND IN PRINT CURRENTLY --
AND WILL BE REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS BUT STILL HAVE SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS GIVE.
THE ATTACKER THE CONSUMER DURING
THE CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL IMPRINT BUT WE'LL TAKE
A LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS AND GET
BACK TO MEMBERSHIP THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S ALAN LEVINE --
REPRESENT BECAUSE ACTION GROUP
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I JUST WANNA REMIND THE SENATORS
THAT SEQUOIA IS A PROCESS THAT
IS.
DESIGNED TO BRING THE PUBLIC AND
TO INFORM DECISION MAKING
PROCESS.
IF A MEMBER OR A GROUP IN THE
PUBLIC.
SEIZE THE SPECTER.
OF POTENTIAL HI THE HIGH COST OF
LOSING LITIGATION THEY WILL BE
THIS WAY THAT FROM TRYING TO
ENFORCE A PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
IN CALIFORNIA SO I'D LIKE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
I KNOW I WILL SAY I MEAN THE THE
YOU KNOW THE DID EVERYTHING
UNDER THIS BILL IT DOESN'T JUST
AWARD FEES.
BECAUSE YOU LOSE ARE YOU THERE
HAS TO BE A PRETTY HIGH FINDING
BY THE JUDGE -- THE MERE THOUGHT
OF HAVING TO PAY THOSE COSTS
WILL TO SCARE PEOPLE OUT OF
PARTICIPANTS.
OKAY I THE ITEM IS NOW BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE -- FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THOUGHTS EIGHT I DO
HAVE ONE LOGISTICAL QUESTION ON
YOU WE JUST SEVERED THROUGH YOU
KNOW A LATE NIGHT AT JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE I'M.
WHAT THE THIS IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY?
WITH THE IMMENSE I'M.
WHAT'S LOGISTICALLY RELIGIOUSLY
HAPPENS IS THEY'RE GONNA I WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE A GO OFF THE FLOOR
FOR IT JUDICIARY. TO GET THIS
PASS UP THIS WEEK OR YEAH.
SO WE CAN DO IT TUESDAY NEXT
WEEK I UNDERSTAND OKAY ALL RIGHT.
UNDERSTAND OKAY QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AS CENTER CASKEY.
I MONTH I'M LOOKING AT THE STAFF
REPORT THAT AT TALKED ABOUT THE
DOESN'T HAVE THE WORD CLAIM
SENATE -- THAT'S ADDED.
EDUCATE ME ON BOND WHAT
ADDITIONAL -- PARAMETERS THAT
THE COKE COURT COULD LOOK AT TO
AWARD ATTORNEY FEES UNDER JUST
THE CLAIMS NOT A ACTION OR
TACTIC.
WELL I I THINK I THINK THE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
TAKE A STEP BACK IN AND MAKE
CERTAIN THAT -- THE MESSAGE IS
CLEAR THAT THIS DOES NOT.
IS NOT DESIGNED TO DISSUADE --
SEE WHAT CHALLENGES -- ON THE
MERITS AT ALL -- WE DON'T WANT
THE LITTLE GUY TO HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME.
IF IF -- IF YOU'RE SHE WERE TO
BRING OR AN INSTITUTION WHERE TO
BRING -- A CAUSE OF ACTION -- OR
CLAIM -- ON UNDER -- SOME SORT
OF SECRET CHALLENGE.
I THINK THE IDEA IS SOMETIMES IT
IS BEEN LOOKED UPON AS A TOOL --
TO EXTRACT CONCESSIONS.
OUR WITH THE THREAT OF DELAY
TACTICS IN JUST THE THE MERE
THREAT OF OF OF SECRET CHALLENGE
CAN SOMETIMES -- STOP PROJECTS
IN THEIR TRACKS.
I THINK THE IDEA THOUGH IT IS.
WE DON'T WANT TO DISCOURAGE
MERITORIOUS CLAIMS IN THE BAR AS
CHAIRMAN INDICATED IS SO SO HIGH.
FOR A JUDGE TO DETERMINE THAT
SOMETHING IS.
IN BAD FAITH OR COMPLETELY
WITHOUT MERIT BUT YOUR YOUR
QUESTION ON CLAIMS.
THE WEATHER ITS TACTICS OR ITS
ITS ITS CLAIMS IF YOU'RE
BRINGING SOMETHING THAT IS
WHOLLY ON RELATED -- TO A
PARTICULAR SEQUEL ACTION -- I
MAYBE IT YOU KNOW I'M JUST
THROWING OUT AS HYPOTHETICAL YOU
KNOW WHAT TITLE NINE ACTION FOR
EXAMPLE -- HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE UNDERLYING LAND USE
ISSUE OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT IT
HAS ABSOLUTELY NO LEGAL
SUBSTANCE WHATSOEVER BUT GET IT
WILL FORCE.
THE RESPONDENT ON TO ENCOURAGE
TO ORDER LEGAL COSTS -- THROUGH
REPRESENTATION AND TAXPAYERS
HAVING TO HAVE COURT SYSTEMS --
HANDLE THIS TYPE OF OVERHEAD SO
I THINK IT WAS A VERY FAIR AND
BALANCED WAY THAT.
IT LOOKED ALLOWS PEOPLE TO MOVE
FORWARD -- WITH SEQUEL BECAUSE
IT IS WE WANT TO PROTECT SEQUEL
DON'T GET ME WRONG WE WANT TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF SICK
WHEN THE PURPOSE.
WE JUST WANT TO FIGURE OUT IF
THERE'S WAYS THAT -- WE CAN
IMPROVE THE PROCESS.
YEAH I MEAN FOR BETTER FOR WORSE
SEEK WAYS YOU'RE ONLY
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IS TO GO
TO COURT SO WE AND WE SOMETIMES
WE FORGET THAT BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE OTHER MECHANISMS
AND IN.
THE I PLAINTIFF MAY BE
UNSATISFIED WITH THE PROCESS
THAT THE LEAD LEAD AGENCY THE
LOCAL AGENCY USED IN THE IN THE
IN PROCESSING OF OUT OF IT AND
THEY HAVE A CLAIM.
THAT MAY BE A PROPERTY RIGHT OR
WHATEVER THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY'RE RELYING ON THAT TO FEEL
THEIR ADVERSELY AFFECT WHICH IS
DIFFERENT FROM.
YOU KNOW AND ACTION OR AS A
TACTIC THE DAY THE DAY MAY USE
SO WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S IT.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
IT'S USUALLY A CLAIM MEANS IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I YOU KNOW IT'S
PHYSICAL OR ITS ITS ACTUAL
AFFECT.
IN MONETARILY COULD AFFECT ME.
I GUESS THE NEXT QUESTION I HAVE
IS THAT CAUSING UNNECESSARY
DELAYS.
I GUESS SOME DELAYS ARE
NECESSARY SUMMER UNNECESSARY BUT
THIS IS AND REASONABLE DELAY.
TELL ME YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THAT AT THE CHANGE ROM A
NECESSARY TO AND REASONABLE I
THINK WE WANT TO EMPOWER THE
COURTS ARE IN A SITUATION LIKE
THIS.
AND THE JUDGE HERE SHE WILL BE
IN A POSITION TO DETERMINE ON AT
BEST WHAT IS A REASONABLE AN
UNREASONABLE IN FACT THAT'S
ALREADY CODIFIED -- IN DIFFERENT
FORMS THROUGH DISCRETION GRANTS
TO JUDGE IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM SO
INHERENTLY IT ALREADY EXISTS.
I THINK WHAT WE WANTED TO DO WAS
WE WANTED TO TAKE.
UP AN ALREADY EXISTING -- BODY
OF LAW.
IN A RIGHT FOR ATTORNEYS FEES
THAT ALREADY EXIST AND PUT IT
ESPECIALLY IN THE CONTEXT.
OF INFILL HOUSING TO IMPROVE THE
PROCESS THAT SOMETIMES GETS --
SLOW DOWN -- ON REASONABLY.
AND I THINK IF THERE ARE
MERITORIOUS CLAIMS AS DETERMINED
BY A JUDGE -- OR THE THE THE
COURT.
THOSE ABSOLUTELY ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH WE DON'T WANT TO STOP.
BY -- ACTIONS THAT HAVE -- YOU
KNOW DEGREES OF MERIT IT'S THE
ONES THAT HAVE. ZERO MERIT THAT
ARE DESIGNED ONLY TO EXTRACT
CONCESSIONS THAT ARE DESIGNED --
TO TO TO HOBBLE A PROJECT
WITHOUT LEGAL BASIS.
WELL THAT WOULD BE ZERO MERRICK
WITH WITH SEEMS TO ME TO BE
UNNECESSARY YES THAT WOULD BE
IT'S IT'S NOT ASSERT
UNREASONABLE MAY HAVE. 10% MERIT
128% MERIT SORT OF SEEMS --
OUTLANDISH FOR SOME PEOPLE OF AN
INFILL PROPONENT BUT IT'S IT'S A
IT'S A HIGHER LEVEL AND AND LESS
I'M MISUNDERSTANDING THE
UNNECESSARY IN AND REASONABLE
RIGHT SO THAT TIGHTENS IT UP A
LITTLE -- I I'D BE WILLING TO
WORK WITH YOU IF YOU FEEL THAT --
YOU WOULD PREFER UNNECESSARY --
INSTEAD OF ON REASONABLE -- I'D
DEFINITELY BE WILLING TO WORK
WITH YOU TO TO ADVANCES ALONG
THE PROCESS I THINK THE THE
FOLKS SPOKE OUT ARE SAYING THAT --
YOU KNOW THE PROFESSIONAL --
ENVIRONMENTALISTS S PROBABLY
NOT GONNA HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
THEYRE GONNA BRING A CLAIM AND
THEIR THEIR LAWYER UP IN THERE
OKAY IT'S THE UNSOPHISTICATED --
COMMUNITY GROUP THAT REALLY
DOESN'T BELIEVE THAT THEY GOT A
FAIR.
THERE WAS AN THERE WAS A A
MEDICATED ARE MITIGATED NEGATIVE
DECK AND THEY FEEL THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A WHOLE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT AND
THEY DON'T HAVE.
YOU KNOW IT'S A SMALL INFILL
PROJECT AND THEY DON'T FEEL THAT
THEY'VE THEY GOT THE RIGHT --
OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE THEIR
CONCERN BECAUSE OF THE THAT THE
FAST TRACK THAT THEY HAD MET
MAYBE GOOD FOR THE PROJECT I I I
GET THAT SO.
IT WILL SIT AND SOPHISTICATED
LOOK -- FOLKS ARE YOU AND I BOTH
PRACTICE LAW -- AND USE THE
EXAMPLE OF WHEN I CLERKED FOR
FOR A JUDGE -- NGUYEN YOU HAD
FOLKS THAT REPRESENTED
THEMSELVES.
IT WAS WITHOUT EXCEPTION THAT
THE JUDGE WOULD BE GRANTED -- I
CERTAIN CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
UNSOPHISTICATED PETITIONER -- SO
I THINK ALREADY IN OUR SYSTEM IT
IS BUILT.
IN IT'S DESIGNED TO MAKE IT
ACCESSIBLE.
AND I THINK IT'S WITHIN YOU KNOW
THE NORMAL PRACTICE AND AND
CANONS OF THE JUDICIARY -- FOR
THOSE -- CONSIDERATIONS TO BE
MADE NATURALLY SO I THINK IF
YOUR CONCERN IS -- THAT THE
LITTLE GUY.
IS GONNA BE HURT IN THIS PROCESS
THAT'S NOT THE INTENT AND ONCE
AGAIN I BIãU MORE THAN WILLING --
TO WORD SMITH THIS IF THE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ENGAGE THIS --
ENGAGE ON THIS MORE DETAIL --
I'D LOVE TO EARN YOUR SUPPORT IN
THIS PROCESSAND BE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THEM.
MR ONE LAST QUESTION AND IT'S
IT'S THE CHILLING EFFECT WELL I
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU THAT THERE
ARE -- THERE'S AN INVITATION
WHEN PEOPLE COME IMPROPER FOR
THAT THE KIND GENTLER -- JUDGE
TO ADD WORK WITH THEM AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY THEIR HEARD
THERE'S OTHERS THAT -- HOURS
DON'T WANT TO SPEND ANY TIME
WITH THIS NONSENSE -- IS INDEED
USING THEIR WORDS AND THAT WOULD
MAKE A FINDING. TO AWARD
ATTORNEY FEES HE WAS A LITTLE
SMALL GROUP THAT MAY HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON OTHER FOLKS
EVEN THOUGH IT MIGHT NOT HAPPEN
IN LOS ANGELES BUT THEY KNOW
THAT THE YEARS HERE'S THIS ONE
CASE WHERE -- THE JUDGE HAS
ORDERED ATTORNEY FEES AND THE
SMALL ACTIVIST GROUPS THAT MAY
HAVE.
A LEGITIMATE REASON TO CHALLENGE
THE PROCESS OF THE LEAD AGENCY
HIS HAS UNDERTAKEN ON THIS
INFILL PROJECT WHICH IS WE WANT
HOUSING AND ALL THAT TYPE STUFF
SO THOSE ARE THE CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE.
NO AND I I WOULD SEE I MEAN THE
BAD FAITH STANDARD IS A HIGH BAR
AND THAT'S WHEN THAT I YOU KNOW
I I CERTAINLY FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH -- THE EDISON
REASONABLENESS STANDARD IS I
WONDER WHY I YOU KNOW.
I WANTED I WANT TO GRAB WITH ALL
OF THE MORE I MEAN WE JUST
PROVIDED WITH THESE A MAN'S -- I
AM WELL AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
THIS WOULD GO TO JUDICIARY
[inaudible]
I YOU KNOW I WE'RE ALL IN
JUDICIARY ALL THREE OF US.
AND SO I MEAN I I SUPPOSE I I
WOULD WANT YOU KNOW IF ANYTHING
OF THAT WOULD BE A GOOD THING
FOR THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
LOOK AT AND YOU KNOW AND AND AND
I THINK FOR US -- TO TO KIND OF
EXPRESS I'M FULLY COMFORTABLE
WITH THE BAD FAITH STANDARD I I
THINK THAT IS HIGHER THAN
REASONABLE ST I'M I'M AYE AYE
I'M NOT SAYING I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT I JUST --
WOULD WANT.
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
IMPLICATIONS AND I THINK I I
WOULD BE LESS COMFORTABLE
PASSING THIS OUT OF COMMITTEE IF
IT WERE NOT GOING TO DO THIS
NEXT.
I FOR FOR FOR A MORE ROBUST
EXAMINATION OF WHAT THAT WOULD
ENTAIL -- BUT I I DO YOU.
I MEAN I I DO TEND TO BE SOMEONE
WHO.
IS PRETTY SUPPORTIVE OF GIVING
JUDGES DISCRETION I THINK THAT
IN THE END OF THE DAY YOU KNOW
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS YOU'RE
ABLE TO DETERMINE.
THIS THE DIFFERENT.
FACTORS AT PLAY AND AND SO ON I
I HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN OUR
JUDICIARY AND I I FEEL I WAY ON
ALL THE BILL REFORM ISSUES THAT
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT I'M.
SO I THAT'S WHY I HAVE YOU KNOW
BEEN OPEN TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS BECAUSE I THINK.
AND LET'S CONTINUE LOOK OUT
LET'S CONTINUE IF WE FIND THAT --
THAT -- THE THE WORD ON
REASONABLE IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
I THINK -- IS ACCEPTABLE DOWN
THIS PROCESS THAN.
CERTAINLY WORK WITH YOU AND I
WOULD WOULD CONSIDER OF REMOVING
IT.
OKAY SO LET'S LET'S CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION AND AND SO
JUST.
SO WHAT JUST.
AYE AYE WE WERE ASKED.
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE.
I IT READS.
THE US SENATE BILL SIXTY NINE
WITH AUTHORIZED THE COURT TO
WHERE TO TURN THESE FEES TO THE
PREVAILING PARTY.
THAT IS A RESPONDENT OR REAL
PARTY IN INTEREST.
WHEN THE COURT FINDS THE
PETITIONER USED ACTIONS TACTICS
OR CLAIMS MADE ON REASONABLY OR
IN BAD FAITH THAT ARE FRIVOLOUS
OR INTENDED TO CAUSE UNNECESSARY
DELAY?
THIS LANGUAGE WOULD PROVIDE FOR
DIFFERENT STANDARD FOR AWARDING
ATTORNEY'S FEES FOR THOSE INFILL
HOUSING DEVELOPER OBJECTS THAN
WHAT IS CURRENTLY PROVIDED IN
EXISTING LAW [inaudible]
SO -- THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW FROM THE FROM THE AUTHOR.
AND SO THAT'S THE CONTEXT OF
THIS DISCUSSION I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THE FOLKS IN THE
AUDIENCE AT THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE WE'RE COMING
FROM SO I'M [inaudible]
SO.
YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY -- WITH
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING OF OF OF
THIS STILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
I'M I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY -- YOU KNOW BUT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE BE A
MORE ROBUST EXAMINATION THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THAT ON WHICH WE ALL
SET.
AND YOU KNOW I MEAN ULTIMATELY --
BUT FOR ME IT WAS YOU KNOW DOES
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THE IDEA OF
REQUIRING.
THE JUDGE TO OFFER A TO TO AWARD
FEES -- WITH A NON STARTER BUT
BUT THE AUTHORIZATION.
ARE THE GIVES DISCRETION OF THE
JUDGE GIVES ME -- I THINK -- A
LOT MORE COMFORT [inaudible]
AND SO.
WITH OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OR OTHER THINGS YOU
WANT TO ASK ABOUT OKAY SO WITH
THAT YOU CAN MAKE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE WE
CAN'T TAKE A MOTION -- BUT OKAY
WELL LOOK I WAS GONNA SAY I
THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY --
YOU BROUGHT UP YOU IN YOUR YOUR
COLLEAGUES BROUGHT UP -- SOME
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND I THINK --
I'VE DEMONSTRATED A WILLINGNESS
THAT WE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD --
A GOOD PRODUCT AND CENTER WHAT
CASKEY BRINGS UP SOME SOME GOOD
POINTS AND I WOULD DEFINITELY
TAKE WHAT -- WHAT HE HAS TO SAY --
AND MAKE AMENDMENTS AS NECESSARY
TO EARN THE SUPPORT OF NOT ONLY --
THIS COMMITTEE BUT ALSO
JUDICIARY OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU I WAS JUST RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE WILL TAKE
THAT UP IT COMES UP I THINK THAT
WHEN IT COMES UP [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER -- ELEVEN
CENTER MORE LIKE IS HERE THIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX A SCOPING PLAN.
THIS SB.
FIVE THREE FIVE OF CENTER MORE
LIKE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I BELIEVE THAT -- THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE IS PROVIDED
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE AGREED.
TO I HAVE A AMENDMENTS.
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL.
SHE RIGHT HERE.
AND THE MEASURE COLLEAGUES A I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE -- ON A COUPLE
OF OCCASIONS.
TO FIRST AND LISTEN TO PETER
DRUCKER IN PERSON WHILE HE WAS
STILL ALIVE.
WE PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
AND THIS.
THE SAME AS MANAGEMENT GURU --
IMPRESSED ON ME ONE OF HIS NOW
FAMOUS QUOTES.
IF YOU CAN'T MEASURE IT YOU
CAN'T IMPROVE IT.
OR YOU CAN'T MANAGE WHAT YOU
CAN'T MEASURE [inaudible]
THE MEETING.
YOU CAN'T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
YOUR SUCCESSFUL IN THIS SUCCESS
IS DEFINED IN TRACK.
WITH WILDFIRES CONTINUING TO BE
A PREDOMINANT THEME HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ONE MISSING
COMPONENT.
IN THEM IS THERE MASSIVE
PRODUCTION OF GREENHOUSE GASES.
IF WE MEASURE THE AMOUNT OF
GREENHOUSE GASES THESE COMPOUND
FOR RATIONS CREATE.
IT WOULD BETTER EMPHASIZE THE
NEED TO REDUCE MANMADE WILDFIRES
IN OUR STATE.
IF WE CANNOT QUANTIFY THE
DEVASTATION BY ITS IMPACT ON
GLOBAL WARMING THEN THE
UTILITIES WOULD BETTER
APPRECIATE SACRAMENTO'S INTENT
ON HARDENING ELECTRICAL ASSETS.
AND THE POTENTIAL FOR UNDER
GROUNDING THEM. FOR WHATEVER
REASON REMEDIES ARE AVAILABLE TO
PREVENT SPARKING OR IGNITING
VEGETATION. ONE HEADLINE IN
DECEMBER STATED CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES HAVE RELEASED
EMISSIONS EQUAL TO ABOUT SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION TONS.
OF CARBON DIOXIDE THIS YEAR.
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON SENATE BILL FIVE THREE FIVE
OKAY THANK YOU AND AND I AND WE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE.
YOU TAKING THE AMENDMENTS I MEAN
I THINK ON THAT NOW HOUSES WENT
THROUGH.
KIND OF A THE DETAILED SENSE OF
WHY WE WERE CONCERNED WITH THE
ORIGINAL APPROACH -- BUT YEAH
THERE'S ABSOLUTE NO QUESTION
THAT WILD FIRES ARE.
CONTRIBUTING -- TO TO CLIMATE
CHANGE AND AND THERE THEY BE
NEED TO BE DISCUSSED YOU KNOW TO
BE EXAMINED AND AND AND AND
EVALUATED AND AND TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT AND SO I DON'T THINK
IT'S ANY JUST I DON'T I THINK
THERE'S SOME FUNDAMENTAL
AGREEMENT ON ON ON ON THOSE
KINDS OF ISSUES.
AND SO I'M REALLY DO APPRECIATE
YOU WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND DO YOU WANT TO TAKE THE
IMMENSE -- TO TO TO TO WORK YOU
KNOW TO TO TO ADDRESS I THINK
THE CORE ISSUES THAT THE THAT WE
ALL KNOW EXIST WITH REGARDS TO
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATE WITH FIRE SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I AM GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH ME YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
GREAT OKAY SO I'M.
SO WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT
SO LET'S ASK. FOR FOR FOLKS WHO
WANT TO SPEAK OUT IN SUPPORT.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
I ANY FOLKS WHO WANT TO RAISE
CONCERN -- THOSE ARE.
YES -- LARRY CAMP -- REFUTING
FOR SANDERS A CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FORCES
ASSOCIATION WERE WORSE WE DO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OUR FOLKS WANT TO RAISE
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS.
YEAH I WANNA.
RHINO WIKI WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY WHERE
PREVIOUSLY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CONCERNS AND OPPOSITION THAT ARE
CALLED LETTER HEAD DOWN YEAH.
AND AND AND VERY PEASED TO SEE
THE AMENDMENTS AND DEFINITELY
HAVE NO OPPOSITION TO THIS IS.
A LOT OF AGENCIES ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THIS RIGHT NOW IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THIS IS.
THE MAIN CONCERN THAT WE HAD ALL
ALONG WAS NOT TO CONFLATE
WILDFIRE MISSIONS WITH
ANTHROPOGENIC EMISSIONS AND
THAT'S AGAIN SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE VERY MUCH WANT TO SEE TO USE
THE PARTS OF THANK YOU FOR THE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU.YEP TO THE RADIUS TO HAVE -- AIR
BE PREPARE SEPARATE PORT APART
FROM THE SCOPING PLAN IT COULD
THEN FORMALIZE THE DATA -- WITH
THE COMPANY LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM WILDFIRES AND SO
THE WAY OF OF GET MORE
INFORMATION AND AND AND SUPER
IMPORTANT.
SO.
THANK YOU OKAY I ANYONE ELSE
WANTS TO RAISE CONCERNS
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR --
WE WE DO HAVE BEEN A QUORUM YET --
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
HERE AND PRESENTING AND I'M
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS GOING TO RECOMMEND IT.
DO YOU PASS -- RECOMMENDATION I
AND I SUPPOSE IT NOW WILL WOULD
GO OFF TO APPROPRIATIONS FROM
HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR PRESENTATION
ACTOR.
IN SESSION I SEE THAT CENTER
HUESO HAS COME -- MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE WILL GO
TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN THIS IS.
I NEVER EIGHTEEN SB SIX SIX
SEVEN GREENHOUSE GASES RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE FACILITIES GOOD
MORNING SIR -- ALRIGHT THEN
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THERE WILL.
OFTEN IN I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE LAST PAGE OF THE ANALYSIS
[inaudible]
ERA.
THANK YOU.
FOR GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB SIX SIX SEVEN THIS
IS A BILL WAS WHICH SIX TO
SUPPORT LOCAL JURISDICTION.
JURISDICTIONS.
AS THEY WORK TOWARD MEETING OUR
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING GOALS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE CAL
RECYCLE.
ON OR BEFORE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TO DEVELOP AN
INNOVATIVE FIVE YEAR STRATEGY TO
MEET THE STATE'S ORGANIC WASTE.
AND DIVERSION GOALS BY
SUPPORTING ORGANIC WASTE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE CAL
RIGHT.
THE CAL RECYCLE IN THE TREASURE
TO COORDINATE WITH THE STATE OF
NEVADA.
OREGON AND WASHINGTON ON
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING TO
SUPPORT REGIONAL RECYCLING NEEDS.
SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT OF
INTERSTATE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE MARKETS NECESSARY FOR
THESE RECYCLED.
MATERIALS -- WE HAVE A JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RURAL COUNTIES.
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO ASSURE
SOME COMMENTS.
OKAY -- WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING -- JOHN
KENNEDY WITH ROLE -- CALIFORNIA --
WE SEE THIS BILL IS A VITAL LOOK
AT ALL THE COMPLY WITH SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE YOU'LL
REMEMBER THAT WAS A BILL PASSED
A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
IT REQUIRES THE STATE -- 75%
ORGANIC WASTE BY -- TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE POWER CYCLE THE
DOCKING IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS
THAT WILL HAVE FOUND THE FACT ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS -- OUR CYCLES
ANTICIPATING REX COULD COST UP
TO TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT.
EVEN IF WE GET SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND BENEFITS ASSOCIATED.
WITH THE RAGS THAT STILL MEANS
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS JUST TO MEET THIS
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP US GET THERE
BY PROVIDING SOME CLEAR
DIRECTION TO POWER CYCLE TO
IDENTIFY THE TECHNOLOGIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S NEEDED.
AND DEVELOP A FINANCING --
PLANNED TO IDENTIFY THE TYPES OF
FINANCING FUNDING THAT'S
REQUIRED TO HELP US COMPLY WITH
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REQUIREMENTS SO AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE THINK THIS IS A WIN
WIN WIN TO HELP US ACHIEVE OUR
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING
REQUIREMENTS. TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COMPLY WITH THOSE
MANDATES AND THEN FINALLY TO
INCREASE IN STATE JOBS.
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
SEVEN PLEASECOME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS THEIR
GOLFING BEHALF LEAVE CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
UNICA FOR COALITION FOR AN OVER
NATURAL GAS AND SUPPORT.
AS CHAIR MARKET PREY ON BEHALF
OF REPUBLIC SERVICES WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS -- MEASURE FORWARD I AND WE
WANT TO ECHO THE OTHER COMMENTS
MADE BY MISTER KENNEDY.
THE CHAMBERS OF COMMITTEE BRING
RCM HAVE SEE ON OUR ENVIRONMENT
SERVICES ALSO AN ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER THANK YOU IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THERESA BURKE RICH
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPOST COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE MORAL ON
BEHALF OF RECOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
SELECT US HERE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY AND STOP WHAT.
PART.
JUST MULLIN ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTORS BOTH FOR THE RECYCLING
THAT'S PILING UP AND ALSO THE
ORGANICS WHICH IS A CHALLENGE TO
RECYCLE AS WELL THANK YOU.
A FIVE YEAR PLAN.
LET'S HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION
THIS IS SIX SB.
SIX SIX SEVEN THOSE OPPOSED.
AS AMENDED WE BROUGHT IN THE CAL
RECYCLE WITH TREASURE.
RIGHT THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
LET'S RETURN IT BACK TO THE THE
DAIS.
SENATE COMMITTEE OF ANY
QUESTIONS ON ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN NO QUESTION SUPPORT THE
BILL.
RIGHT NOW WITH A WE HAVE A WE
HAVE IN THE SIDE OF THE SHIP
QUORUM A SO WE CAN'T MAKE
MOTIONS YET.
RIGHT.
OKAY -- WILL HOLD IT.
THANK AT THE PROPER TIME WITH.
A RATED QUORUM WILL MOVE IT
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN THIS IS SB -- SIX NINE
THIS IS THE HE WON THE RIVER.
YES.
AND WE'RE STILL WORKING ON THAT
AND AND YOU KNOW LAST YEAR --
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FILED SUIT
AGAINST.
THE I. B. W. C..
ON ON THE TIJUANA RIVER CLEANUP--
WE ALSO -- WORKED ON A BILL --
TO START A PLANNING PROCESS THAT
WOULD.
ALLOW FOR THERE TO BE A SOLUTION
ON THE TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY.
SO WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
WORK IN AND THAT THE QUAN A
RIVER VALLEY -- A RAMS OUR SIDE
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST --
THREATENED.
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL SITES IN
THE WORLD.
NOW IT'S OF A VERY IMPORTANT --
ECO SYSTEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA IT
JUST HAPPENS TO BE AT THE BORDER
OF WHICH THE HAS FACED -- VERY
LITTLE POSITIVE IT ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ALL THIS BILL.
OF FIRST OF ALL OF IS IS A BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE SOME MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF. TO A COMMUNITY
THAT HAS BEEN PLAGUED BY DECADES
AND DECADES OF OF OF AN ENORMOUS
POLLUTION AND RUNOFF.
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY
ARE ALL IN MY DISTRICT AND THEY
HAVE BEEN PLAGUED BY THIS
PROBLEM.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING --
THE COMMITTEE AGAIN AND AND FOR
WORKING FOR MY OFFICE AND MAKE
SURE THIS BILL -- IS IS
SUCCESSFUL IN REACHING ACHIEVING
ITS OBJECTIVE.
AND I'D ALSO LIKE -- TO EXCEPT
AMENDMENTS ADMIN PROPOSED TO
MAKE THE BILL MUCH BETTER --
THIS BILL AGAIN WOULD WOULD --
HELPED IN THIS UP [inaudible]
UP.
PROCESS THAT ENSURES THAT -- WE
CONTINUE -- TO RESTORE THIS
IMPORTANT VALLEY THAT WE WORK TO
STOP THE THE UNNECESSARY RUNOFF
THE RUNOFF COMING THROUGH THIS
VALLEY IS.
IS PRETTY MUCH THE RESULT OF A
PLUMBING PROBLEM.
IN MEXICO THAT CAN BE RESOLVED
WE CAN BE CORRECTED.
AND IN THE INTERIM WE HAVE TO
TAKE MEASURES TO STOP AT THIS
WASTE FROM COMING IN -- TO THIS
VALLEY AND THERE'S A WAY TO
FILTER.
THE THE WASTE -- IT IS ENOUGH
SOME INSTANCES WE'VE HAD
AUTOMOBILES.
COME INTO THE VALLEY FROM MEXICO.
WE'VE HAD -- REFRIGERATORS WE'VE
HAD THOUSANDS OF TIRES.
WE'VE HAD OF STYROFOAM BOTTLES.
THERE IS A PICTURE.
OF OF OF ONE EVENT ONE RAIN
EVENT THE STACKED.
BOTTLES AND IF YOU THINK OF ANY
KIND OF PLASTIC BOTTLE.
OF DETERGENT PLASTIC BOTTLES
WATER BOTTLES BEVERAGE BOTTLES.
THE IN THIS PHOTO IF I CAN JUST
DESCRIBE IT -- THE THE PHOTO IS
A ERSON STANDING NEXT TO A PILE
THAT'S APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FEET
TALL.
OF PLASTIC MATERIAL.
THAT INCLUDE BOTTLES AND AND
STYROFOAM AND TIRES.
THIS IS JUST.
AN UNBELIEVABLE BURDEN ON THIS
COMMUNITY AND IT'S CAUSING A
COULD CONTAMINATION OF ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST BEAUTIFUL
BEACHES.
IMPERIAL BEACH HAS BEEN FAMOUS
FOR SURFING IN INTERNATIONALLY.
AND IN MANY CASES -- THE PEOPLE
OF MY COMMUNITY CANNOT EVEN
RECREATION THE NATURAL NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT THEY CAN'T GO TO THE
BEACH.
WITHOUT THE THE THE THE THREAT
OF HEPATITIS.
THEY ACTUALLY GIVE SWIMMERS OUT
THERE HAVE HEPATITIS SHOTS
BEFORE THEY GO INTO THE WATER.
AS A PRECAUTION.
AND I JUST SHOULD NOT BE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT SHOULD NOT EXIST.
AND WE HAVE FIVE DIFFERENT
SPECIES OF BIRDS THAT ARE ON THE
THREATENED OR ENDANGERED LIST.
THAT MAKE THIS -- ENVIRONMENT
THEIR HOME.
SO I I ASKED OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ME AND
SUPPORT MY EFFORTS TO TO HELP.
CLEAN UP CALIFORNIA HELP PROTECT.
THIS OF THE A VERY SENSITIVE --
LOCATION.
AND SUPPORT THE PEOPLE OF MY
COMMUNITY ABOUT HAVE ACCESS. TO
CLEAN WATER IN THEIR OCEANS AND
IN THE RIVERS.
SADLY THIS USED TO BE YOU KNOW
IN IN THE NINETEEN TWENTIES WE
STILL HAVE THE THE FOUNDATION
OUT THERE.
OF A OF A SALMON CANNERY.
THERE USED TO BE A SALMON
CANNERY IN TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY
AND THERE ARE SCARCELY.
ANY FISH OR ANYTHING THAT CAN
MIGRATE UP THIS RIVER BECAUSE
IT'S COMPLETELY DESTROYED.
I IT'S HARD TO EVEN.
CONTEMPLATE ANY SALMON RUNNING
THROUGH SAID HE WILL COUNTY
ANYMORE.
BUT THINK ABOUT.
NOT LONG AGO WE WERE FISHING
SALMON IN ABUNDANCE.
FROM THE TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY
AND THE ONLY THING YOU CAN FISH
OUT OF THAT RIVER NOW IS
PROBABLY A TIRE.
OR PLASTIC BOTTLE.
AND THAT IS A TRAGEDY.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
TO DO A TO REVERSE.
DECADES AND DECADES OF HARM TO
THIS VERY IMPORTANT HECK ECO
SYSTEM AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
THANK LET'S HEAR FROM YOU HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF A SB.
SIX NINETY I CAN GIVE THE HI
JENNIFER SAVAGE THEIR CREDIT
FOUNDATION.
THE CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER.
AND SURRIDER SAN DIEGO CHAPTER
IS LONG DEDICATED TO IMPROVING
THE SITUATION AT THE BORDER AND
pON IT IT'S BEEN A TERRIBLE
PROBLEM FOR DECADES.
SO IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN M. AT HALF OF
THE BEACHES.
ARE THE TWO THAT I SHOULD SAY IN
IMPERIAL BEACH WERE CLOSE ON
AVERAGE HALF TIME -- DEPENDING
ON THE BEACH THEY HAD ONE
HUNDRED TO THREE HUNDRED
CLOSURES SUPPORTER FIELD BEACH
WITH CLOSE THREE HUNDRED DAYS
OUT OF THE YEAR.
AND THAT'S IT INCREDIBLY
SIGNIFICANT BLOW NOT ONLY TO
COASTAL RECREATIONAL USERS BUT
ALSO TO THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
AND WE KNOW THAT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE LAST YEAR WERE
MADE SICK -- BY SWIMMING IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALONE THAT
AREA IS THE HIGHLY
DISPROPORTIONATE OF WHAT IS
ALREADY A TERRIBLE PROBLEM.
I'M IN THE US THE US BORDER
PATROL WHO HAS.
BEEN PARTNERING WITH SURFRIDER
HELPING TO PROVIDE TOUR IS DOWN
IN THE AREA IF IT DOESN'T ONE
MYSELF AND I'M ENCOURAGE ANYBODY
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE TO TAKE.
ONE I'M AS OF MARCH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THEY HAD EIGHTY THREE
AGENTS WHO WERE MADE SICK -- BY
THE POLLUTION DOWN THERE
[inaudible]
AND THE STATE HAS CONSISTENTLY
AND YOU'RE AWARE OF THIS PROBLEM
STATE HAS CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED
EFFORTS TO SOLVE IT THE PRIOR
LEGISLATION IT THROUGH THE
CURRENT LAWSUIT. TO THE BUDGET
AND THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
TANGIBLE BENEFITS TO AND TO THE
WILDLIFE THERE THE CRITICAL
WETLANDS.
ON HUMAN HEALTH BOTH FOR COASTAL
RECREATIONAL USERS SURFERS
SWIMMERS EVEN JUST BEACH GOERS
IT SO TOXIC YOU CAN'T WALK
THROUGH THE ESTUARY WITHOUT IT
AFFECTING YOU.
I'M AND YOU ARE OF COURSE A U.
S. BORDER PATROL.
AS WELL AS TO THE CAUSE THE
ECONOMY THERE THIS PROJECT HAS
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY PROJECTS THAT
COULD REALLY FINALLY AT LAST DO
SOME GOOD -- SO WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I THOUGHT THANK YOU
OF OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE SB
SIX NINETY PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND EVEN GENEVIEVE ABIT ON
BEHALF OF THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION AND SUPPORT.
LET'S HEAR FROM OPPOSITION OF
ANYBODY OPPOSED TO SB.
SIX NINETY I WAS CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING.
THE STAFF REPORT NOTES MEMBERS
THAT.
THERE IS A BUDGET REQUESTS A
PENDING BEFORE SUB TO UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A TIGER BUT CHAIRMAN
THAT HAS TO GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS WE'RE NOT TALKING
MONEY RIGHT NOW WE'RE JUST
TALKING THE THE BILL THAT.
CONTEMPLATES TO STAND DIEGO
WATER POURED NEGOTIATED
AGREEMENT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
SENDER SCANNERS RECOGNIZE A
RETURN TO GAVEL BACK HERE.
I'M WHEN APPROPRIATE I'LL MOVE
THE BILL AND I WANT TO THANK
DOCTOR FOR INTRODUCING IT THERE
IS AN INTERNATIONAL TREATY.
ON THAT WOULD DO MUCH OF WHAT
YOU'RE HOPING BUT IS NOT BEING
ACTED UPON WHICH SO OFTEN WE
FIND OURSELVES IN THE SITUATION
OF HAVING.
TO TAKE ON THAT WORK THAT
OTHERWISE -- WOULD BE SHOULD BE
DONE BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT I SUPPORT THE BILL AND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT [inaudible]
OKAY SO [inaudible]
WE REVIEW.
OKAY YOU'RE A SUBJECT CLOSE.
JUST SIMPLY STAYING A SAYING
THAT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STEP IN THIS PROCESS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING.
VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH THE THE
SENEGAL WATER POURED
[inaudible]
AND THEY HAVE BEEN -- ENORMOUS
ADD ADVOCATES AND ALLIES IN THIS
EFFORT TO DEAL WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND YOU KNOW ORIGINALLY OUR ARE
LAWSUIT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH.
WHO THE PRESIDENT IS THAT THE
THAT THE FRANK TRUTH IS THAT WE
WE DON'T FEEL THAT?
REGARDLESS OF WHO'S PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OR SECRETARY
OF STATE OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE I. B. W. C. HAS NOT BEEN AN
ADEQUATE ADVOCATE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ALL ON OUR BORDER
ISSUES FACING MEXICO.
AND THERE ARE TREATIES AND THEIR
JOB IS TO ENFORCE THEM.
AND HOLD -- THE THE THE PARTNERS
TO THE STREET IS ACCOUNTABLE AND
THAT'S ALL WE'RE ASKING THEM TO
DO.
WITH THIS BILL WERE WERE SIMPLY
TAKING ANOTHER STEP. TO ASK THE
THE WATER BOARD SHOULD NEGOTIATE.
ARE IN AGREEMENT WITH WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON OUR BEHALF
STATE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
A DOCUMENT THAT WE CAN ENFORCE.
AT AS A STATE AS WELL BECAUSE
THEY ARE I ADVOCATE.
N. AND WE NEED THEM TO FIGHT FOR
US AND AND IN A COMBINATION WITH
WITH THE LAWSUIT THIS ACTION I
THINK WE WILL GET.
A LOT MORE FROM THE I. B. W. C.
THAN WE CURRENTLY GETTING SO.
YOUR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS WOULD
WOULD MEAN THE WORLD TO THE
PEOPLE OF MY COMMUNITY.
AT AND TO THIS IMPORTANT VITAMIN
THE SERVICE ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER FOR THIS AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
ADVOCACY ON THIS IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE IF THEY EVEN
READ YOU KNOW I WAS.
OUT AS I WAS IN.
OHIO ACTUALLY IF YOU MONTH A
MONTH OR TWO AGO AND IT WAS THE
FRONT PAGE STORY IN USA TODAY
WAS TALKING ABOUT THE VISION
ISSUES I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN A BIG
LEADERON THIS.
IN YOUR CAPACITY AS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON MEXICO
CALIFORNIA COOPERATION WE WENT
DOWN TO THE BORDER AND EXAMINE
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES SO I I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THE CERTAINLY ENJOY THE PAST
RECOMMENDATION. FOR ME SO NOW WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM BECAUSE
WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM HERE SO
SEXY PLACES DOUSE A QUORUM.
AND ALLEN.
HERE ALLEN HERE.
EIGHT BATES PRESENT HELLO
[inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER PRESENT STERN STONE I
CAL SKI.
OKAY SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM IT'S
FOR MEMBERS PRESENTS A MAJORITY
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THIS
WEST SO BILL.
THAT'S THE MOVE BY CENTER
SKINNER.
I SECRETARY PLEASE COLOR OF
WE'RE GONNA DO SIX AT SIX NINETY
SB SIX NINETY BY SENATOR HUESO.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALLEN.
AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN STONE BY
CASKEY.
AYE CASKEY I OKAY SO THAT ARE.
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET I
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPENED TO
ENTERTAIN I THINK IT'S A LOT OF
THE MEMBERS WE WILL TAKE UP TO
SIXTY SEVEN BUT LATER BECAUSE WE
NOW HAVE TWO AUTHORS HERE HERE.
SO -- YOU DON'T WANNA MOTION ON
THE PREVIOUS BILLS OUT BECAUSE I
WANT IT I WANT TO GET TO THE
NEXT MEMBERS.
WE'RE HERE WE CAN DO THAT WHEN
WE HAD SUCH TROUBLE.
GETTING AUTHORS I'M SO SENATOR
RAZA YOU'RE NEXT IN LINE -- AND
THIS ITEM NINE HI THIS IS SB --
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT WELL OKAY SO.
SO ONE QUESTION ON OUR
YELLOWSTONE [inaudible]
SO FAR [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY I I MEAN I I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS -- MR MERRY'S YOUR
WITH YOUR TIME SITUATION YEAH.
OKAY YOU CAN ADMIRE YOUR YOUR
PHOTOGRAPH UP HERE -- OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT THE
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR FLEXIBILITY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SEE THANK YOU A
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- I WANT TO
THANK OF THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WERE WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH US.
I ALSO WANT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENT.
RIVER REFERENCE ON PAGE SEVEN OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
UP.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL IS VITAL TO
PROTECTING ALL CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN FROM EVERY WALK OF LIFE
FROM EVERY RACE AND ETHNICITY.
EXPOSURE TO CHLORPYRIFOS BEGINS
IN THE WOMB AND CONTINUES WHEN
KIDS CONSUME THE FRUITS THE NUTS
IN THE VEGETABLE THAT WE AS
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS
ENCOURAGE THEM TO EAT.
BUT IT PUTS ALL CHILDREN AT RISK
OF HARM.
THE SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS HAS
BEEN IRREFUTABLE.
ABOUT THE NEARLY ONE MILLION
POUNDS OF THIS CHILD BRAIN
DAMAGING PESTICIDE THE GETS
APPLIED EACH YEAR ON OUR
CALIFORNIA CROPS.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CONCLUDES THE RISK
THE INFANT AND CHILDREN'S HEALTH
DEVELOP AND DEVELOPMENT IS
UNAMBIGUOUS.
YOU HAVE A LETTER FROM THIRTY
NINE SCIENTISTS -- UP TO THIS
AFFECT THEY RIGHT THERE IS CLEAR
EVIDENCE THAT THE CONTINUED USE
OF THIS PESTICIDE IS HARMFUL TO
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
BASED ON THE RESULTS OF DOZENS
OF STUDIES THEY TELL US EXPOSURE
HAS BEEN LINKED TO ABNORMAL
REFLEXES IN NEWBORNS.
MENTAL AND PSYCHOMOTOR DELAYS
AND PRESCHOOLERS -- DECREASES IN
I. Q. ATTENTION DEFICIT
HYPERACTIVITY DISORDER AN AUTISM.
EVEN SCRIPT STRUCTURAL CHANGES
IN THE BRAIN THE EARLY RESULTS
OF THESE STUDIES FORCED THE
MAKER OF RAID.
S. C. JOHNSON SON. TO REMOVE
THIS CHILD BRAIN DAMAGING
CHEMICAL FROM ITS PRODUCT ALMOST
TWO DECADES AGO.
THE EPA UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
RECOGNIZED THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE.
UP BY PROPOSING TO BAN THIS
CHILD BRENT BRAIN DAMAGING
INGREDIENT IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION'S EPA
CONTRADICTED THE OVERWHELMING
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
ON THE CLEAR CONCLUSION OF THE
EPA'S OWN SCIENTISTS.
BY REFUSING TO FINALIZE THAT BAN
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN NOW THE ONLY
WAY CALIFORNIA CAN RESPECT THEY
REFUSE TO BOWL SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE IS BY ENACTED AS BEFORE.
FIVE EIGHT THIS YEAR WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERING GOVERNOR
NUISANCE PLAN TO EXPAND EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT WHILE
DOING SO THE GOVERNOR MAKES A
STRONG AND CONVINCING CASE WHERE
THE PHYSICAL DEVELOPMENT OF A
CHILD'S BRAIN.
SB FOUR FIVE EIGHT WILL END
CALIFORNIA'S WIDESPREAD USE OF A
PESTICIDE INGREDIENT THE DOES
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE.
AMONG THE MEN IN THE BILL'S MANY
SUPPORTERS ARE THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS AND EARTH JUSTICE
WE MUST END.
THE MULTI DECADE LONG DELAY OF A
BAND OF THIS TOXIC CHEMICAL
JOINING ME TODAY ARE TYLER SMITH.
STAFF SCIENTIST AT JUSTICE AND
GREG GLORIA STAFF ATTORNEY AT
EARTH JUST.
AND THESE.
HELLO GOOD MORNING GERMAN ALLEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS TYLER SMITH I'M A STAFF
SCIENTIST EARTH JUSTICE WE ARE
THE NATION'S LARGEST NONPROFIT
APARTMENT A LAW ORGANIZATION.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
FOUR FIVE EIGHT AND WE JOIN THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS AND THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
IS CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT THE
CONTINUED USE OF CORPORATE FOSS
HARMS THE BRAIN DEVELOPMENT OF
INFANTS AND YOUNG CHILDREN.
ACROSS DOZENS OF STUDIES
EXPOSURE TO CORPORATE BOSTON
SIMILAR PESTICIDES.
BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH POOR
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL AND SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT IN CHILDREN.
NOW IS THE SENATOR MENTONED IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN US EPA CONCLUDED
THAT USING CORPORA FALSE ON FOOD
DOES NOT MEET THE FEDERAL SAFETY
STANDARD.
OF A REASONABLE CERTAINTY OF NO
HARM.
MAY PROPOSED A BAN THAT WOULD
HAVE ELIMINATED NEARLY ALL USES
OF THIS PESTICIDE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN US EPA SCIENTISTS
REVIEWED THE STUDIES CITED BY
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL IN THEIR
LETTERS TO YOU.
AND EXAMINE THE HUNDREDS OF
WHERE THE CORPORATE FOSS MAY BE
USED UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THEY FOUND THAT ALL OF THESE
USES RESULT IN UNSAFE LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE EVEN WHEN THE HANDLERS
FOLLOW ALL OF THE DIRECTIONS ON
PESTICIDE LABELS.
AND WHERE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT.
AND THEY FOUND THAT THE
CONTINUED USE OF CORPORATE FALLS
ON FOOD HARMS THOSE TO BE
PERFECT.
USES ON FOOD EXPOSE CHILDREN
WANTED TO YEARS OF AGE THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TIMES WHAT THE
AGENCY CONSIDERS ACCEPTABLE AND
MOREOVER YOU WITH THE PS
CONCLUDED THAT THERE IS NO SAFE
LEVEL.
OF CORPORATE BOSS IN DRINKING
WATER.
AND YET IN EARLY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED THAT IT
WOULD NOT FINALIZED THE PROPOSED
BAN.
THE ADMINISTRATION DISREGARDED
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND
LEFT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE EXPOSED
TO THIS TOXIC CHEMICAL.
NOW A COALITION OF HEALTH LABOR
AND CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
THE THROUGH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
AND US EPA HAS NOT DISPUTED THE
CONCLUSIONS REACHED BY
SCIENTISTS BUT INSTEAD IS BASIS
LEGAL ARGUMENTS IN THIS
LITIGATION ON UNRELATED
PROCEDURAL ISSUES.
THERE SIMPLY IS NO DEBATE ABOUT
THE SCIENCE A CORPORATE BOSS
EXCEPT FROM THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE
MONEY OFF CORPORATE.
BUT UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE TAKES
ACTION.
THIS CHEMICAL WILL REMAIN ON THE
MARKET AND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WILL REMAIN EXPOSED WHILE THE
FEDERAL LITIGATION CONTINUE.
AND IT MAY TAKE YEARS TO RESOLVE
THIS LITIGATION EVEN IF THE
PLAINTIFFS ULTIMATELY PREVAIL.
SENATE BILL FOUR FIVE A WOULD
MAKE CALIFORNIA A SAFER PLACE
FOR KIDS TO LIVE.
I HEARD YOUR SUPPORT AND I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GREG LAURIE
I'M AN ATTORNEY ADDRESS JUSTICE
I'M HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
WHAT THE SO FOLKS WANT TO WIN
SUPPORT THE BILL.
ESPERANZA ROSSUM HALF THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
CO SPONSORS THANK.
IS TO SHARE MEMBERS THEIR FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT.
DOCTOR MY NUMBER TELL
REPRESENTING FIVE THOUSAND BOARD
CERTIFIED PEDIATRICIANS TO THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AND I'M ALSO
THE STATE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS CO
CHAIR FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
HEALTH REPORTER WITH SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS MAKE IT ACROSS THE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THE SCIENCE BEHIND CLICK HERE
FOSS FOR OVER TWO DECADES.
AND THE EVIDENCE IS UNEQUIVOCAL
THAT THE TIME TO BAN IT IS NOW
THANK YOU.
PLEASE SEVEN LEAD BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS THE SCIENCE
ON THE DAMAGE TO CHILDREN IS
SOLID BUT WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
BECAUSE THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE
SUGGESTING THAT CHLORPYRIFOS IS
A HORMONE DISRUPTING CHEMICAL.
AND THEREFORE A POTENTIAL RISK
FACTOR FOR BREAST CANCER THANK
YOU.
BRENT ASSOCIATE OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR ALSO RESTAURANTS SUPPORT FOR
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AS WELL.
JULIE CHAPMAN WITH INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO ON WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BRENDA WIKI WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY -- ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT.
A BIT OF AN AND THIS WITH UNITED
FARM WORKERS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
BRAND SPENCER WITH THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN STILL
STRYCHNINE IN SUPPORT.
PAULINA THOREZ WITH THE CENTER
AND REYES PAVIN VIRE MEANT
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
GEN FLORIDA'S WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
ELLEN CHAPMAN WITH INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
AND COTTON WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
JIM UNDERGONE BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S DOCTOR CAMBRIA
GARREL MY PEDIATRICIAN
PRACTICING IN LOS ANGELES MAYOR
DUE TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
RIBS GRAY CRESSMAN I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS ANGELES SAID
NUMBER THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M DOCTOR HILLARY SEIDENBERG
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES I'M REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I AM DOCTOR VERONICA RUNOFF THE
PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS ANGELES HERE
WITH THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND I SUPPORT THIS.
I AM DOCTOR JENNIFER MAN I'M
PEDIATRICIAN IN -- LOS ANGELES A
PART OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI DR KELLY SHIFT KIßM A
PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS ANGELES THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND I SUPPORT THE SPELL.
I'M DOCTOR LINE INTO
PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS ANGELES HERE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS ABOUT.
HI I'M DOCTOR JENNIFER JOHNSON
I'M A PRACTICING PEDIATRICIAN
AND LOS ANGELES HERE AT THE
CABIN.
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
MY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ARE SO FOLKS WINERIES
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL RAISE
CONCERNS [inaudible]
SEEING NANA.
ALL RIGHT LET'S AREA.
HOW YOU DOING THIS TO RENEW?
WE HAD TO FOLKS OKAY.
I WAS DOING.
MISSION.
YEAH BUT WHO'S WHO'S WHO'S TAKEN
THE LEAD [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE TWO OF YOU [inaudible]
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CAROL
BURNS AND WITH BIRDS
EPIDEMIOLOGY CONSULTING AND I'M
RETIRED FROM THE DOW CHEMICAL
COMPANY.
I'VE PHD AND A MASTERS IN
EPIDEMIOLOGY.
I OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL TO BAN
CHLORPYRIFOS.
FIRST PLEASE DO NOT DISMISS ME
BECAUSE I'M A CONSULTANT FOR
COULD HAVE A I AM INTRODUCED
BELOW CLOSER TO MAKE FURTHER
HERE PLEASE DON'T DISMISS IS
WITH YOUR CONSOLE THEM.
FOR WHATEVER WHATEVER OKAY MARY
A THEY ARE THEY USED TO BE DAHLE
AGROSCIENCES AND NOW THE THE
WORK WITH OR FOR A MANUFACTURER
CLICK HERE THAT'S OKAY.
SO I WAS PREGNANT WHEN I STARTED
WORKING AT THE DOW CHEMICAL
COMPANY AND MY OFFICE WAS ACROSS
THE STREET FROM WHERE THEY
MANUFACTURED AND FORMULATED
CORPS PURIFY US.
ALL THREE OF MY CHILDREN WERE
DELIVERED AT THE HOSPITAL WITHIN
A MILE OF THIS FACILITY.
MY VIEWS TODAY RESULT FROM
TWENTY YEARS OF CONDUCTING
RESEARCH AND REVIEWING THE
WEIGHT O THE EVIDENCE OF
CHLORPYRIFOS NOT FROM MY
EMPLOYER.
FIRST IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP THE
SCIENTIFIC DISCUSSION ON CORE
PURIFY US. FOR PURIFIES IS AN
ORGANIC PHOSPHATE BUT NOT ORGAN
ALL ORGAN APOSTATES ARE CLICK
HERE FOR US.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT TOXICOLOGY
AND EXPOSURE PROFILES.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO YOU TO WRITE
DOWN THESE ACRONYMS TCP.
D. E. P. E. N. D. A. P..
WHEN MEASURED IN YOUR AND T. C.
P. IS A SPECIFIC METABOLITE OF
CHLORPYRIFOS TRICOR APPEARED IN
ALL?
D. E. P. IS A METABOLITE OF UP.
TO SEVEN OR GALA PHOSPHATES
INCLUDING CORPORATE BOSS IN D.
A. P. IS A METABOLITE OF UP TO
TWENTY INSECTICIDE SO IT'S
NONSPECIFIC. TO THE BEST
SCIENTIFIC PRACTICE TO COMPARE
RESULTS SPECIFIC TO CHLORPYRIFOS
AND LOOKING AT RESULTS FOR TCP
IN D. E. P..
NOT THE LESS SPECIFIC ON ALL OUR
GAL PHOSPHATES IMPORTANT TO
COMPARE LIKE WITH LIKE.
SECONDLY IN A POINT OF AGREEMENT
IN THE PAST TWENTY YEARS THE DPR
REGULATION OF CORPORATE BOSS HAS
CHANGED USES.
REDUCE DRAFT AND AS A RESULT THE
EXPOSURE POTENTIAL HAS DECLINED
IN CALIFORNIA.
SPEAKING TO THE EPIDEMIOLOGY
STUDIES FOR THE MOST PART THE
STUDIES ON CHILDREN WERE BORN IN
THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES IN
THE FIRST DECADE OF TWO THOUSAND
THE NEW YORK CITY STUDIES FROM
COLUMBIA AND MOUNT SINAI ARE
ABOUT INDOOR APPLICATIONS WHICH
ARE NO LONGER REGISTERED.
THERE ARE TWO AUTISM STUDIES YOU
HEAR ABOUT.
A LOT AND BOTH RELIED ON
APPLICATION AND RESIDENTS
RECORDS FROM THE NINETEEN
NINETIES.
TO TWO THOUSAND TEN REASSURINGLY
THE AUTISM STUDY OF CHILDREN AS
REPORTED BY UC DAVIS MOST
RECENTLY.
FOUND NO LINK OF CHLORPYRIFOS AN
AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER.
IN OTHER WORDS DPR HAS ADDRESSED
THE CONCERNS OF THIS PANEL.
FURTHER THE HOME STUDY IN OHIO
CAN DISPEL SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
RESIDUE ON FOOD SINCE NO ADVERSE
ASSOCIATIONS WERE REPORTED WITH
CHLORPYRIFOS LEVELS IN THIS
STUDY.
THE MESSAGE SO I'D LIKE YOU TO
KEEP IN MIND IS THAT MODERN USE
PRACTICES IN DVRS ADDITIONAL
PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA USES.
SHOULD BE EVALUATED BEFORE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A BAND.
IN CLOSING THE CONTEXT OF WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT THE SCIENCE
LOOKING AT BEST SCIENTIFIC
METHODS EXPOSURE LEVEL AND
REPLICATION.
THE COLLECTIVE EPIDEMIOLOGY DATA
DO NOT SUPPORT CAUSE AND EFFECT
RELATIONSHIP FOR RURAL
DEVELOPMENT.
IN CORPUS EXPOSURE.
I'D LIKE TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT ABOUT THE POINT ABOUT
RESIDUES BEING A HUNDRED AND
FORTY TIMES HIGHER THAN USEPA
SAFE LEVELS.
THIS WAS BASED ON A DRAFT POINT
OF DEPARTURE.
ON WHICH WAS BASED AND THAT IT
WAS DEBATED AND REJECTED AS POOR
SCIENCE BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION US SCIENCE
ADVISORY PANEL.
LASTLY INDUSTRY AND D. P. R. ARE
PROMOTING PRECISION AGRICULTURE
AN INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT.
BANDS LIKE THE ONE PROPOSED MAY
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
INCREASED RESISTANCE.
DUE TO LIMITED TOOLS HIGHER USE
OF LEFT LESS EFFECTIVE PRODUCTS
AND PRECEDENT SETTING OF SCIENCE
BASED PRACTICES FOR DECISION
MAKING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE THIRD.
YEAH MY NAME IS BRIAN NEUFELD.
I OWN A FARM MANAGEMENT BUSINESS
AND TULARE COUNTY.
I DO A CUSTOM FARMING.
PEOPLE BY FARMS AS INVESTMENTS
IN MY JOB IS.
TO GROW THE BEST CROSS THAT WE
CAN'T SO I SPECIALIZE IN GROWING
TREE CROPS LIKE CITRUS AND NUTS
AND VINES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
AND I'VE BEEN DOING THIS A LONG
TIME I WAS.
BORN IN A FARMING FAMILY AND BUT
I STARTED THIS BUSINESS ONE
BECAUSE I LIKE FARMING INTO --
YOU KNOW WE'RE GROWN REALLY GOOD
CROPS MEAN STUFF THAT WE ALL EAT
EVERY DAY EVERYBODY'S IN ALMOST
NOW.
CUTIES HALOS MANDARINS.
THESE THINGS ARE VERY POPULAR
THINGS AND AS PART OF OUR
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS WE HAVE JUST A SMALL
AMOUNT OF TOOLBOX LAUGHTER
THINGS THAT WE CAN USE.
SO IN MY PARTICULAR CASE I TRY
TO UTILIZE AS MUCH BIOLOGICAL.
A INSECTS TO HELP US GET OUR JOB
DONE BUT FROM TIME TO TIME WE
HAVE TO DO THINGS LIKE SPRAYED
WITH.
PESTICIDES AND SO I WANT TO RUN
DOWN REAL QUICK.
THE PROCESS THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS ASIDE
REGULATION REQUIRES -- PEOPLE
LIKE ME WHO ARE FARMERS I'M NOT
A PEST CONTROL ADVISER.
I'M JUST A FARMER -- WHICH BY
THE WAY I WANT TO SHOW YOU THIS
CARD THAT.
THE P. R. ISSUES MAY AS A
QUALIFIED APPLICATOR.
IN ORDER TO OBTAIN THIS CARD I
GOT A TAKEN EXAMINATION AND HAVE
TWENTY HOURS OF CONTINUING
EDUCATION AND LAWS IN RAGS --
EVERY TWO YEARS -- BUT THIS DOES
NOT ALLOW ME TO WRITE A
RECOMMENDATION AS A DOCTOR WOULD
WRITER RECOMMENDATION FOR
APPLYING RESTRICTED CHEMICALS
SUCH AS CORPORATE BOSS.
SO I HIGHER THE A PEST CONTROL
ADVISER.
THE WAY THAT THEY OBTAIN THEIR
LICENSE IS A HELL OF A LOT MORE
THAN THIS I MEAN THEY GOT TO GO
TO A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY.
THEY GOTTA GO TO ABOUT FORTY
HOURS A YEAR WORTH OF
EDUCATIONAL -- UNIVERSITY
SPONSORED TRAINING IN ORDER TO
WRITE A RECOMMENDATION SO I
GOTTA GET A RECOMMENDATION FROM
A LICENSE [inaudible]
PROFESSIONAL.
THEN I HAVE TO USE MY CARD NOT
EVERYBODY CAN GO BY CORPORATE
BOSS YOU GOT TO HAVE THIS CARD
IN ORDER TO GO DO IT.
AND AND I RECEIVED A LETTER LAST
NOVEMBER FROM TULARE COUNTY AYE
COMMISSIONERS OFFICE SAYING.
WHEN YOU RENEW YOUR LICENSE FOR
EACH INDIVIDUAL FARM WE'RE NO
LONGER GOING TO HAVE FOR PARA
FOST?
AVAILABLE FOR YOU TO JUST PUT ON
THERE.
THE ONLY WAY THAT YOU CAN
UTILIZE IT IS UNDER SPECIAL
CONDITIONS SO THIS IS ALL NEW TO
EVERYBODY AND I WAS CONFUSED
WHEN THIS CAME OUT.
SO WHEN I WENT TO GO REGISTER.
SO HOW COME I CAN'T OF CORPORATE
FOR US ON HERE.
THIS IS IN A PRODUCT THAT I
REALLY USE ANYWAY BUT
OCCASIONALLY FROM TIME TO TIME
IF I HAVE A A MAJOR PROBLEM ALL
USERS SO.
THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW IS.
IF I WANT TO USE IT I GOTTA GO
THE AYE COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE I
GET A GIVEN VERY SPECIFIC
DETAILS AS TO WHAT MY PAST IS
AND RIGHT NOW FOR CITRUS.
I CAN ONLY USE IT FOR ANSWER I
CAN USE IT FOR SALE ADS THAT'S
IT.
YEAH OKAY SO THE POINT IS IS
THAT THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACERIGHT NOW
THAT ARE PROHIBITING GROWERS
SUCH AS MYSELF.
FROM EVEN WANTING TO USE THIS
PRODUCT THERE'S NO NEED TO
ELIMINATE IT BECAUSE IT'S JUST
ANOTHER TOOL IT'S IN OUR BOX
THAT.
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO GROW
OUR CROPS.
SO I OPPOSE THE THE BILL.
OKAY APPRECIATE THAT.
OUR OTHER FOLKS WANT TO WEIGH IN
OPPOSITION -- CAN RAISE CONCERNS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LEARN
ON PAGE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION EASY FARMERS
PLEASE CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND
GROWERS ASSOCIATION.
WESTERN PLAN HEALTH ASSOCIATION
WESTERN OUR PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
FARMERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER HERRON MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION.
SURE SURE MEMBERS ANTHONY
MILLION ON BEHALF THE ALLMAN
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DON KHAKI
MCCUE CAP CAN ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN A POSITION.
JULIE NON ASKEY BOBBY HAPPY
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION.
MICHAEL MILLER CONFERENCES ASIAN
LANDRY GROWERS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE WE BELIEVE IT'S FLAWS IN
THE REGULATORY ARENA AND NOT IN
STATUTE THANK YOU.
TAYLOR RUSH WITH A CALIFORNIA
FIRM HERE IN OPPOSITION.
MATTHEW OF THE WESTERN ROLLERS
ALSO OPPOSED.
ELEONORA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY A SO OF ADAMS NAM FOR
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS ABOUT
SAID MR EMERITUS. TWENTY FROM
THE OPPOSITION DE I SAW IN THE
STAFF REPORT THAT THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE A GRANTED WE
HAD NEW WITH THE WORDY -- LIKE
TO HEAR THE OPPONENTS OF THE THE
NEW LANGUAGE THAT WAS PUT IN THE
HEALTH.
I'M SORRY COULD YOU PLEASE
REPEAT I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
OPPOSITION POSITION ON WITH
REGARD TO SELF THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE PUT IN LANGUAGE GIVING
YOU WITH ALREADY TO A WEEK.
I WOULD.
YOUR TAKE ON YOUR THOUGHT ON
THAT RATE US ON BEHALF OF COURSE
HAVE A YEAR AGAINST THESE
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE THERE'D
PARTICULARLY CONCERNING BECAUSE
IT UNDERMINES THE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE SCIENCE BASED SYSTEM
FOR REGULATING PESTICIDES THAT
HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR DECADES.
THIS GRANT SO WE HA
UNPRECEDENTED AUTHORITY TO IN
FACT APPROVE OR DISAPPROVE RISK
MANAGEMENT MEASURES THAT DPR HAS
DETERMINED TO BE APPROPRIATE FOR
PARTICULAR PESTICIDE.
AND FURTHERMORE THE AMENDMENT IN
PARTS OF THIRTY TWO WE HA
UTILIZING AN INAPPROPRIATE
STANDARD OF PROOF QUOTE CLEAR
AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE WITHOUT
PRECEDENT IN THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE COAT.
OKAY.
I'M MISTER CHAIR FIBERS.
STAFF NOW SAYS ONE OF THE
ANALYSIS TALKS ABOUT A 50%
REDUCTION IN THE USE THE OF AND
I'LL GET IT.
FOR FIVE REFER US BOTH FOR PURE
FIVE OR FOR A FIGHT OKAY --
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WHAT ARE THE
EPOCHAL LOGICAL STUDIES NOW ON
THE USE OF IT BECAUSE THERE'S
THERE'S IT WAS TRENDING DOWN
WHETHER FROM THE OPPONENTS AND
THE OPPONENTS ON TODAY'S SCIENCE
STUDIES.
CHERYL SENATOR IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE P. A. PUT OUT
THE ITS LAST RISK ASSESSMENT ON
CORPORATE OFF THE FINAL RISK
ASSESSMENT.
LOOKING AT THE MOST RECENT DATA
AND SAYING THAT -- EXPOSURE TO
CORPORATE BOSS RESULTS IN
UNACCEPTABLE LEVELS OF EXPOSURE
TO INFANTS TO CHILDREN.
THE WOMEN OF REPRODUCTIVE AGE.
THAT TAKES ACCOUNT OF THE
CURRENT DATA -- SO BASED ON THE
BEST SCIENCE WE HAVE FROM U. S.
EPA.
AND ALSO THE ANALYSES THAT WERE
DONE BY CALIFORNIA DPR -- THE
CURRENT LEVELS OF EXPOSURE
CONTINUE TO PLACE CHILDREN AT
RISK.
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD IF THE
RESPECTFULLY -- THE EPA
REGULATIONS IN FACT TODAY ARE
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIX THAT'S
STILL A DRAFT -- BUT WHAT I
THINK YOU'RE ASKING IS -- WHAT
IS THE EVIDENCE IN EPIDEMIOLOGY
FOR THE ROAD THE USE PATTERNS
TODAY?
BASED ON THAT 50% REDUCTION OF
CORPORATE BOSS YOU SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE IT REALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO CITE THE LATEST UC
DAVIS STUDY ON AUTISM WHICH
FOUND NO EFFECT AT ALL AND THOSE
CHILDREN WERE BORN.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THAT TIME PERIOD
OF LOWERED USE.
THE STUDIES FROM COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY MOUNT SINAI AND UC
BERKELEY ARE ALL BASED ON
CHILDREN THAT WERE BORN IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT SO THAT'S
THAT.
WE CAN DEBATE THE CONSISTENCY OF
THOSE STUDIES ABSOLUTELY BUT
CERTAINLY THE USE PATTERNS WERE
DIFFERENT IN CALIFORNIA.
AT THAT TIME PERIOD [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
MR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THANKS
SENATOR RAZA AYE I KNOW IT THIS
BILL COMES FROM TO I MEAN JUST.
TERMS OF THE HISTORY WE'RE
SAYING THE PAST.
DOESN'T.
MATTER IS A RELEVANT NOW BUT WE
KNOW WHAT.
WORKING PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THROUGH
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
MANY DECADES.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE EVEN
GRANTED CITIZENSHIP RIGHTS OR
WHATEVER MAY HAVE BEEN THEY
BUILT THIS STATE AND NOW
SUFFERING THE CONSEQUENCES THEY
FED US FOR DECADES SO.
I'M NOT PARTICULARLY MOVED BY
THAT ARGUMENT I'M ALSO I HAVE TO
SAY.
I'M NOT PARTICULAR INTEREST WITH
THE CHEMICALS INDUSTRY HAS TO
SAY ABOUT [inaudible]
THIS.
CHEMICALS BILL -- I KNOW WITH
THEIR THEIR MOTIVES ARE GOING TO
BE THERE -- SELLING PRODUCT I
THINK ON THE WHOLE.
BUT I DO WANT TO BRING BACK UP.
IF IF THE CITRUS.
MY MY FOLKS GROW TANGERINES IN
ORANGE INVENTOR ACCOUNT.
AND I'M TRYING TO GET BACK FROM
MY MOM ACTUALLY AS WE SPEAK. TO
INVOKE HER IN THE BILL BUT IN
THE HEARING BUT I DON'T I DON'T
THINK THEY USE -- CHLORPYRIFOS
IN IN ANY OTHER TREATMENTS BUT I
KNOW THAT A C. PEAS A BIG DEAL.
AND THAT PSYLLID.
TANK THE ENTIRE FLORIDA'S CITRUS
INDUSTRY SO BUT BUT I DON'T LET
THAT SORT OF THINK THAT FEAR
CLOUD THIS LEGISLATION LET'S
LET'S GET DOWN TO IT LET'S
FIGURE OUT.
IS THIS ACTUALLY USEFUL OR NOT
SO IS THERE ANYONE STILL HERE
FROM THE CITRUS INDUSTRY JUST
GIVES A GENERAL SENSE.
YEAH I CAN CAN YOU JUST YOU MIND
COMING BACK UP -- JUST SO JUST
GIVE US IT GIVES THE ANNOUNCES
SAID.
IT TALKED ABOUT.
WE'RE DOWN.
TO JUST OVER NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND POUNDS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND THEN IT SAYS THE THE
THE INTERIM RAGS FROM T. P. R.
[inaudible]
RECOMMENDED.
DISCONTINUING ITS USE ON MOST
CROPS SO SOON WALK US THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT LIKE.
WHAT CROPS ARE STILL ALLOWED BY
THOSE INTERIM RIGS WHAT WHAT IS
THAT LIMITED TREATMENT LOOK LIKE
AND YOU SAID YOU TALKED ABOUT
LIKE?
OTHER PASSED AT OTHER USE OF A I
FORGET WHAT YOU CALL -- THE
OTHER IN SYNC INSECTS BEEN
BENEFICIAL -- YES -- SO FOR A
LONG TIME A LARGE VAN WAS USED
FOR CALIFORNIA RED SCALE WHICH
IS BEEN A PROBLEM FOR A LONG
TIME IT'S AN INSECT THAT.
LANDS ON YOUR FRUIT IT'S THOSE
LITTLE ROUND SPECS THAT ARE ALL
OVER YOUR FRUIT.
AND YOU KNOW AS OUR CLIENTS GET
WARMER AND ALL THAT IT'S BECOME
WORSE AND WORSE SO ANYWAYS THAT
PRODUCT IS NO LONGER USE FOR
THAT.
SO THAT WOULD HAVE BESIDES THAT
USING EVERY DAY THOUGH IT WE CAN
EITHER USE IN COURT YOUR FAUCET
OUR WE'RE NOT NO NAY PACK I HAVE
AND USE IT IN OVER THREE YEARS.
BECAUSE IT'S SO HARD TO USE BUT
I CAN STILL USE AND THAT'S THE
POINT IS THAT.
IT WITH A C. P. IS A HUGE
PROBLEM ESPECIALLY WHEN HLB
SHOWS UP LIKE YOU SAID TWO
THIRDS OF FLORIDA INDUSTRIES
WIPED OUT AS A RESULT OF THIS.
WINTER IS THE HEIGHT OF IT SO
THIS IS A CHEMICAL THAT WE CAN
USE TO WIN DO YOU WANT TO USE IT
THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M CURIOUS
THANK YOU SEE IMEAN USED FOR
THREE YEARS.
MY ONLY USE ONLY I NEED TO USE
IT WHEN IT'S A BECOMES A PROBLEM.
I DON'T WANT MY VARIOUS VERSUS
SOME OTHER CHEMICAL WHEN THEY
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE VERY MANY
OPTIONS WELL WHAT ARE THE OTHER
OPTIONS BESIDES THE THE IN THE
LITTLE RED BUGS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT ELSE OUT THERE WELL
THE ONLY THING THAT STRETCHES
FOR IS.
AUNTS AND FOR ACP THAT'S IT.
I'M SAYING SAYS I CORPORATE
FOSTERS A WHAT ELSE YOU USING IN
THE INTERIM TO DEAL WITH A C. P.
OR WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S WHAT
FORTUNATELY WHERE WE'RE AT AND
CENTRAL VALLEY WE HAVEN'T HAD TO
DEAL WITH THAT YET WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO KEEP IT SOUTH OF YOU
KNOW.
RIGHT OUT OF IT MAYBE SOMEONE
CAN CALM ON THE NAKED TONIGHT TO
BE THAT WAS THAT'S WHAT I WAS
TOLD A COUPLE YEARSAGO WHEN I
WAS.
WORKING ON THAT ISSUE AND IT
YEAH I DON'T I FATHERS FOR
COMPANY BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT'S
BY LIKE I WAS VERY CAN MEAN.
WHAT WE DO IS IN UIX OR IS IT?
OR IS IT.
IS IT IS YOU KNOW CORPORATE I'VE
IT WHAT WHAT'S HAS - SO ON ON
THAT ACCOUNT I MEAN.
OUR UNIVERSITIES HAVE PUT OUT
THESE INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS WHICH MEANS THAT HERE IS.
A AY TO UTILIZE CHEMICAL
CHEMISTRIES TOGETHER.
THE BEST CONTROL PASS AND ALMOST
EVERY GROWER NOW IS USING THESE
THINGS GIVEN THE INCREASED COST
OF PESTICIDES ALL I MEAN YOU
HAVE.
TO SO.
YOU HAVE IT'S YOU HAVE A NUMBER
OF TOOS IN YOUR BOX THAT YOU
CAN YEARS.
AND IF WE'RE ELIMINATING THESE.
I GOT YOU I JUST WE CAMPOS I
CAN'T SIT HERE PUT HAS TO HELP
PEOPLE RIGHT LIKE THAT THAT'S
NOT GONNA.
FLY IN THIS COMMITTEE -- OR I
DON'T THINK IN THIS LEGISLATURE
WILL SEE WHERE THINGS AND UP BUT
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OKAY IF
IT'S A MATTER COST.
HOW DO WE HELP YOU GUYS GET
THERE RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN BREAKING THE
CITRUS INDUSTRY OR AN OUTBREAK
OF OURS  DON'T HEAR THAT FROM
THE AUTHOR?
RIGHT WE DON'T SO SO WHAT'S THIS
OTHER PATHS START TO LOOK LIKE
WE'RE DOWN FIFTH WE'RE DOWN OVER
50% WE'RE DOWN TO NINE OR
THOUSAND POUNDS.
WHAT ELSE IS BEING USED HELP ME
OUT HERE WHAT WHAT OTHER WHAT
OTHER CHEMICAL TREATMENTS OUT
THERE?
OR NOT IT SORT OF I MEAN NO ONE
LIKES PESTICIDES PERIOD RIGHT
THIS IS ALWAYS A TOUGH
CONVERSATION HAVE -- BUT THE
TECHNOLOGIES HAD TO OF ALL I
MEAN WE'VE GOT OTHER THINGS ON
THE SHELVES BESIDES YOU WOULD
THINK THAT BUT THERE IS.
THAT YOU DON'T EVEN USE IT.
YEAH WELL IT'S BECOME BURDENSOME
TO USE IT.
BUT THE BUT THE THE REGULATIONS
ON THE USE OF THE PRODUCT.
ARE PROHIBITIVE OBJECTS USING IT
WELL HAT'S WHAT I'M GETTING AT
IS THAT WE'RE NOT JUST BRAIN
WHEN WE WANT TO SPRAY WE CAN'T
JUST DO WHAT WE WANT TO DO I GOT
TO WORK WITH OUR AG
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
I DO IT I'M DONE.
I GOT YOU I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT OTHER CHEMICAL
APPLICATIONS OUT THERE IS THE
CITRUS INDUSTRY USING BESIDES
CORP HERE FOSS TO PREVENT HLB.
FOUR IT'S NOT PREVENTING HLB
IT'S IT'S THIS ORDER ATTACK IT
IS.
TO INSECTS FINE THE TICKET KELLY
C. P..
THE KILL SELLERS WHAT ELSE WITH
WHAT OTHER CHEMICALS ARE OUT
THERE THAT THE INDUSTRIES USING
RIGHT NOW.
ALL OF A THREE OR FOUR OTHER
CHEMICALS THAT WE CAN HEAR LIKE
WHAT.
I KNOW I HAVEN'T HAD TO SPRAY
FOR YET.
AS ANY DID ANYONE IN HERE HAVE
ANYMORE INFORMATION THERE YEAH
LAURENCE SORRY I I THAT I JUST.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO GET TO THE
NITTY GRITTY THANK YOU SENATORS
SO -- THE CHERRIES CORRECT
NEONICOTINOIDS ARE THE OTHER
ALTERNATIVE AND THAT'S WHAT'S
MOST USED WHEN IT'S COME TO
COMBATING ACP AGENTS THAT ARE
STILL IN TRYING TO KEEP IT OUT
OF COMMERCIAL GROVES.
THAT'S IS BEING USED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO FIGHT IN THE
BACKYARDS SO THAT IS THE
ALTERNATIVE RIGHT NOW THERE'S
ALSO -- WE'RE TRYING WITH THE
WASPS BUT UNFORTUNATELY TAMARIX
CO AS FAST AS THEIR BREEDING
THEY JUST CAN'T KEEP UP.
SO THOSE ARE THE ALTERNATIVES
WERE LOOKING FOR WE'RE LOOKING
FOR TERRORISTS YET.
ARE GIVE ME THAT ONE AGAIN SO IT
WAS TAMARIX YOU IT'S A LITTLE
LAS HOW THAT'S THE BIOLOGICAL
CONTROL YES AND IF YOU KNOW WE
WOULD LOVE IT IF WE COULD JUST.
USE THESE WASPS EAT UP THE BUG
AND BE DONE WITH IT BUT THEY
JUST CAN'T.
THE BASS NUMBER LOGICAL NOT
ENOUGH THE NEAR NEXT WHICH I
KNOW THERE'S OTHER CONCERNS
ABOUT IN THE POLLINATOR
POPULATION FOR THOSE WE'VE HAD
SOME OF THOSE BILLS THAT PASS
BUT SO IN.
THOSE THE ONLY.
TWO THOSE ARE REALLY THE ONLY
TWO THAT ARE EFFECTIVE BESIDES
CORPORATE VICE THEIR **** WE'RE
LOOKING FOR OTHER ALTERNATIVES
THERE'S SOME RESEARCH BEING DONE
AT UC RIVERSIDE RIGHT NOW TRYING
TO FIND SOME THINGS TO DO. ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WHICH
IS IT'S KIND OF ONE OF THOSE
POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE IN
CALIFORNIA WERE THE ONLY STATE
THAT HAS A DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION.
GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THAT
MEANS NO MATTER WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES CALIFORNIA MAKE
SURE IT'S SAFE BEFORE IT GETS
HERE BUT WHAT THAT DOES DO IS IT
EXTENDS THE TIME AND THE COST
FOR OTHER ALTERNATIVES TO MAKE
ITS WAY INTO CALIFORNIA'S MARKET
PLACE.
AND IT COST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO GET THESE THINGS THROUGH THE
SCIENTIFIC PROCESS.
I'M TO MAKE IT TO THE MARKET AND
IT CAN BE TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS
THROUGH THE FEDERAL PROCESS AND
WITH THE PR SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO GET MORE OF THESE
ALTERNATIVES.
BUT IT TAKES SUCH A LONG TIME
WHAT LONG AMOUNT OF TIME AND
IT'S SUCH A LARGE INVESTMENT.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT SOME WAY
TO STILL PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND ALSO GET THESE ALTERNATIVES
IN HERE BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
SOLUTION FOR THAT YET BECAUSE WE
NEED WE STILL NEED. TO BE MAKING
SURE THAT ALL THE SCIENCES
CORRECT IN BEING DONE BEFORE IT
EVER GETS RELEASED INTO THE
MARKET BUT THAT'S THAT'S WHY
IT'S IT'S HARD AND SO WHILE.
FARMERS AT THE TIME I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT YOU BUT WHEN YOU'RE
SAYING TOO LONG OF A LAG TIME
BUT I MEAN I KNOW EVERYONE'S
HUSTLING FROM WHAT I CAN TELL
THEIR DITCHES INDUSTRY. TO TRY
TO GET SOMETHING SOME OTHER
SOLUTIONS TO MARKET LIKE I I
DON'T HEAR YOU GUYS SAYING YOU
WANT TO USE THIS HE SAID HE
DOESN'T EVEN USE IT NOW IT'S
IT'S ONE OF THOSE PESTICIDES IS
KIND OF A LAST RESORT PESTICIDE
YOU USE IT.
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE GIANT
INFESTATIONS AND NOTHING ELSE IS
WORKING?
I'M AND THAT'S WHY WE ARGUE THAT
IT JUST NEEDS TO BE A TOOL IN
THE TOOLBOX THAT'S USED IN.
LIMITED USES IS RESTRICTED AND
THINGS LIKE THAT WERE TRYING TO
GET ALTERNATIVES BUT IT YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE SCIENTIFIC
PROCESS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE.
THE SCIENCE IS THERE AND THE
MITIGATION MEASURES ARE THERE IN
THE RESTRICTIONS ARE THERE
BEFORE IT EVER GETS USED AND NOT
JUST TAKES TIME.
AND A LOT OF MONEY I JUST I WERE
IN A RUSH BOTH ON A C. P. BUT
ALSO ON HUMAN HEALTH HERE AND SO
I I DON'T AT EIGHT IT'S TOO OPEN
ENDED RIGHT NOW AND JUST THAT IT
WAS A DRAFT REGULATION.
I DON'T KNOW I I DON'T FIND THAT
PARTICULARLY COMPELLING LIKE
THIS IT THIS LAST ADMINISTRATION
I TRUSTS.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE NEW ONE I
DON'T FUNDAMENTALLY SO LIKE IF
IT'S A MATTER OF ME THERE'S A
LOT OF RAIDS THAT.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE THAT
THAT JUST DIDN'T MATERIALIZE --
I DON'T NEED IT TO BE EVEN CLEAR
AND CONVINCING AT THIS POINT I
HAVE A VERY PRECAUTIONARY.
SENSE ON THE THE HUMAN HEALTH
SIDE I JUST.
I DON'T WANT.
TO WE CAN'T BREAK YOU GUYS AND
AND WE CAN HAVE AN OUTBREAK HERE
SO HOW DO WE FIND A WAY TO
BRIDGE THIS PERIOD WERE
BASICALLY PHASING THIS THING OUT.
AND I I DON'T HEAR IT COMING
FROM INDUSTRY DAY BUT LIKE IT'S
AT THE END IS NEAR AS A MATTER
OF WHEN FEELS LIKE.
AND WOOD WE DO TODAY OR DO WE DO-IT.
WHENEVER THIS NEW STUFF COMES TO
MARKET SO.
I I I DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT
INDIA'S BUT HOW DO WE MAKE THAT
TRANSITION WORKS OVER IF WE MOVE
THIS THING THROUGH.
RIGHT LIKE HOW HOW DO WE FIND
THAT BRIDGE TO SOLVE THE THE A.
C. P. ISSUE IN THE NEAR TERM DO
YOU THIS I MEAN YOU GUYS HAVE A
GUIDE.
READ ON THAT I KNOW YOU'RE
INCREDULOUS ABOUT THE THIS SORT
OF ALTERNATIVES BEING.
I ON WORKABLE THE GOOD THE THE
THINK THERE'S FUNDAMENTAL MERIT
[inaudible]
WITHOUT CHLORPYRIFOS.
YES BECAUSE THE SO JUST FOR THE
FIRM FROM YOUR PROTECTED SENATOR
THEIR PROPONENTS I MEAN JUST.
WHAT IS THIS TRANSITION LOOK
LIKE?
WE BàN IT WE ENDED.
AND THEN SO HOW DO WE SOLVE THIS
SOARED IN TERM PERIOD BECAUSE I
WANT I WANT TO I'M THERE I JUST.
CENTER I THINK YOUR YOUR
INSTINCT IS CORRECT I MEAN THIS
STUFF IT'S BEEN PROVEN TO BE
DANGEROUS FOR CHILDREN IN A
NEEDS TO COME OFF THE MARKET.
BUT I WHAT I'M HEARING FROM THE
POSITION IS THAT THEY DON'T USE
QUICKER OF US NOW.
THERE ARE TWO ALTERNATIVES AND
MORE ON THE WET HE DOESN'T USING
NOW BECAUSE HE DOES HAVE AN
INFESTATION OF LONG BEING SO HE
DOES NEED TO GO KILL THOSE SOLD
BECAUSE THERE'S NO INFESTATION
BUT HE'S ALSO SAYING IF THERE IS.
ONE WE NEED TO HIT HARD SO LIKE
IF IF SOMETHING BREAKS OUT WHAT
WE DO.
YOU KNOW SENATOR I I THINK THAT
THAT'S A QUESTION WILL HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON THIS.
VERY CLEAR ON WHAT THIS MEANS
FOR CHILDREN'S HEALTH.
I WOULD ALSO ADD.
THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR TWO
DECADES YES.
OF ITS IT DIDN'T JUST.
YOU KNOW THE ISSUED ON THE
DANGERS HAVE BEEN KNOWN FOR
DECADES.
AND SO ARE THE QUESTION FOR ME
IS HOW MUCH LONGER.
DO WE PUT THESE KIDS AND BABY IS
IN DANGER.
AND WE SHOULD PUSH OURSELVES TO
COME UP WITH THOSE ANSWERS MUCH
SOONER.
AND NOT LET DECADES GO BY.
OF A YOU KNOW WITHOUT DOING
SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT ABOUT IT
AND THAT'S AND THAT'S OUR POINT
TODAY.
IS IS GONE TO THE POINT WHERE
THE SCIENCE IS IRREFUTABLE.
LET'S DO SOMETHING AND NOT KEEP.
PUTTING IT OFF AND PUTTING IT
OFF AND PUTTING IT OFF LIKE I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THERE ARE.
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE BEING
LOOKED AT AND LET'S PUSH ON THE
ALTERNATIVE I GUESS MY QUESTION
FOR LAUREN IS I MEAN ALONG THESE
LINES.
VIEW THIS.
THIS BILL DOES IT IS NOT JUST AN
HOUR RATED IT IT OUTLAWS -- THE
PESTICIDE IN TILL SUCH TIME AS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE P. R. ISSUES
CONTROL MEASURES WHICH DETERMINE
THE PRODUCTIVE TRIP CHILDREN'S
NEURAL DEVELOPMENT.
SO.
PERHAPS IN THERE THERE'S SOME
WIGGLE ROOM TO ALLOW FOR THE
KIND OF STRONG RESPONSE -- IN A
YOU KNOW IN A IN IN THE CASE OF
A STILL IT OUT BREAK.
I AS LONG AS THERE ARE MEASURES
TAKEN.
TO PROTECT KIDS I MEAN IF THERE
IS AN EMERGENCY SITUATION --
EIGHT YEAH YOU KNOW WE WE
BELIEVE AS WRITTEN THE
AMENDMENTS REALLY ARE A BAN
BECAUSE OF THAT CLEAR AND
CONVINCING STANDARD IS CONFUSING
IT THROWS THE REGULATORY SYSTEM
JUST KIND OF ON ITS HEAD.
AND BUT I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING AND WE WOULD ENCOURAGE --
THE YOU KNOW THE INDUSTRIES
WORKING WTH DPR TO TRY TO
FIGURE THIS OUT DEEP YOU'RE
RIGHT NOW IS WORKING WITH CARBON
A WE HAN.
ON THESE INTERIM MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT NO ONE IS BEING
HARMED WE HAVE DEEP HEARING CDFA
THAT IS REGULARLY TESTING FOOD
TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NO RESIDUE
ON IT.
SO ARGUMENT IS THAT A LOT OF
THIS IS ALREADY BEING DONE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA FORGET WHAT THE
FEDS ARE DOING CALIFORNIA IS.
PUSHING VERY HARD AND HAS
RESTRICTED THE USE SO MUCH IN
VERY SPECIFIC QUANTITIES.
THAT WE'RE BEING INCREDIBLY
PROTECTIVE OF HUMAN HEALTH UNDER
THESE MITIGATION MEASURES AND
RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- SO I I I DO THINK
WE CAN WORK WITH THE P. ARE YOU
KNOW WHAT IS A MORE THEY THEY DO
HAVE PROCEDURES IN PLACE FOR
CERTAIN EMERGENCIES I THINK THIS
BILL WOULD.
STOP THAT.
YES I GUESS I MEAN I GUESS MY
ARM QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER IS.
I HEAR THEY ARE I MEAN THE ART
CITRUS INDUSTRY IS JUST FREAKED
OUT ABOUT [inaudible]
THE SILICON.
AND HAVING SOMETHING SIMILAR
HAPPENED TO WHAT HAPPENED. TO
THE FOLKS IN FLORIDA AND YOU
KNOW I GOT I'M A CITY PERSON
LIKE YOU I HAVEN'T SPENT A LOT
OF TIME IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BUT I'VE DELVED INTO THE NEW
UNIX ISSUE BECAUSE I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT IMPACT ON
POLLINATORS AND BEES.
I AND YES SPEND SOMETIME TALKING
THE FARMERS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN AND JUST GOT A A SENSE
OF OF THE DEPTH OF THEIR CONCERN
THERE.
YOU KNOW I WONDER IF YOU KNOW
WHAT THE BILL MOVING FORWARD IF
THERE IF THERE COULD BE SOME
SORT OF I MEAN I I'M SURE THIS
pTO BE HAPPY WITH THE BILL BUT
FROM A YEAH FROM FROM SOME THE
CONCERNS YOU HEARING FROM THE
COMMITTEE I WONDER IF THERE BE A
WAY. FOR US TO TO CREATE A
ANOTHER FLEXIBILITY IN THE BILL.
THAT WOULD ALLOW.
FOR SOME SORT OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO BE TAKEN THAT COULD
BE VERY CONTROLLED AND TARGETED
AND I WHERE WHERE WE REALLY
WOULD HAVE A STRONG.
I SENSE OF OF CONFIDENCE THAT
IT'S NOT GOING TO PACK KIDS BUT
SOME SORT OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE
THAT COULD BE TAKEN IN THE IN
THE CASE OF A MATTER OF AN
OUTBREAK OF THE SELL IT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
I ANY OBVIOUS HE WOULD TAKE A
LOT OF EXPERTISE IN ENGAGEMENT --
I UNDERSTAND THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO WANT ANY RESTRICTION ON THIS
PESTICIDE IN GENERAL ARE BUT I I
WONDER WHETHER THAT COULD BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD SPEND
SOME TIME LOOKING INTO -- IN IN
IN THE IN THE IN THE IN THE
POSSIBILITY OF THERE BEING A
STILL IT OUT BREAK IN -- IN IN
THE IN THE CENTER VALLEY I'M
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S CONCERN ABOUT
RIGHT NOW YOUR TURN OTHER MORE
ORANGE TREES IN PEOPLE'S
BACKYARDS IN THE CITIES AND
THERE ARE IN SUCH A VALLEY.
SO HARD TO REGULATE AND CONTROL
THAT'S ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
RAN INTO IN THE ISSUE THE NEO
NECKS.
I THEY'RE JUST IT IS THIS COULD
BE THIS COULD JUST BREAK OUR
CITRUS INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH YOU KNOW IS AN IMPORTANT.
ARE PART OF OUR STATE'S ECONOMY
SO HOW DO WE SO I DON'T KNOW I I
I I GUESS I WOULD ASK YOU. TO
SPEND YOUR HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND
TO THAT I ASKYOU TO SPEND SOME
TIME. TO KIND OF DELVE INTO --
THE POSSIBILITY OF A VERY
TARGETED EMERGENCY RESPONSE IN
THE IN THE IN THE IF THERE WERE
TO BE A DEVASTATING SO IT
OPERATE.
WELL I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WHEN
I'M GOING BACKWARDS HERE -- YEAH
AND I WOULD.
THE CORE THE BILL LOT OF THERE'S
BEEN.
A NON STOP WORKING TOWARDS.
GETTING RID OF IT.
AND SO I DON'T WANT TO OPEN UP A
DOOR THAT SAYS WELL NOW WE CAN
START USING IT AND SO.
YOU KNOW EVEN FROM THE EVEN FROM
THE OPPOSITION SAYING WE'RE
USING THAT YES AND LESS AND LESS
THAT'S A GOOD THING I DON'T WANT
TO OPEN UP THE DOOR SO.
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN YOU'RE
RAISING I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT GOING BACKWARDS AS FAR
AS THE USE OF IT.
OF YOU KNOW WHERE WE HAVE GOT.
TO WE'VE GOT TO PROTECT THOSE
BABIES NO I I I CAN AGREE WITH
YOU MORE I CAN AGREE WITH YOU
MORE I WOULD ONLY BE.
YOU KNOW I WOULD ONLY BE EVEN
ANDERSON ENTERTAINED SOMETHING
LIKE THAT IN THE CASE OF AN
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCE.
I WHICH WOULD BE.
YOU KNOW A POTENTIALLY
CATASTROPHIC.
I YOU KNOW INDUSTRY THREATENING
STILL IT OUT BREAK THAT --
KINDLE WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IN
FLORIDA [inaudible]
YES.
HAS BEEN ON THE RISE AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE FARM WORKERS
THERE'S BEEN SOME PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE INDUSTRY.
BUT OUR EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD.
AND REGULATORS AND HOW THEY
TREAT FARMWORKERS IN THE FIELD
IS THAT EVEN THROUGH EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS IT TOOK DECADES TO
GET THE SIMPLE.
COMPONENTS OF WATER IN SHADE AND
YET.
MANY DIED FARMWORKERS LATER WE
COULDN'T GET THAT SO I WOULD
JUST CAUTION THE LEGISLATIVE
BODY AS WE LOOK AT REGULATIONS
AND THAT PROCESS AND WHAT THE
DAMAGE.
HAS BEEN DONE IN TERMS OF
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR LIVES AS
ARE OUT THERE.
I WOULD JUST JUMP BACK INTO VERY
INTO.
YOUR GAUGE.
WE CAN'T LEAVE THIS OPEN ENDED
TO SOME DISCRETION ON THERE WITH
YOU I MEAN THEY GIVE IF THERE
ARE SOME WIDE OPEN DOOR NO WAY
RIGHT THAT'S NOT GONNA WORK NO
AND I AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
SQUISH AROUND THIS ISSUE AND
SORT OF GIVE SOME OPEN ENDED UP.
FORTY THAT'S REALLY A BACK DOOR
TO JUST CONTINUE DOING WHAT
WE'RE DOING THE PEOPLE ARE
HURTING AND PEOPLE HAVE SERIOUS
DISEASES NSWER ANY DISPUTE
ABOUT THE AUTISM STUDY GOING
BACK IN TIME THE STAFF IS DEAD.
SERIOUS AND DEADLY SO I'M THERE
JUST TO DO SOME THOUGHT BEFORE
I'M I'M I'M I'LL BE SUPPORTING
TODAY ABSOLUTELY.
GIVE SOME WORK LET'S WORK ON
THIS THOUGH AND AND AND AND
ENGAGE WITH THE CITRUS FOLKS IN
START FIGURING OUT LIKE.
WHAT IS THE AVERAGE LOOK LIKE
HOW DO WE?
IF IT IS ABOUT FUNDING
ACCELERATING ALTERNATIVES HOW DO
WE FUND THAT HOW WE GET THINGS
IN THE MARKET FASTER -- AND THEN
IN THIS OUTBREAK CASE LIKE JUST
WHAT'S THE PLAN LIKE LET'S JUST
BE UP FRONT ABOUT IT AND THEN
WE'RE GOING IN EYES WIDE OPEN
EVERYONE FEELS COMFORTABLE LIKE
THERE ACTUALLY IS A PLAN.
BUT WE WE CAN'T GO BACKWARDS AND
IT YOU KNOW THIS IS.
THIS IS GOT END IT'S JUST IT'S A
IT'S A TIMING A TO IT'S IT'S
HIGH I I YEAH IT'S A IT'S IT'S
ABOUT THIS TRANSITION AND DOING
NO HARM TO PEOPLE.
AND THIS INDUSTRY IN THE PROCESS
THANK YOU ANYWAY I'M THERE I
THANKS FOR INDULGING THE THE
CONVERSATION AND LISTINGS AND
POOR AND ONE AND AND IT'S ONE I
THINK I JUST THINK THE SILLY
ISSUES WHEN IT A LOT OF FOLKS
AREN'T VERY AWARE OF WHO AREN'T.
DEEPLY ENGAGED IN THE INDUSTRY --
FONG INDUSTRY A CENTER CASKEY.
SYSTEM THEY GIVE US A CHAIR --
GET OUT THERE THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS A AS SAFE INSECTICIDE
OKAY I MEAN THESE THESE
CHEMICALS ARE DESIGNED TO KILL
LIVING CREATURES.
AND IF YOU ARE EXPOSED TO THEM
ENOUGH AS A HUMAN BEING YOU'RE
GOING TO GET YOURSELF SET.
I MEAN I GOT A FRIEND OF MINE
THAT -- WANTED TO KILL SOME ANTS
IN HIS GARAGE BE SPRAYED FRANCE
AND CLOSES GARAGE DOOR.
ANY LOSSES HERE FOR FIVE YEARS
YOU DID READ THE ARMOR ACTIONS
LIKE I'D READ ALL THIS
INSECTICIDE IN AND STILL
SUFFERING FROM THE CONSEQUENCES
MY DAD WAS A SPRAY PAINTER.
I HAD HIS OWN BUSINESS A LOS
ANGELES -- THERE WERE THE
WARNINGS ABOUT LEAD BASED PAINTS
WHEN HE WAS SPRING AND WASHING
ITS HANDS WITH LACQUER THINNER
AND UNFORTUNATELY PASSED AWAY.
FROM -- WITH THE THEY CALLED
ALZHEIMER' BUT IT WAS REALLY
THE ORGANIC SOLVENTS IN THE LEAD
THAT.
THAT POISON MY MY DAD.
AND THERE CERTAINLY WASN'T THE
THE THE REALIZATION WITH A
FARMWORKERS DECADES AGO ABOUT
THE TOXICITIES OF THE THE
CHEMICALS ARE BEING USE ARMIES
ARE WASN'T -- EMPHASIZED -- THEY
WERE JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE
COULD BEAT OUR STATE AND AND AND
AND PETER COUNTRY -- WHAT'S
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE INDUSTRY IS
THAT.
WE SEE A SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN
THE UTILIZATION OF THIS CHEMICAL
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE SOME HEALTH RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
AND AND SENATOR STERN WANTED TO
SAY THAT WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING
OTHER ALTERNATIVE CHEMICALS ON
THE MARKET TO REPLACE THIS THE
MAY IN FACT BE SAFER.
BUT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THEIR
DUE DILIGENCE THAT I DON'T THINK
IT GOVERNMENT THAT NEEDS TO PUSH
THOSE CHEMICALS TO THE FOREFRONT.
IT'S THE MARKETABILITY IN THE
PROFITABILITY THOSE COMPANIES TO
GET THOSE SAFER INSECTICIDES ON
THE MARKET.
SO LET ME JUST GIVE YOU ONE
QUICK EXAMPLE ANOTHER ONE IF I
MAY.
WE HAD AN ISSUE IN THE TO MACULA
ONE COUNTRY CALLED THE GLASSY
WINGED SHARPSHOOTER.
IT DOESN'T MADE A 20% OF OUR
VINE I WAS COUNTY SUPERVISOR AT
THE TIME.
I WAS GETTING CALLS FROM
DEVELOPER SAYING HEY WE LIKE TO
BUY THAT THREE HUNDRED ACRE
VINEYARD SIDE WE WANT TO PUT
SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT
LOTS AND BUILD HOMES.
AND I SAID NO I SAID WE ARE
GOING TO WORK WITH OUR
INSTITUTION YOU SEE ARE WE'RE
GONNA FIND A CURE FOR THIS I'M A
PUT A CIRCLE AROUND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES.
EVER GOING TO PRESERVE THAT ONE
COUNTRY.
AND WE DID WE ALSO WENT TO THE
STATE LOOKING FOR ASSISTANCE THE
COUNTY PUT UP A QUARTER MILLION
DOLLARS IMMACULATE BUT A POOR TO
MILLION.
AND THEN WE SAW SENATOR
FEINSTEIN THAT RECOGNIZE IT IF
WE DON'T TACKLE THIS PROBLEM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT'S GOING
TO MIGRATE TO NAPA WE'RE GOING
TO DECIMATE.
A MAJOR INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WELL WE DID FIND A CURE FOR YOU
SEE OUR WE PRESERVE OUR WINE
COUNTRY THE GLASSY WINGED
SHARPSHOOTER IS NO LONGER A
MAJOR THREAT FOR NAPA AND SONOMA
AND CENTRAL VALLEY -- HERE WELL
IN MY DISTRICT I MEAN.
SUN KISSED WAS FOUND IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHERE AN
AGRICULTURAL COUNTY WE HAVE A
pWE HAVEN'T HAD TOO MUCH OF THE
SILLY IT.
BUT IF YOU OUTLAW THIS CHEMICAL
WHIH IS THE BACKSTOPS.
AND THERE'S NO OTHER
ALTERNATIVES TO STOP THIS
POTENTIAL DEVASTATION ON OUR
AGRICULTURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHY WOULD WE DO THAT.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH HAVE
COMING UP WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
STEPS THAT ARE NECESSARY BEFORE
AN AD COMMISSIONER AND A COUNTY
CAN AUTHORIZE THE UTILIZATION OF
THIS.
BUT WE HAVE TO KEEP THIS IN OUR
ARMAMENT TARIAN UNTIL THESE
OTHER.
INSECTICIDES COME ON THE MARKET
SO WE DON'T DECIMATED OUR
AGRICULTURAL -- BUSINESS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY.
SO -- I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE I'M NOT GOING TO PUT MY
FARMERS IN IN HARM'S WAY OF
LOSING THEIR INVESTMENTS AND
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE QUALITY
CITRUS.
COMING FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY --
UNTIL WE HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
THAT CAN REPLACE THAT BACKSTOPS
BECAUSE YOU HEARD THE WASH DON'T
DO IT THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE
INSECTICIDE TO THAT CAN DO IT.
SO WE NEED TO KEEP THAT ONE
CHEMICAL I HAVEN'T HEARD OF
PATHOLOGISTS COMING FORWARD AND
TOXICOLOGIST COMING FORWARD AND
SAYING WE HAVE CHILDREN BEING
POISONED AND THE THEIR COGNITIVE --
ISSUES OR OR THERE AND IT'S
CAUSING UTISM WHERE THEY WORSE
WORSE DPR RESEARCH DID GET DTS
pUNIQUE STATE WHERE WE HAVE A
DEPARTMENT.
THAT CAN EVEN PREAMP THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF THE SAY SOMETHING
A SAFE OF OUR AGENCY SAYS THAT'S
NOT WHY NOT LET.
DTS DO THEIR JOB WHY WE'RE
PREEMPTING THEM THAT'S SETTING A
BAD PRESIDENT OR WHAT WE'VE
INDEED DTS FOR IF WE'RE GONNA
PREEMPT THEY'RE THEY'RE
PROFESSIONALS THAT.
ALL THEY DO IS THEY HAVE
PROFESSIONAL TOXICOLOGIST
RESEARCH BIOLOGIST TO COME UP
WITH THESE CONCLUSIONS TO ADVISE
US.
MANY OF US EARLY PEOPLE I HAVE A
PIECE OF SCIENCE BACKGROUND I
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
BUT I DON'T WANNA CRIPPLE THE
THE THE CITRUS INDUSTRY WHAT THE
WITH WITH WITH A KNEE JERK
REACTION. TO A CHEMICAL THAT IS
NOT BEEN SHOWN TO CAUSE ANY
MORBIDITY OR MORTALITY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AT A TIME WHEN
IT'S UTILIZATION IS COME DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY WE'RE LOOKING FOR
A LOT TURNS TO REPLACE.
THOSE REASONS AGAINST PORTABLE.
A AB DID MEAN WHAT CAN YOU
RESPOND OF THE SENATOR'S
COMMENTS ABOUT ABOUT EVIDENCE.
OF I MEAN I EAT THERE SEEMS TO
BE A THREE SERIOUS DISCONNECT
BETWEEN [inaudible]
AREA.
THAT'S VERY FUNNY.
SURE SENATOR I WOULD RESPOND IN
A NUMBER OF WAYS.
AS SENATOR TO RAZA MENTIONED IN
HER OPENING REMARKS THERE IS A
LETTER.
AVAILABLE TO ALL OF YOU THIRTY
NINE SCIENTISTS AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS STATING
UNEQUIVOCALLY.
THAT OUR CORPORATE BOSSES LINK --
TO DAMAGING SHOT TO CHILDREN'S
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
THEY ALSO STATE THAT NO SAFE
LEVEL OF EXPOSURE HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED I BELIEVE SENATOR
STONE.
REYES THAT LETTER TWO WEEKS AGO
AT THE SENATE HEALTH CARE AND
YOU ALSO HAVE OF COURSE THE ODD
NUMER THE SUPPORT NUMEROUS
PEDIATRICIANS AND OTHERS WOULD
WIND UP TODAY.
W. SUPPORT FROM THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
SO I I THINK THERE'S AMPLE
SUPPORT FROM SCIENTISTS AND
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN THIS
STATE AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THANK FINANCES VERY CLEAR.
AND THAT -- CHILDREN'S HEALTH IS
THREATENED AS LONG AS CORPORATE
BOSSES USE.
AS THE PR I WOULD ONLY POINT OF
THE DPR EVALUATION FROM LAST
YEAR.
FINDING THAT EXPOSURE TO ALL AGE
GROUPS THROUGH FOOD.
RESULT IN UNSAFE LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE.
EXPOSURE AT ALL AGE GROUPS AND
DRINKING WATER.
RESULT IN UNSAFE LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE.
AND EXPOSURE UP TO HALF A MILE
AWAY.
FROM FIELDS WHERE YOUR FAUCET
SPREAD.
ALSO RESULT IN UNSAFE LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE.
SO USEPA CALIFORNIA.
SCIENTISTS AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN THE STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE EVIDENCE IS VERY CLEAR.
OKAY CAN I TALK TO RESPOND I'LL
BE QUICK.
SO I WOULD ALWAYS SAY THE
EVIDENCE ISN'T CLEAR AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BELIEVE ME BECAUSE
I'M FROM INDUSTRY I ITEM BRACE
THAT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE THE
UNDERLYING DATA THERE'S A STUDY
UC BERKELEY RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA LOOKING AT I. Q..
THEY FOUND NO ASSOCIATION WITH
CORPORATE BOSS SAID IN
CINCINNATI FOUND NO ASSOCIATION
WITH CORPORATE VICE. TWO
PUBLICATIONS FROM EUROPE ALSO
KNOWS THIS ISSUE WITH PER
PURIFIES IN LOSS OF I. Q. SO WE
HAVE FOUR STUDIES.
THE SHOW NO ASSOCIATION WITH
CORE PURIFIES IN LOSS OF I. Q..
I'M A GET IT I'M A MOTHER TO WE
DON'T WE WE AGREE THAT WE WANT
TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN I GET
THAT.
BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE FRONT
UNDERLYING SCIENTIFIC DATA.
THAT HAS BEEN ROLLING OUT SINCE
THE COLUMBIA STUDY WAS PUBLISHED
IN THE ISN'T SUPPORTING THOSE
STUDY.
OKAY I MEAN I GUESS I DO TAKE
COMFORT FROM THE FACT THAT THE
BILL AND I UNDERSTAND IT MAY BE
YEAH.
BARS ARE STANDARDS THAT THAT THE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THERE'S TOO
HIGH BUT YOU KNOW IT REALLY.
YOU KNOW IF IF.
WHEN WHEN IF THE DPR FEELS
COMFORTABLE ISSUING YOU THAT
THAT THEY'VE GOT CONTROL
MEASURES IN PLACE THAT ARE
DETERMINED TO BE PRODUCTIVE OF?
CHILDREN'S NO DEVELOPMENT.
THE YEAH THE THE USE OF THE
PESTICIDE WOULD BE.
AND IF WE ALLOWED -- IF AS LONG
AS A DVR DETERMINES IF THERE'S
ENOUGH -- PROTECTION IN PLACE I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT -- YOU
PROTECTION IN THE BILL FOR
INDUSTRY I I GUESS I WOULD I
WOULD SAY THAT -- I WOULD JUST
KIND OF YOU ASKED THAT WE YOU
KNOW.
THIS BILL ISSUES A SERIOUS ISSUE
AND AND IF THERE I DON'T KNOW I
MEAN IF THERE IS SOME.
I I I WOULD ULTIMATELY OBVIOUSLY
PUT.
KIDS HEALTH OVER OVER INDUSTRY --
BUT IF THERE IS SOME WAY IN THE
CASE OF AN OF A CATASTROPHIC
EMERGENCY FOR THE INDUSTRY.
AND ALL THE JOBS AND AND AND THE
CON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SO
SEATED -- THAT THAT WOULD THAT
WE COULD FIGURE OUT A PATH THAT
WOULD PROTECT HEALTH AND THE
KIDS HEALTH.
AND FARMWORKERS SELF WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING THE INDUSTRY AND THAT
WOULD BE A SMART THING FOR US TO
DO AND SO I YOU KNOW I'M.
I ACTUALLY GREW THE CENTER WE WE
ARE NOT -- THIS TAKE A STEP BACK --
IN SO.
I GUESS I I JUST TRY TO GET A
SENSE FROM YOU IF IF IF.
IF YOU WANTED TO EXPLORE THAT
IDEA -- AND AND I WOULD ONLY
TRIBUTARY GOT INTO THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES --
AND I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO TAKE
ANY FROM COMMITMENT RIGHT NOW
BUT IF THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
YOU'D BE ONE SENSE OF TIME
LOOKING INTO AND EXPLORING.
I WITH A COMMITTED LOOK YES WE
COULD SIT DOWN WITH YOUON IT
LIKE YOU SAID UNLIKE COMMITTEE.
YEAH -- UP TO MAKE IN THAT KIND
OF CHANGE BUT I WOULD
WE DON'T PRETEND TO FIX ALL OF
THE ISSUES.
FACING AGRICULTURE.
AND OUR FOOD CROPS WITH THIS
BILL.
WE HAVE A ONE VERY SPECIFIC
MISSION.
AND THAT IS TO PROTECT THOSE
BABIES.
WHERE IN A K<c.cyan> SITUATION FOR</c>
DECADES?
DECADES WE HAVE KNOWN OF THE
HARM THAT IT CAUSES AND IT'S
ONLY GOTTEN CLEARER AND CLEARER.
AND I I WOULD I WOULD SAY THIS
IS AT THIS POINT AT THIS POINT
IT IS ABOUT.
WHAT'S THE CHOICE HERE.
IT SHOULD NOT BE A CHOICE FOR US
A DIFFICULT CHOICE TO PROTECT
THOSE BABIES TO PROTECT THOSE
CHILDREN.
I WOR IN THE FIELDS UNTIL I WAS
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE I KNOW THE
POWER IMBALANCE THAT EXISTS HERE
AND SO WE'RE REACHING OUT YES TO
THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE ALTHOUGH
WE RELY.
ON OUR AGENCIES.
NO DOUBT WE RELY ON OUR AGENCIES
BUT I CAN POINT TO NUMEROUS.
WAYS IN WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
TURNS AROUND AND TELLS OUR
AGENCIES YOU'RE NOT DOING THIS
OR GREAT THAT YOU'RE DOING THAT
AND WE DO.
WE DO INFLUENCE WHAT ARE
AGENCIES DO SO.
I JUST LOOK TO YOU ALL.
YOU KNOW CONSIDER WHAT'S AT
STAKE HERE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE A BEEF TO
GRIND WITH THE CITRUS INDUSTRY.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO WORK
AND DEPEND ON INDUSTRY
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY FOR OUR
SURVIVAL BUT I ALSO KNOW.
WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE FOR THOSE
BABIES AND FOR THOSE PREGNANT
WOMEN AND I'M ASKING IS THAT FOR
THAT.
NARAL -- CONSIDERATION THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND SO MANY OTHER THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO TO SUPPORT
AGRIBUSINESS IN THE STATE BUT IT
SHOULD NOT BE AT THE COST.
OF THESE BABIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES.
AND SO.
OKAY SO I I VERY FOR I'LL TAKE
THAT AS A CLOSE I I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR I AM LIKE I
CAN'T HELP AYE AYE AYE
UNEQUIVOCALLY SUPPORT YOUR YOUR
CORE GOAL HERE.
AND AS I'M CERTAINLY GOING TO GO
FOR IT TODAY AND AND YOU KNOW
LET'S LET'S KEEP THIS DISCUSSION
MOVING.
I I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
THE BILL.
SO MOVED BY SENATOR STERN --
SURGERY PLEASE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER NINE SP FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT AND SENATOR DRYSDALE.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALAN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES NO HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE.
STONE NO Y. CASKEY
.
OKAY -- I BELIEVE THAT ROLL OPEN
ON OKAY ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
SIR.
YOU DO OKAY ART THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER OKAY SO LET'S
CALL IT CENTER COVER EURO -- WE
STILL [inaudible]
CENTER.
THE PANTING IS NOT A ONE THIRTY
RIGHT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WHAT.
ALL RIGHT SO WILL OPEN THE ROLE
RIGHT AFTER THIS BILL YEAH IF
THAT'S OKAY IT'S JUST THAT THE
APPROACH.
STAMBERG HERE FOREVER.
AND WE WE REALLY DO APOLOGIZE
YOU MISTER MAYOR I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE THOUGHT THAT WAS GOING
TO GO QUITE AS LONG BUT I'M HOPE
YOU LEARNED SOMETHING ABOUT
PESTICIDES -- YEAH.
YEAH OKAY SO SENATOR WITH WE
WELCOME YOU -- AND WE WELCOME
OUR PRO TEMAS TEMAS MERIT IS OUR
MAYOR.
GOOD PRESENT SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR
THIS IS ITEM TWENTY TWO YOUR
AGENDAS MEMBERS.
WE WILL.
THANKS.
WHEN I MAKE MY COMING I MAY HAVE
TO LEAVE AN I POD CAM AND I WE
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND REYES ORDERS?
I MEMBERS WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ON ALL THE PREVIOUS GOES AFTER
THIS BILL AND THEN RECESS
BRIEFLY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
CENTERS I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN --
MY COMMENT BY THINKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL AND APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
LISTED ON PAGE. TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH
AMONG OTHER THINGS KEEPS
CONSISTENT THE EXISTING THIRTY
DAYTIME FRAME TO GIVE NOTICE TO
THE PUBLIC OF THE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME PROJECTS APPROVED AS A USED
BY RIGHT.
AND REMOVES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AS THE ENTITY RESPONSIBLE FOR
DETERMINING WHETHER THE LAWSUIT
IS BROUGHT TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
INTEREST WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE AG ON THIS
PIECE AND SO WILL.
WILL HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS WE
JUST WEREN'T ABLE TO DO IT
BEFORE TODAY'S HEARING.
AS WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA FACES
A DUAL CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS.
AND THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH THE RESULTING
BURDENS FALLING PARTICULARLY
HARD ON PEOPLE LIVING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS.
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
AND ABOUT A THIRD OF THOSE ARE
ESTIMATED TO BE LIVING WITH
AMOUNT MENTAL ILLNESS.
IN MONTEREY COUNTY ARE BY INYO
COUNTY PHONE HOMELESSNESS GREW
23% IN THE PAST TWO YEARS AND
IT'S THE HIGHEST LEVEL IN TEN
YEARS WE KNOW THAT HAVING PEOPLE
WITH SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITIONS
LIVING AND SHELTERED RECYCLING
IN AND OUT OF HOSPITALS AND
INCARCERATION.
IS COSTLY TO THE PUBLIC AND
RESULT IN NEEDLESS SUFFERING FOR
THE HOMELESS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE GOOD NEWS S THAT LAST FALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED PROPOSITION TWO THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME INITIATIVE WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE STATE TO ISSUE
TWO BILLION IN BONDS. TO CREATE
TWENTY THOUSAND UNITS A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
HOUSING.
KEEPS PEOPLE INSIDE REDUCING
ILLNESSES AND SUFFERING AND
LOWERING PUBLIC COSTS.
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR HOPES TO
FULFILL THE INTENT OF THE VOTERS
BY CLARIFYING AND STREAMLINING
THE LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND IT AND
ASSOCIATED SERVICES.
LIKE THOSE THAT NO PLACE LIKE
HOME BONDS WILL FIND.
THIS BILL UTILIZES THE
STREAMLINING APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROJECTS
ENVISIONED IN LAST YEAR'S AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO AND APPLIES
THIS PROCESS TO PROPOSITION TO
SUPPORT OF HOUSING IN ORDER TO
EXPEDITE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
SUFFERING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
THE BILL EXPANDS THE DEFINITION
OF SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
INCLUDES THAT SUPPORT OF HOUSING
MAY BE A USE BY RIGHT IN ZONES
WHERE MULTI FAMILY.
AND MIXED USE ARE PERMITTED
CALIFORNIA VOTERS MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THEY WANT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS AND ARE
HOMELESS TO BE SHELTERED AND
CARED.
FOR NO PLACE LIKE HOME GOT MORE
VOTES THAN ANY OTHER MEASURE ON
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
SEVEN FORTY FOUR AM WITH ME
TODAY IS MAY.
DARRYL STEINBERG TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR MERRY
PRESENT A PATIENT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF LIKE AND I
UNDERSTAND I WAS IMPRESSED WITH
THE THOROUGHNESS THAT LESS
DISCUSSION I'M REALLY HAPPY TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY AND BUTTE.
WITH OLD COLLEAGUES IN A
DIFFERENT ROLE -- ENJOYED BY
TINA THOMAS WHO -- I ONLY
ALLOWED NOT TO WEAR A TIE I SO I
PUT SHOULD I BE WEARING ONE WELL
YOUR YOUR WITNESS SORRY REMEMBER
THE PUBLIC I WONDERED ABOUT THAT.
I TRY NOT TO IN MY NEW JOB IS
WHICH IS WHICH IS I CAN -- THE
I'M JOINED BY TINA THOMAS WHO IS --
IS THE PRIMARY DRAFTER ACTUALLY
BEHIND THIS IDEA IN ONE OF THE
LEAD A SEEK WERE.
ATTORNEYS AND ADVOCATES FOR THE
HOMELESS IN CALIFORNIA AND MY
FRIEND -- SO I'M ACTUALLY HERE
ON BEHEST OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY THE
INSTITUTE -- HUMBLY IN A IN MY
NAME WHERE WE ARE [inaudible]
WORKING WITH.
VERY GOOD PEOPLE NOW TO TRY TO
HELP YOU TRANSFORM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA.
OF NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
ESSENTIALLY TO SAY THAT THERE
MUST BE STATEWIDE APPROACHES TO
USING THESE PRECIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH DOLLARS AND SO WE WE
THOUGHT WHAT IF WE SECURITIZED.
SECURITIZED A TWENTY FIVE YEARS
WORTH OF SMALL INCREMENTS OF THE
MONEY.
AND CREATED A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
HOUSING BOND HOUSE THE HOMELESS
MENTALLY ILL.
AND SO IT PASSED IS CENTER
COPIER SAID I WANT TO THANK HER
FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND ALL SHIP
HERE.
IT PASSED MORE VOTES THAN ANY
OTHER INITIATIVE ON THE BALLOT
WHICH A FIRM IS WHAT I'VE KNOWN
FOR A LONG TIME WHICH IS THAT
THERE IS A VERY SILENT -- BUT
EVER GROWING CONSTITUENCY AROUND
MAKING MENTAL HEALTH.
A PRIORITY IN THIS STATE.
WE WANT TO PUT THESE RESOURCES
TO WORK.
BECAUSE THE TRADITIONAL WAY
RESPECTFULLY AND I WAS PART OF
THIS PROBLEM AS WELL I THAT WE
DO THESE BIG IN GREAT THINGS IN
AND IT TAKES.
FOREVER SEEMINGLY. FOR THE MONEY
TO GET OUT.
WE KNOW THIS WHEN IT COMES TO
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
CHRONIC MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
ON THE STREETS FOR A LONG TIME.
THE COMBINATION OF A NEW.
AND SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES.
TOGETHER WITH APPLYING THE BEST
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY GOTTEN PEOPLE OFF
THE STREET.
TOGETHER WITH WILL AND I SAY
THAT.
IN A BROAD.
SENSE AND NOW THEY WERE IN
IMMINENT A VERY SPECIFIC SENSE
COMBINED WITH WILL.
WILL HELP US GET THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS.
HOW IS THAT WILL WE NOW HAVE THE
MONEY?
WE KNOW WHAT WORKS THE
COMBINATION OF ASSERTIVE OUT
REACH INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
TRIAGE HOUSING PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE CARE AND TREATMENT.
HOW DO WE SUPPLY THE WILL?
THE WILL IS SUPPLIED IN PART BY
CHANGING THE LAWS WHICH MAKE IT
SO DARN DIFFICULT TO SITE.
THESE WERE THE PROJECTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE [inaudible]
IT'S LEGENDARY.
YESTERDAY WE APPROVE CITING A
TRIAGE SHELTER.
IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO I HOPE
YOU WILL ALL BENEFIT FROM THAT
AS PEOPLE WHO WORK IN AND AROUND
THE LEGISLATURE. TWO THINGS ARE
VERY CLEAR AND IT WAS STATED
VERY CLEARLY.
THE MORE SITES YOU TAKE OFF THE
TABLE.
FIRST IF YOU WERE SITES THE ROD
LOCATE ANYTHING.
AND SECONDLY PEOPLE MAY NOT
WANTED IN THEIR BACKYARD.
BUT WORSE THAN THAT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE THE
CONTINUED EXPLOSION IN GROWTH OF
HOMELESSNESS IN THEIR BACKYARD
IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND SO THIS IS AN ATTEMPT. TO
TAKE SOME OF THE PRESIDENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
ADDRESSED TO BUY RIGHT IN
THROUGH.
MODEST REVISION OF OUR
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS TO
SAY WHEN IT COMES TO LOCATING SB
TWO PROJECTS NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
MAKE IT EASIER TO BUILD.
MAKE IT MORE OF A BY RIGHT.
DON'T LET NO BE THEIR FIRST IN
REFLEXIVE ANSWER WHICH IT TOO
OFTEN IS.
AND THIS BILL IN COMBINATION
THOSE RESOURCES IN COMBINATION
WITH APPLYING THE ELEMENTS THAT
WE KNOW WILL WORK TO GET PEOPLE
OF ST GIVE US A REAL CHANCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
Q. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS STAMBERG
[inaudible]
I'VE YES MA'AM -- I'LL I'LL BE
HERE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS I DON'T NEED TO
TESTIFY THANK YOU.
SO DOES ANYONE HAVE A PARTICULAR
QUESTION THE MERS GOTTA LEAVE --
SO ANYONE HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE MAYOR BEFORE.
AT THIS TO AN OVER AN HOUR OKAY.
OTHERWISE OTHER AND THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL OKAY. THIRTY CENTER
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE YES YES
MA'AM.
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS RESERVE ATTACK A
QUESTIONS OKAY GOTCHA.
OKAY WILL ANYONE ELSE WANT TO
WEIGH IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MALLORY SPOKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH A RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY OUR FOLKS WINERIES
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
YOU CAN COME UP [inaudible]
YEAH.
ARE YOU GUYS ARE ALWAYS FIGHTING
AT THE HE'S A REALLY NICE GUY.
YOUR MEMBERS THEM HOME FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IS LIMITED TO THE
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW
PORTION RIGHT WING.
I WHY IS THIS GOING TO ADD YOU
DISH.
VERY GOOD QUESTION.
BUT THE THE TUESDAY AND THE ALL
OF THE REMAINING ISSUES IN THE
BILL OR OUTSIDE OUR PURVIEW --
AND IF THE IF THE X. RIDE REVIEW
WERE REMOVED WE WOULD REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION.
VERY QUICKLY BECAUSE YOU'VE
HEARD ME ON THIS TOPIC MULTIPLE
TIMES.
AND IS A FORMER LONG TERM --
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL DISABILITIES IT'S
UNQUESTIONABLY IMPORTANT THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE.
THE TARGET OF THIS BILL AND THAT
WOULD BE ADVANTAGE BY THIS BILL
HOWEVER.
TAKING THIS SUPER XCELERATED
JUDICIAL REVIEW APPROACH AND
APPLYING IT JUST TO THIS
PARTICULAR.
CATEGORY OF CASE WORK TO THE
DISADVANTAGE OF A VARIETY OF
OTHER LITIGANTS WHO HAVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE COURTS
INCLUDING -- LITIGATION
INVOLVING ISSUES THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS JUST BEEN HEARING
THIS MORNING FOR EXAMPLE.
THE BILL BY SENATOR HUESO
DEALING WITH WATER CONTAMINATION
IF LAWSUIT IS BROUGHT DEALING
WITH THAT INCREDIBLE PROBLEM
AFFECTING.
MANY YEAH COUNTLESS AT
CALIFORNIANS THAT LED THE
LITIGATION MOVED TO THE BACK OF
THE LINE AND DOES NOT GET THE
CALENDAR PREFERENCE -- WHAT
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE THE BILL
THAT YOU JUST HEARD BY SENATOR
TO RAZA -- IF A PERSONAL INJURY
ACTION IS BROUGHT.
ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY BRAIN DAMAGED AS A
RESULT OF PESTICIDE
CONTAMINATION.
THAT CASE IS NOT GET THE ALTAR
CALENDAR PREFERENCE THAT BILLS
LIKE THIS PROVIDE SO WE'RE NOT
HERE TO TAKE ISSUE WITH THE
IMPORTANCE OF CREATING MORE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL DISABILITIES.
IT'S UNQUESTIONABLY A VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
OBJECTIVE NO ONE CAN TAKE.
ISSUE WITH THAT.
BUT THE UNDERLYING JUDICIAL
CONSTRUCT THAT THE THAT THAT
THIS PORTION OF THE BILL IS
BASED NOT THE ENTIRE BILL.
BUT THAT THIS PORTION OF THE
BILL IS BASED UPON IS IF IT WAS
FLAWED FROM ITS INCEPTION.
AND WE URGE YOU NOT TO CONTINUE
TO REPLICATE AND EXPAND ITS
APPROACH BECAUSE THE UNDERLYING
PREMISE THAT FOUNDATION FOR THIS
XCELERATED JUDICIAL REVIEW.
IS THIS OPPOSE IT CERTAINTY THAT
COMES WITH THIS SUPER
ACCELERATED TURNAROUND TIME FOR
THE TRIAL IN THE APPELLATE
COURTS TO FINISH THEIR WORK.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
THAT DOES NOT EXIST IN THE REAL
WORLD.
BECAUSE TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE
PROJECTS ARE CHALLENGED THEY
WILL UNDOUBTEDLY BE CHALLENGED
BY.
VERY DETERMINED OPPONENTS OFTEN
VERY WELL RESEARCHED OPPONENTS.
WHO WILL BE VERY CREATIVE IN
BRINGING BOTH SEE C<c.cyan> AND NON</c>
SEQUEL CAUSES OF ACTION WE'VE
SEEN THAT IN SOME OF THE PROJECT
TO DATE -- I'M NOT CONDONING
THAT KIND OF LITIGATION BUT THE
REALITY IS THOSE CASES WILL BE
BROUGHT.
THEY WILL HAVE SECRET AND NON
SEQUEL PORTIONS AND YOU ARE
TAKING JUST A PORTION OF THE
LITIGATION MOVING IT TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE.
AT THE EXPENSE OF ALL OTHER
LITIGANTS ON THE DOCKET WITH OUT
GETTING THE CERTAINTY.
IT'S SUPPOSEDLY COMES FROM THIS
APPROACH SO WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
AND UNDERSTANDING ABSOLUTELY THE
INTENTION.
BEHIND THE BILL IN THE IMPORTANT
PUBLIC POLICY OBJECTIVES WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ARE OPPOSED WE WISH
THAT YOU COULD PROCEED FRANKLY
WITH THE OTHER PORTIONS OF THE
BILL WE UNDERSTAND THAT
CLARIFYING THE USE BY RIGHT.
AND THE THINGS THAT WERE DONE I
KNOW SOME OF MY ENVIRONMENTAL
FRIENDS MAY HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
THEIR APPROACH BUT OUR
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE AND CONCERN
WOULD BE REMOVED IF THAT PORTION
OF THE BILL.
WERE TAKEN OUT AND AND SO
RESPECTFULLY WE ORDER NO VOTE --
BUT ON THAT SOUL BASS. FIVE GOOD
AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON US SENATORS ARE
BRAND ALSO IS YOUR CALL
CALIFORNIA -- THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME JUST APPRECIATED
A OF WE APPRECIATE THE OTHER
TAKING MMS REGARDING THE TEN DAY
NOTICE REQUIREMENT.
AND THE TWENTY FEWER WORDS --
HOWEVER WE STUFF CONCERNS ABOUT
SB -- SEVEN FORTY FOUR FIRST WE
WANT TO NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH MANY
MAY NOT BELIEVE THIS WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THE GOAL OF FINDING A
SOLUTION TO THE HOUSING CRISIS
BY BUILDING SUPPORTIVE.
OPEN MERGING CA AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE UNDERSTAND SYMPATHIZE
WITH THE AUTHOR ABOUT THE NEED
TO DO SO HOWEVER WE OPPOSED TO
THE PROCESS BY WHICH SEVEN FORTY
FOR ANOTHER BILLS LIKE IT.
GO THROUGH TO GET THIS DONE --
BY PROVIDING IN OUR VIEW IS NOT
NECESSARY TO CREATE NEW SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS ARE STREAMLINED A
SECRET PROCESS TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS GOAL AND IT TO DO SO ONLY
PROPAGATES THIS MISLEADING
NARRATIVE THAT COMMUNITIES NEED.
NEED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN SUPPORT
OF HOUSING AND A STRONG SEEK A
NOT ONLY DOES SB SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN FORTY FOUR EXAMPLES
PROJECTS AND SEQUEL THE DOG
ACTUALLY GOES A STEP FURTHER AND
LIMITING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
AN EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW FOR
THESE PROJECTS NOW I'M HAVING A
A LITTLE BIT OF A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING HOW YOU CAN EXEMPT
SOMETHING FROM SEQUEL.
YET STILL LIMIT SEEK WAS
IMPORTANT MECHANISMS OF
PROVISIONS BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
VERY WELL THAT DOING SO WOULD
HAVE AN UNDOUBTED I'M
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN OTHER
COMMUNITIES.
THE BEST PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S
AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS
SUBSTANTIVE SEQUEL RIGHTS THE
LEGISLATURE NEED TO FOLLOW THE
PROCESS THAT'S THE GROUT.
AND THE JUDICIAL REVIEW PROCESS
IS THAT SHE WAS ONLY OF COURSE
MECHANISM WHEN YOU CUT THE
REVIEW PERIOD SHORTAGE TWENTY
SEVENTY DAYS YOUR EFFECTIVELY
COULD TELLING THAT PROCESS AND
TELLING.
THE YEARS CONSTITUENTS THAT THE
POP ON THE SUBSTANCE OF SEEK WAS
NOT AS IMPORTANT AS BUILDING
THESE PROJECTS.
LASTLY AND MANY IN THE BUILDING
AND BOTH THE LEGISLATURE AND
EXECUTIVE BRANCHES OF THE
GOVERNMENT ABOUT IT SOME
INTEGRATION OF IF WE CAN'T IF WE
CAN BUILD THESE PROJECTS AND
GIVE EXTRA YOU JUST REVIEW. FOR
STADIUMS WE CAN DO SO FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ONE NINE AND
WHILE I ADMIRE THE DESIRE TO BE
CONSISTENT FIRST TAKING THE FULL
ENFORCEMENT POWER SEEK WHICH NOT
BE THE STARTING POINT. FOR
BUILDING NEW DEVELOPMENT AND
COMPLETELY REMOVING OF NEW
DEVELOPMENT FROM C. QUESTION NOT
BE IT SHOULD BE A NON STARTER
CONSIDERING ONE THE LEGISLATURE
AND STATES STRONG COMMITMENT TO
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION.
INTO THE NUMEROUS STREAMLINING
EFFORTS FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
UNDERSEA BARTY ALLIED.
SO WITH THAT WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR NOBLE -- AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO FIND SOME SORT OF NO
GROUND THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS A COMMITTEE BRINA WIKI
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY I AGREE WITH ALL OF
THE POINTS THAT - HERE CALL
CALIFORNIA JUST RAISED IF I MAY
SPEAK VERY QUICKLY.
TWO POINTS AND I WILL MAKE A
VERY BRIEF ONE IS UP THERE WAS
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT FOR THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME.
BALLOT MEASURE I MYSELF
SUPPORTED THAT -- BUT THAT
MEASURE DID NOT INCLUDE THAT
THERE WOULD BE A A REDUCTION IN
THE AMOUNT OF PUBLIC OVERSIGHT
AND THE REDUCTION AND ANY
IMPACTS TO ERNIE UNDERMINING OF
SYKORA ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
PROJECTS.
AND AND THAT LEADS ME TO MY
SECOND POINT WHICH IS THAT.
INHERENT IN THE BILL IS THIS
FAITH.
THAT THE CITY COUNCIL OR THE
PLANNING -- BODY THAT APPROVES
THESE PROJECTS CUSTER ARE HAVE
HAVE BANISTER COMES BACK AS THEY
NEED TO BE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THESE
PROJECTS AND THAT IS SIMPLY NOT
MY EXPERIENCE THAT IS NOT
EXPERIENCE OF THE CENTER FOR
BALLOT UNIVERSITY EVEN WHILE WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
BUILDING.
HOUSING FOR THE FOR DRESSING THE
HOMELESS ISSUE AND FOR INFILL
HOUSING -- TO SAY THAT THERE TO
REMOVE THE SICKER MOVES OUR
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY MAKE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THE CHANGES.
THAT REDUCE OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS ON THESE OF THESE
PROJECTS ALLOWING THOSE PROJECTS
TO GO FORWARD BUT MAKING THE
CHANGES THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
REDUCE THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M.
OKAY THE MATTERS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE I'M WHAT ONE THING.
THAT I'VE I WOULD LIKE TO BRING
UP.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO PASS THIS.
ARE WE DON'T.
GAP SITUATION WHERE.
A NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROJECT.
IS PART OF A BIGGER PROJECT.
THAT INVOLVES A LOT OF OTHER
STUFF.
AND THAT THAT BIGGER PROJECT.
GETS THE ADVANTAGE OF THE
EXPEDITED REVIEW [inaudible]
I WHEN IT WHEN THE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME PORTION IS ONLY A SMALL
PORTION BECAUSE WE ARE WE REALLY
ARE I MEAN I DON'T I DON'T
DISAGREED ANYTHING THE
OPPOSITION TO SET IN AND I YOU
KNOW I CONTINUE TO BE.
I'VE WARILY APPROACHING THIS
STUFF -- BUT YOU KNOW I I AM
KIND ACUTELY AWARE OF THE THE
THE POLICY INTERESTS AT PLAY
HERE WITH REGARDS -- TO THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME INITIATIVE AND
BY THE WAY I I REALIZE RELATING
TO DO THIS BECAUSE IT WAS TRIPLE
REFERRED ARE YOU WANT TO GO INTO
FINANCE AND HOUSING -- YOU KNOW
AND AND IT I THINK IT SPEAKS TO
THE ENORMOUS.
I'M REPORTS THAT WERE PLACING ON
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
I'VE THE THE ISSUES AT THE HEART
OF NO PLACE LIKE HOME BUT I'M.
WHEN YOU KNOW I'M NOT GONNA ASK
YOU TO MAKE IT?
A COMMUNITY PARTICULAR LANGUAGE
NOW BUT I'D LIKE YOU TO RESPOND
TO THIS ISSUE WHICH IS VERY
MEANINGFUL TO ME.
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE REALLY
NARROW THIS VERY GENEROUS
EXPEDITING.
I TO THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROJECT THEMSELVES AS OPPOSED TO
HAVING THE BIG BE PART OF A
BIGGER PROJECT.
EVEN YOU RAISE A REALLY GOOD
POINT NEVER CONSIDERED THAT.
ANYTHING ELSE WOULD BE IN
ADDITION TO THE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME HOUSING THAT'S ALL WE
INTEND AND SO IF WE NEED.
TO BE SPECIFIC ABOUT THAT --
WERE MORE THAN HAPPY BECAUSE
THERE'S NO INTENTION TO DO URBAN
RENEWAL RIGHT -- IT'S TO BE ABLE
TO I MEAN IT MAY ACTUALLY END UP.
IMPROVING AND NEIGHBORHOOD BUT
IT'S TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
HOUSING THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
GETTING AT OKAY HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS WE COULD WORK ON ON A
MAN'S LANGUAGE YES LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD JUST WHERE THERE'S SURE
THAT BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE AT A
REAL I AM.
VERY PROBLEMATIC LOOPHOLE IF IF
WE GET THAT ADDRESS AND THAT'S
OUR INTENTION OKAY SO I WE HAVE
NO PROBLEM WITH IT OKAY
SANDERSON.
THANK YOU MISTER AND SENATOR
KERREY -- I POLICE OF OR YOUR
YOUR DESIRE -- TO MITIGATE THE
HOMELESS PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IN
IN THE IN CALIFORNIA AND I'VE
LEARNED BEING A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT -- ALWAYS VERY DIFFICULT IF
YOU HAVE A PRISON IF YOU HAVE A
HOMELESS SHELTER.
AIRPORT -- ALL THE NEWBIES COME
OUT AND MAKE IT A VERY DIFFICULT
DECISION SOMETIMES FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS SO -- IN A AND I'M ONE
THAT LIKE SICK WAS STREAMLINING
AND I LIKE ARGUMENT.
THAT WAS THAT WAS MADE BUT FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS THAT IF WE CAN
EXAMPLE.
FOOTBALL STADIUMS A BASKETBALL
STADIUMS -- WHEN WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS WHY WOULD WE DO
AN EXPEDITED AN ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW?
BUT I ALSO.
CAME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND SO I WANT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND.
HOW I'M GONNA BE ABLE?
TO EVALUATE A PROJECT.
AND MITIGATE IMPACTS SO.
HOWWOULD A DEVELOPER APPROACH --
COUNTY OR CITY.
WITH RESPECT TO THE CITY OR THE
COUNTY'S GENERAL PLAN SO LET'S
SAY YOU HAVE AN INFILL PROJECT
IN -- IN A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
LET'S SAY YOU'RE ALLOWING YOU
KNOW FIVE TO THE ACRE OKAY AND
YOU GOT A FEW LOTS OF AVAILABLE
SOMEBODY SAYS I'M GONNA BUY THAT
PIECE OF INFO ON I'M GONNA.
I'M GONNA GO SIX STORIES UP.
WOULD YOUR BILL BASICALLY.
ALLOW A SIX STORY PROJECT IN A
RESIDENTIAL AREA.
THAT DOESN'T THAT HAS HEIGHT
RESTRICTIONS WITH THE NEW
GENERAL PLAN OR WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO TO ADDRESS THAT OR WHAT IF
YOU'RE IN A LOCK PATTERN YOU
KNOW THAT THEY COULD EITHER A
LOCK.
GET IN THE WAY OF HI
RESTRICTIONS OR OR EVEN --
TONIGHT THE PROJECT.
WHAT?
IF YOU HAVE IF YOU HAVE A SIX
STORY.
BUILDING LET'S SAY IT'S GOING TO
HAVE -- TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
UNITS -- AND YOU'RE ON A
NEIGHBORHOOD STREET IS GOING TO
BE SOME TRAFFIC IMPACTS OUR
PEOPLE GOING TO GET AN EMERGENCY
VEHICLES GET IN AND GET OUT.
HOW HOW DOES LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FIT INTO ALL OF THIS KNOWING
THAT THEIR REVIEW IS GOING TO BE
LIMITED?
WELL LET ME LET ME START OFF BY
SAYING THAT THAT -- THIS.
ANTICIPATES THE DROP TO COMPLY
WITH ALL OF THE RULES AND
RESTRICTIONS THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE.
INCLUDING THE GENERAL PLAN
INCLUDING THE GENERAL PLAN IN
MANY INCLUDING ANY ANY STATE
RULES SAY YOU CAN DO DENSITY
BONUSES AND AND LOCAL IT IT IF
IT'S INCLUSIONARY.
RIVER REQUIREMENTS ALL THAT KIND
OF AND YOU YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE --
TO TO VIOLATE THE THE HEIGHT
RESTRICTIONS IN OTHER WORDS IF
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THE E. I.
R. AND IN.
THROUGH THAT WHOLE PROCESS THEN
THEN IT IT'S A BY RIGHT
[inaudible]
ARMED.
AS PER THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
AND WHAT ABOUT A FEES AS AN
EXAMPLE IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY WE
HAVE A THE WESTERN REGIONAL
COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS.
THAT IMPOSES A TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR FEE O EVERY HOME TO PAY
FOR REGIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
YOU'RE BUILDING TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WITH A BE RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING
THOSE FEES LIKE ANY OF THE
DEVELOPER WOULD YES.
OKAY AND THEN HOW ABOUT TRAFFIC
MITIGATION WHAT WENT DOWN
CONTROLS WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE -- TO REQUIRE
IMPROVEMENTS IN AROUND TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
EMERGENCY VEHICLES AND GET TO
THE THE FACILITY THE
FOUNDATIONAL DOCUMENTS LIKE THE
GENERAL PLAN THE HOUSING ELEMENT
ALL APPLY AND ASSEMBLY.
WHEN AN AGENCY ADOPTS THE
GENERAL PLAN OR A SPECIFIC PLAN
OR?
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT THEY ALSO
INCLUDE OBJECTIVE STANDARDS THAT
MUST BE MET BY A PROJECT.
IN THESE WERE NOT EXEMPTING
THESE PROJECTS THIS OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS.
OKAY WELL I APPRECIATE -- YOU
BRING US FOR DO YOU.
USE MY CONCERNS WITH THEIR
ANSWERS AND I'M HAPPY WORKABLE.
THANK YOU OKAY THIS IS ROGER I
THINK YOU ON THE SENATOR STONE
COVERED.
HI MIKE.
MY CONCERNS.
HI I ACTUALLY HAVE SEEN THE LAST
OF MY HADN'T HAVE SOME OF THOSE
ANSWERED THAT.
I HE WENT THROUGH A LAUNDRY LIST
pI I STILL HAVE A CONCERN
REGARDING ALL MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENTS WHERE THERE ARE
VACANT LOTS BUT THEY'RE COVERED
BY CC IN OURS.
WHICH CAN BE MORE RESTRICTIVE --
THEN WHAT IS LAID OUT A GENERAL
PLAN OR THE SONY HOW WOULD THOSE
BE AFFECTED ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
BILL ALLOWS. FOR ON SITE
SERVICES THAT WOULD.
SEEM TO ME FOR SOME WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND THERE THERE
COULD BE.
YOU KNOW IT IT'S ALMOST LIKE
RUNNING A ON AN ASSISTED LIVING
FOR THOSE IN THAT CATEGORY.
HOW WOULD THIS AFFECT?
THE DEVELOPMENTS THAT DO HAVE
VERY STRICT CCAR'S REGARDING --
THE USES PARKING AND ALL ABOUT.
I AND THAT WOULD BE A PROBLEM IN
A NUMBER OF MY SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITIES I BELIEVE --
CC IN OURS WOULD STILL EXIST
THEY RUN WITH THE LAND SO THEY
WOULD NOT EVAPORATE BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL YES OKAY.
GOT THAT ON RECORD THEN I'M
SUPPORTING IT [inaudible]
OKAY ARE.
SO THAT UNDERSTANDING YOU KNOW
I'M I'M I I GOT I I MEAN IT'S
NOT WITHOUT SOME.
SOME CONCERN THAT I AMONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL -- YOU KNOW
DID THE PREVIOUS BILLS THAT WE
LOOKED AT THAT LOOKED AT SEA
QUEST -- STREAMLINING DID
PROVIDE PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED YOUNG LEAD GOLD
[inaudible]
IN.
MANAGE YOUR ENERGY GHG.
I WHICH ARE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT I
THINK THERE WAS A RECOGNITION
BOTH OF THIS SOME OF THE UPPER
BILL THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
WORK THAT IS REALLY A CATERED --
TO ARE MST IMPOVERISHED AND
MOST VULNERABLE.
I MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
AND YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY.
IN THE SENATE IT DOESN'T HERE
ALL THE TIME FROM I MEMBERS OF
THEIR COMMUNITY ABOUT CONCERNS
OVER HOMELESSNESS.
THE INTERPLAY WITH HOUSING
CRISIS.
AND SO IT IS WITH ITS ITH THAT
AND AND WITH THE THE VERY
EXPLICIT INTERESTING THAT WE'RE
GONNA MAKE SURE THIS IS ONLY
NARROWED. TOO EXPLICIT NO AND IN
A PLACE LIKE HOME PROJECTS THAT
THAT I'M I'M AMONG THE SUPPORT
THIS [inaudible]
I TODAY.
THEN DONE YOU KNOW IT IS AN
IMMENSELY IMPORTANT INITIATIVE
AND THAT'S WHY.
ARE MAYOR WAS HERE -- BUT I YOU
KNOW I I DO CONTINUE TO TO SHARE
A NUMBER OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED BY THE IDEA OF THE
OPPOSITION -- SO.
WITH THAT I I THIS IS ONLY A
QUESTIONS ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
AND IT'S BEEN IN MOTION AFTER
YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY SO THE
QUESTIONS.
OKAY SO THERE'S BEEN A MOTION --
WE WILL WORK.
TOGETHER WITH YOU MOVING FORWARD
ON THIS -- SO ME GETS OUT TODAY
MOVE MOVE BY CENTER STONE SUCH A
PRETTY COLOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR CABALLERO
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BATES BATES AYE HILL
[inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE.
STONE IRAQ OWSKI.
OKAY SO WILL HOLD THAT OPEN --
FOR OTHER AT A MEMBERS TO ADD ON
I'M.
THANK YOU AND THEN THE OTHER
ITEM IS ON CONSENT YES YOUR
OTHER ITEMS ON CONSENT AND
ACTUALLY WITH THAT WHEN WE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVE BY CENTER STONE AS SUCH A
PIECE KALRA CONSENT CALENDAR --
CONSENT ITEMS ARE AT THAT
CALENDAR ITEMS NUMBER SEVEN
NUMBER FIFTEEN AND NUMBER --
TWENTY ONE ALAN AYE ALLEN AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE.
HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE [inaudible]
NAY STERN.
OKAY SO CENTERED CABALLERO BOTH
YOUR BILLS ARE OUT -- WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN ON BOTH OF THOSE
AND THEN TAX ACCOUNTED TO ALLOW
THE MEMBERS THAT ON OKAY SO
LET'S STARTGOING THROUGH THE
AGENDA SO WE CAN ALLOW MEMBERS
TO VOTE.
I SB FOR THOSE MCGUIRE BILL THAT
WAS PULLED THAT WAS ROLLED INTO
THE SB.
FIFTY MASTER BASHER.
AND SO WE'LL SEE WHERE THAT GOES
ON NOW THE NEXT BILL THAT WE'VE
HEARD IS MY BILL SB. FIFTY NINE
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THAT
CENTER SKINNER.
I THINK SENATE BILL CENTER BATES
LIKE.
TO TO OKAY SO THE VICE CHAIR
MOVES THE BILL.
HI THIS IS SB FIFTY NINE ALLEN
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ITEM.
FOR SECRETARY PLEASE COLOR.
I REMEMBER FOR SB FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN
HI ALLEN HI BATES.
BATES AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE STONE IOWA CASKEY.
OKAY SO THAT HAS ENOUGH LET'S
GET I BELIEVE THAT ROLE OPEN.
I'D SENATOR JACKSON'S BILL THIS
SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR REALLY INTO
THIS -- TOBACCO PRODUCTS
INTERJECTIONS AS BEFORE.
TWENTY FOUR THERE SKINNER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MOVE THAT.
OKAY SO MOVED BY CENTER SKINNER
SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR ITEM.
EIGHT EXHIBITS CHOLERA.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AS BEFORE
TWENTY FOUR MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ALLEN HI ALLEN HI BATES
[inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE NO WAY CASKEY.
OKAY SO WILL HOLD THAT OPEN
THAT'S THE TWO TO ONE OKAY
SENATOR RASS BILL I THINK
EVERYBODY'S VOTE ON THAT WHEN
THE THE ONE WE JUST HEARD YES.
OKAY SO NEXT WE'LL HEAR IT WILL
DO I'VE CENTER MORLOCKS BILL AS
AMENDED SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE THIS
IS THE SCOPING PLAN RELATED BILL
THEY'VE WILDFIRES.
SO THIS ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE SO CENTER MORE LOCK
EYES SUBSTANTIVELY -- AMENDED
THE BILL AND DONE IT THE
OPPOSITION IS DROPPED ITS
OPPOSITION AND AT THE CHAIR IS
NOW WE'RE NOW RECOMMENDING AYE
VOTE -- IT BASICALLY -- WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT WILDFIRES BUT IT
WON'T IMPLICATE.
THE EXISTING SCOPING PLAN UNDER --
THE RB BUT IT WILL BUT WILL BE
LOOKING AT WILDFIRES AS AS AN
IMPACT.
AS I THINK IT'S A GOOD WIN WIN.
THE SOMEONE LIKE TO MOVE
[inaudible]
THAT.
MOVE BY CENTER STONE AS EXHIBITS
COLORFUL.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB FIVE THREE
FIVE MOTION IS D. PASSES AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE STONE I WAY CASKEY.
OKAY SO HOW THE ROBIN ON THAT NO
MOVED ITEM FOURTEEN THIS SB SIX
THIRTY TWO GALGIANI BILL.
AS AMENDED ONCE AGAIN SIGNIFICAN
AMENDED FROM HOW IT WAS
ORIGINALLY WRITTEN AND AND
EVERYBODY'SHAPPY I CENTER STONE.
AS MOVED IT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND I'M NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SIX
THIRTY TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE HILL.
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
LAKE OWSKI.
OKAY I WILL HOLD OPEN NOW ONE
ONE ITEM SIXTEEN THIS IS A
CENTER MITCHELL'S BILL REALLY IN
A METAL CONTAINING JEWELERY.
SB.
SIX FORTY SEVEN MOVED BY VICE
CHAIR SUCH A PLEASE CORAL ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN SB SIX FORTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE
AYE BATES.
BATES AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE STONE I LIKE HOW SCHEME.
OKAY WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN THIS
ITEM SEVENTY THIS SB.
SIX FIFTY NINE SIGNIFICANTLY
AMENDED THE BILL ALL ORIGINALLY
REQUIRED.
I THE AWARDING OF ATTORNEYS FEES.
ARE AND NOW WE'VE WE'VE SO WHILE
UPS READ THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE I
MOST OF YOU WEREN'T HERE THIS IS
AN AMEND.
ON THIS BILL IF PASSED OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY WILL GO TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND I RAISED
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE
AUTHORS PROPOSED THE MEN'S --
BUT YOU SAID THAT I WAS ONE
SUPPORT TODAY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO FLUSH OUT SOME THE
IMPLICATIONS.
AYE AYES THE BILL GOES ON TO THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
BUT HERE'S THE LANGUAGE SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY NINE WILL
AUTHORIZE THE COURT TOWARD
ATTORNEY'S FEES TO A PREVAILING
PARTY THAT IS A RESPONDENT OR
REAL PARTY IN INTEREST.
WHEN THE COURT FINDS PETITIONER
USE ACTIONS TACTICS OR CLAIMS
MADE UNREASONABLY OR IN BAD
FAITH THAT ARE FRIVOLOUS OR
INTENDED TO CAUSE UNNECESSARY
DELAY?
THIS THING WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
FOR DIFFERENT STANDARD FOR
REWARDING ATTORNEY'S FEES FOR
THOSE INFILL HOUSING DEVELOPER
OBJECTS AND WHAT IS CURRENTLY
PROVIDED AN EXISTING LAW.
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF SOME OF THESE
CHANGES AS IT GOES OVER TO
SENATE JUDICIARY I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE.
ON CENTER BOARD IS BILL MOVE BY
A CENTER STONE SUCH A PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN SB SIX FIVE
NINE AM IN MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN STONE STONE AT
WACO SKI.
OKAY SO WILL THAT OPEN NOW MOVED
AYE AYE AND EIGHTEEN THIS IS SB
SIX SIXTY SEVEN WESSELS BILL ON
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
A MOVE BY CENTER STONE'S
ACTIVITIES CORAL.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN SB SIX SIX
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALAN AYE ALLEN AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE STONE I Y. CASKEY.
OKAY WELL THAT OPEN NOW GOING
ITEM NINETEEN THIS IS SB SIX
NINETY IT ACTUALLY HAS BEEN
VOTED ON BUT I WANNA LET SOME
FOLKS OUT ON SICK TO PLEASE
KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN SB SIX
NINETY THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING I BATES M. VICE CHAIR
BUILDING I HILL [inaudible]
S. STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE I LIKE IT.
OKAY.
SO THAT'S FIVE ZERO NOW WILL --
WILL KEEP IT OPEN -- FOR A
COUPLE MORE MEMBERS THAT ON I
AND THEN FINALLY A COUPLE HEROES
SB.
SEVEN FORTY FOUR THIS IS THE THE
ONE WE JUST HEARD I THINK THAT
EVERYONE.
EVERYONE WAS ON THAT.
SKINNER AS WELL.
OKAY GREAT SO THIS ON THIS -- IT
COVERS ALL OF OUR BILLS FOR NOW
WE WE WE PLAN ON A TWELVE THE
ONE RECESS BUT THEY CAN BE
TWELVE THE TWELVE THIRTY TO ONE
WILL BE RIGHT BACK HERE IN ONE
HALF HOUR.
WITH THE WITH THE REMAINING
BILLS -- FOR ET WHAT YEAH WANT
ONE O'CLOCK SO SO THIRTY MINUTES
WILL BE BACK.
WILL BE RECESSED UNTIL THEN
TRYING TO GET EVERYONE COME BACK
NOW BUT I'M.
WHEN YOU GET A STARTED WITH --
SB.
FORTY EIGHT INTERIM HOUSING
INTERVENTION DEVELOPMENTS YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN WHEN READY.
I THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE --
FOR WORKING WITH US IN WITHIN
ALICE'S.
I SENATE BILL FORTY EIGHT WILL
CREATE A NEW I STREAMLINING
PROGRAM FOR INTERIM SHELTER
DEVELOPMENTS ALSO KNOWN AS
NAVIGATION CENTERS.
OF THE GOAL WHICH IS TO EXPEDITE
APPROVAL OF A HIGH QUALITY LOW
BARRIER SHELTERS TO CONNECT
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
SERVICES IN PERMANENT HOUSING --
ONLY NAVIGATION CENTERS THAT
MEET ALL APPLICABLE HEALTH
SAFETY AND BUILDING CODES --
THAT ALLOW FOR THE PRESENCE OF
PARTNERS PATTERSON STORAGE OF
POSSESSIONS.
THE PROVIDE PRIVACY UNDER
OTHERWISE LOW BARRIER AND OFFER
SERVICES TO CONNECT PEOPLE TO
BERMAN HOUSING.
ONLY BE USED NAVIGATION CENTERS
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR STREAMLINED
THE GOAL HERE IS TO INCENTIVIZE.
THESE ARE VERY -- I THINK
IMPROVED VERSIONS OF THE
TRADITIONAL HOMELESS SHELTER.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES -- TO A HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW REGARDING ZONING -- AND
SPECIFICALLY WHERE I CITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO ZONE FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS -- AS A PERMITTED BY
RIGHT USE.
ARE CURRENTLY US CITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO IDENTIFY THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT -- AS OWNER MORE
THAN ONE'S OWN OP FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS I AND ALTHOUGH MORE
MORE CITIES ARE COMPLYING -- ALL
TOO OFTEN THEY WILL PLACE ADS ON
IN THE MIDDLE OF SOME REMOTE
INDUSTRIAL AREA -- THIS BILL
REQUIRE THAT IT BE -- I NOT IN
INDUSTRIAL AREA AND LET'S THAT
AREA IS VERY CLOSE TO SERVICES --
WE HAVE A TERRIBLE HOMELESS ARE
CRISIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- TOO
MANY PEOPLE LIVING ON OUR
STREETS OF LIVING IN CARS LIVING
IN -- SHELTON AND PLACES WHERE
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO BE
LIVING.
AND ALTHOUGH THE OLD MICHAEL'S
PERMANENT HOUSING -- NAVIGATION
CENTERS AN EMERGENCY SHELTER OR
CRITICAL STEP FOR PEOPLE TO EXIT
THE THREE AND THE TRANSITION AND
THE SERVICES AND PERMANENT
HOUSING -- SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
pYOUR LAWLER FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ONLAW AND POVERTY.
AND SHARON REPORT FROM THE
CORPORATION OF FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHARMERS
ANOTHER WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY I'M.
IT'S SO AS A SENATOR HAS
MENTIONED -- IT FOR ABOUT A
DECADE STATE LAW HAS PROVIDED
FOR BYRATES OWNING FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTERS --
UNFORTUNATELY WE KNOW FROM A
DECADE EXPERIENCE THAT THE SCALE
OF THE LAW IS NOT ENOUGH TO GET
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN AS WE
NEED IN THE PLACES THAT WE NEED
THEM.
THIS IS A GOOD EXPANSION ON
EXISTING LAW THE BUILT ON OUR
EXPERIENCE.
AND WILL HELP DELIVERY NEEDED
SHELTER BEDS IN JURISDICTIONS
WHERE THEY ARE FAR SHORT.
OF IT'S A GOOD INTERMINABLE INTO
AS WE TRIED TO DEVELOP MORE
PERMITS SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
MORE EXTREME LOW INCOME HOUSING
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE DON'T FUND
HOMELESS AS IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING I WE WELL WE DO KNOW
THAT PERMANENT HOUSING WORKS TO
END HOMELESSNESS SHELTERS ARE AN
IMPORTANT PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO
ACCESS SERVICES TO GET CONNECTED
TO PERMANENT HOUSING -- IN MANY
JURISDICTIONS THE NUMBER SALTERS
IS FAILING TO MEET DEMAND AND IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS WHERE WE DO
HAVE ENOUGH SHELTER BEDS -- MANY
OF THOSE SHELTERS ARE SO AND
SAFE AND UNINHABITABLE -- THEY
HAVE VERY HIGH VACANCY RATES
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
ACCESS THE SHELTER.
SB FORTY EIGHT WITH OVERCOME
BARRIERS TO CREATING NEW -- SAFE
SHELTERS AND AS THE SENATOR SAID
IT WOULD PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR
SHELTERS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
RESIDENTS.
INCLUDING -- REQUIREMENTS TO
ALLOW FOR LOW BARRIER SHELTERS
TO ALLOW PEOPLE AND WHO NORMALLY
ARE EXCLUDED FROM SHELTERS.
AS WELL AS TO IMPROVE THE SAFETY
AND HABITABILITY CONDITIONS OF
SHELTERS.
I'M IN DOING SO SB FORTY EIGHT
WOULD EXPAND ACCESS TO SAFETY
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS WHILE EMPHASIZING
THE NEED FOR A MORE PERMANENT
HOUSING.
THEY WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND ARCHER I THOUGHT
THANK YOU.
THE FOLKS WANT TO WIN IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. TWO GERMAN KEITH ON
HER BEHALF CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE THE
SENATORS CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE WE THINK THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION THE
BILL ON INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING FOLKS
OFF THE STREET AND INTO SOME
SHELTER SO WE APPRECIATE THE
CENTERS.
LEADERSHIP AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVID ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION AND
SUPPORT.
FIRST FOR MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SIMILAR RECIPE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR EUROPE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE OKAY FOLKS WORRIES
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE -- ITEMS FOR THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THOUGHT
CONCERNS [inaudible]
TERRACE [inaudible]
YEAH.
LET'S REVISIT THE BY RIGHT AT
STAFF REPORTS THAT SENDS.
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT BALANCING ACT WHEN
YOU HAVE SOME BY MENTAL REVIEW
YOU TAKING ALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW OUT OF DICK OF THE
CONSIDERATION LEASE FOR SEVEN
YEARS.
I UNDERSTAND THE MEMBERS THAT
YOU TOOK AND FINANCE AND AND
GOVERNMENTS -- HOW WILL THE
LOCAL?
LEAD AGENCIES WHERE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF THESE
EMERGENCY SHELTERS.
WELL WHEN I WHEN ZONING IN THE
HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS HAPPENS
THERE IS -- AN ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW THAT HAPPENS -- IN
CONNECTION WITH THAT I IN
ADDITION -- SERVICES AND THIS IS
ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE -- THAT YOU
YOU'RE REQUIRED. TO EVERY CITIES
REQUIRED TO HAVE AN AREA --
WHERE THE -- TO WITH OUR OUR
REVIEWED WHAT THEY'RE ALLOWED
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
DESIGNATE HIS OWN THAT IS BY
RIGHT FOR EMERGENCY SHELTER.
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING IS SAYING
FIRST OF ALL YOU KAMPOT THAT BY
RIGHTS OWN INTO THE MIDDLE OF
SOME INDUSTRIAL.
DISCONNECTED WASTELAND AREA FAR
FROM WHERE WE WOULD NORMALLY
HAVE PEOPLE THEY HAVE -- AND
THEN IF YOU HAVE.
AUGUST A NAVIGATION CENTER WHICH
IS SORT OF A SHELTER TWO POINT
OH FOR LACK OF A BETTER.
TERM -- THE DOT IS ALSO -- BY
RIGHT -- SO I THIS IS NOT.
THIS IS NOT INVENTING A NEW
THING THIS IS -- EXPANDING AND
IMPROVING ON SOMETHING THAT
EXISTS ALREADY.
X. IT IS ALREADY MADE OF POLICY
JUDGMENT TO HAVE STREAMLINED
SHELTER EXCEPT MR THROUGH THE
CHAIR.
IF I MANY MUNICIPALITY AND I
HAVE.
GONE THROUGH AN E. I. R. OR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS AND I'VE
IDENTIFIED BY RIGHT THAT'S
ADJACENT TO THE INDUSTRIAL ZONE
OR IN SOME PLACE THAT DOESN'T IS
NOT CONTEMPLATE BY THIS BILL.
THEN I WILL HAVE DONE A LOT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK TO DETERMINE
IT IT DOESN'T MEAN THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE PROVIDING THAT YOU DID
LET'S SAY DID IT SEVEN YEARS AGO.
AND THEY HAVE -- I CREATED TO
SPY RIGHT NOW YOU'RE SAYING
UNDER THIS BILL IT'S NOT ALLOWED
YOU HAVE TO FIND ANOTHER SPOT
THAT DOESN'T GIVE THE SAME LEVEL
OF ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW BECAUSE
IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA SAVE.
YOU COULD DETERMINE THAT THE
FOLKS CAN.
BUILDING MY MISSING IT.
AND IF THEY HAVE TO MOVE IF THEY
IF IF THEY'RE IN INDUSTRIALS ON
LET'S JUST SAY THAT I HAVE TO
MOVE IT THEY WOULD HAVE TO DO A
GENERAL PLAN AMENDMENTS -- WHICH
ARE MY MY RECOLLECTION FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AT THE HOUSE OF
OUR MENTAL BECAUSE STILL
ATTACHED -- TO TO THAT MAKE THAT
CHANGE [inaudible]
I'M.
CENTER I AYE IF YOU DON'T MIND.
IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE FIVE YOU'VE
COME TO THE BILL.
YES OKAY SO ON PAGE [inaudible]
FIVE LINE.
EIGHT THERE IS A REFERENCE AS A
LOOK OF ROONEY DESIGNATE ZONES
FOR EMERGENCY SHELTERS IN AND IT
THIS IS THE MAN SO WE JUST GOT
THESE.
AND LOOK OVER AT ME AND
DESIGNATE ZONES FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS IN AN INDUSTRIAL ZONE
IF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DEMONSTRATES THAT THE ZONE.
IS CONNECTED TO AMENITIES AND
SERVICES THAT SERVE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
I JUST WANTED TO GET A BETTER
SENSE.
OF WHAT EXACTLY MEAN BY THE WORD
AMENITIES YOU MEAN IS THAT LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE AMENITIES SUCH AS
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER.
OR IS IT MORE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TYPE AMENITIES.
I AND JUST BECAUSE OF THE THE
GOAL THERE IS.
RIGHT IS TO SAY WE DON'T WANNA
BLANCA PER HAVE INDUSTRIAL ZONE
BECAUSE HERE ARE SOME
INDUSTRIAL ZONES ARE COULD BE
RIGHT NEXT TO WHERE PEOPLE GET
SERVICES -- AND SO IT'S NOT
WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID THIS SORT
OF REMOTE DISCONNECTED AREAS --
AND SO THE GOAL IS TO BE CLOSE
TO SERVICES -- AND TO JUST TO
HELP HUMAN BEINGS -- EXIST
[inaudible]
OKAY -- I I CAN GIVE AN EXAMPLE
IF THAT'S AT ALL HELPFUL.
SO.
YOU KNOW JUST IT IN IN OUR
EXPERIENCE IN TRYING TO MOVE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALONG AND
ACTUALLY DESIGNATING A BUYER ITS
OWN PURSUANT.
TO SB TWO FROM TEN YEARS AGO.
WHICH TOOK A LONG TIME TO GET
EVERY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT WELL
THERE'S LIKE 92% COMPLAINTS NOW --
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT A LOT OF
JURISDICTIONS AS A CENTERS THAT
WERE DESIGNATED DESIGNATING SOME
INDUSTRIAL ZONE THAT WAS WAY FAR
FLUNG AND FAR AWAY FROM ANYTHING --
A GOOD EXAMPLE THOUGH OF AN
INDUSTRIAL ZONE THAT ALSO MAKES
SENSE THE SHOULDER LOCATION IS
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO -- THE
AREA WHERE LIVES OFFICIALS
LOCATED WHICH IS AN INDUSTRIAL
ZONE NOT THAT FAR OUT OF
DOWNTOWN WHICH IS VERY CLOSE TO
SOCIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS.
IT'S VERY CLOSE -- TO IT'S WELL
CONNECTED WITH BIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE KNOW THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ALSO
REAL AND BIKE TRANSPORTATION SO
THEN GET TO AND FROM PLACES LIKE
THAT IT'S THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT WHAT WE DON'T
WANT.
A BY RIGHT SHOULDER DESIGNATION
IN A FAR FLUNG INDUSTRIALS ON
WHEN NO ONE IS EVER GOING TO
LOCATE FILTER IS ESSENTIALLY.
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING FOR MY RIGHT
SHOULDER IS IT'S IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE HELPFUL AND SO I THINK
THERE THERE IS GOING TO BE SOME
JUDGMENT ABOUT THE AMENITIES AND
SERVICES.
BUT I THINK WE SORT OF KNOW IT
WHEN WE SEE IT AND I THINK THAT
WE CAN TRUST THAT THAT.
THAT JUDGMENT CAN BE MADE
.
QUESTION I WROTE -- ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB 48% UNDER WIENER P. M. DO
YOU PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BATES [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STONE I KELSEY.
CASKEY AYE OKAY SO THAT'S DONE.
I KNOW CENTER COMMUNITY MORE
BILL WITHIN ABOUT A FIVE SB SIX
EIGHTY NINE WOULD.
YEAH THE SIMPLE BILL -- WHAT?
I THINK IS REFERRED TO AS A
PRODUCTION.
IN THE LAST -- COMMITTEE.
HOW'S IT GOING HOW'S IT GOING
CENTER [inaudible]
YEAH.
IS IS OVER [inaudible]
ONE YEAH.
WE DID NOT USE THE TERM DOKKEN --
NOMENCLATURE HERE IN THIS --
ANNOUNCES MILLION IN -- IN
DEFERENCE TO OUR OUR OUR FRIENDS
FROM PITA -- BUT I YOU MAY YOU
MAY PROCEED.
VERY GOING TO TO PERKY AND
FATTER YEAH WELL.
THAT WOULD STILL BE UPSETTING.
AS OUR FRIENDS THE FENDER STERN
REFERRED TO IT AS THE OPENS TO
THE OCEAN.
IS THAT OKAY WELL CACOPHONY
MAYBE IT'S HELLO BEAUTIFUL OKAY
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ARE YOU MAY PER SEASON.
OKAY AFTER THE BANTER MISTER
CHAIRED ODD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RIGHT THANK YOU AND ACT THE
STAFF.
WERE ALL WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL AND HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS -- SB SIXTY
NINE THE OCEAN RESILIENCY OCT.
TO TWENTY NINETEEN BOB
REPRESENTS A MAJOR STOPPED WORD
OF PROTECTING OUR OCEAN
ECOSYSTEMS.
AGAINST THE GREATEST THREAT THAT
THEY FACE TODAY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THE ACIDITY HYPOXIA MASS
EXTINCTION IT CAN LEAD.
TO HEALTHY OCEANS INTERN I CAN
SERVE AS THE LARGEST -- ABSORBER
OF CARBON EMISSIONS ON EARTH AND
CAN HELP BLUNT THE WORST IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
SB SIXTY NINE WILL RESTORE WATER
QUALITY AND ELIMINATE LOCAL
OCEAN ACIDITY HOT SPOTS BY
SETTING STATEWIDE A CITY ON AYE
ACIDITY AND HYPOXIA OBJECTIVES.
REQUIRED DENITRIFICATION OF
WASTEWATER DISCHARGES AND
OVERLAYING MARINE RESERVES AND
AREAS OF BIOLOGICAL SIGNIFICANCE
WITH STATE WATER QUALITY
PROTECTED AREA DESIGNATIONS.
LEGISLATION WILL ALSO HELP
RESTORE HABITATS AND ENCOURAGE
PRACTICES OTHER INCREASE
SEQUESTRATION OF SO CALLED BLUE
CARBON.
INCLUDING WETLANDS RESTORATION
BENEFICIAL REUSE OF MARINE
SEDIMENTS TO BUILD UP A ROAD
WETLANDS.
AND SUSTAINABLE CULTIVATION OF
SHELLFISH AND SEE WE'D.
WE ALSO NEED TO PROTECT OUR
ECOLOGICALLY CRITICAL SPECIES.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE COASTAL
ECONOMIES RELY ON THE BILL WILL
PROTECT WHALES BY CODIFYING AN
EXISTING VOLUNTARY PROGRAM AIMED
AT PREVENTING SHIP STRIKES.
SB SIXTY NINE ALSO TAKES A
NUMBER OF LONG OVERDUE STOPS.
ARE TO BEGIN REBUILDING OUR
SALMON FISHERIES ARE REBUILDING
OUR SALMON FISHERIES INCLUDING
PROTECTION OF THE FOREST STREAMS
WHERE THEY SPAWN.
I KNOWLEDGE OF THIS IS A BIG
AMBITIOUS -- BILL OF TERRACE
FAMILIAR WITH THOSE BILLS AS HE
DOES THE SOUTH -- AND THAT THERE
ARE SOME GROUPS THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERN.
ARE WE ARE WORKING WITH EACH OF
THESE GROUPS -- AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH -- AND THE
HOPE THAT WE END UP WITH A
PACKAGE TO EVERYONE I CAN GET
BEHIND.
I'M ALTOGETHER ARE THESE
MEASURES WILL ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE STRATEGY.
AND THE ABILITY TO MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON OUR
OCEAN.
OUGHT TO SEQUESTER A LARGER
AMOUNT OF CARBON.
ALLOW COASTAL COMMUNITIES TO
CONTINUE THEIR WAY OF LIFE INTO
THE FUTURE.
I WITH ME TODAY ARE TO RESA
BURKE OF EDGE OF THE PACIFIC
COAST SHELLFISH GROWERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND ALLEN LEVINE OF COAST ACTION
GROUP.
I AND ALSO WITH US TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MAY COME UP --
JOHN BOTHWELL THE CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BROUGH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THREE SEBERG **** ON BEHALF OF
THE PACIFIC COAST OFFICE GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND IN PARTICULAR
THE CALIFORNIA MEMBERS WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB SIXTY NINE
WHICH WILL HELP MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S OCEANS MORE
RESILIENT TO CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS.
AQUACULTURE IS NOW THE FASTEST
GROWING FORM OF FOOD PRODUCTION
AND WHEN IT IS DONE RESPONSIBLY
IT IS CONSIDERED TO BE ONE OF
THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
SUSTAINABLE WAYS TO PRODUCE
ANIMAL PROTEIN.
CARBON IMPROVE WATER QUALITY
ASSISTING IN CURBING ACCESS
TONIGHT ACCESS NITROGEN AND
PHOSPHORUS AS WELL AS IMPROVING
WATER CLARITY.
CHAU OFFICE USE CARBON FROM THE
OCEAN TO MAKE THEIR CELLS AND
SEE WE TAKE UP CARBON DIOXIDE
JUST LIKE TERRESTRIAL PLANTS
WHEN THE SEAWEED AND SHELLFISH
DIE THEY WILL DECOMPOSE AND FALL
TO THE OCEAN FLOOR ACTING AS A
CARBON SINK.
THE ABILITY FOR SELFISH TO
IMPROVE WATER CLARITY HAS
ALREADY BEEN PROVEN TO BE
BENEFICIAL IN EFFORTS TO RESTORE
EAGLE YOUR GRASS BEDS.
IN MORE SEDIMENT FILLED WATERS
LIKE CHESAPEAKE BAY. THREE
ESTABLISHMENT OF NATIVE SEE
SHELLFISH REEFS AND HELP FOREST
WILL HELP BUFFER THE COASTLINE
BY PROVIDING A NATURAL STRUCTURE
THAT WILL HELP STABILIZE.
THE SUBSTRATE AND REDUCE IMPACT
OF STORM WE'VE ACTION. FOR
PROMOTING THE CALIFORNIA'S
SUSTAINABLE MAYOR CULTURE WE
WILL BE INVESTING IN AN INDUSTRY
THAT NOT ONLY PROVIDES JOBS AND
INVESTMENT THE ECONOMY BUT IT
ALSO DIRECTLY HELPS COMBAT THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
BECAUSE WE ARE SO DEPEND ON OUR
HEALTH THE OCEAN WE SEE
OURSELVES AS PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO ADDRESSING THIS
QUICK CRITICAL CHALLENGE OF
OCEAN RESILIENCY.
THE PACIFIC OR SHELLFISH GROWERS
ASSOCIATION IS THANKFUL TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY MY NAME'S ALAN
LEVINE.
I REPRESENT.
COAST ACTION GROUP WHICH IS A
AFFILIATE OF REVERTED COAST
WATER SHED ALLIANCE.
SINCE THE GROUP THAT WORKS IN
MENDOCINO AND SNOW MECHANIC
BECAUSE BECAUSE ACTION GROUP IS
WHAT WORKS STATEWIDE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN ALLOWING ME TO
ADDRESS YOU IN SUPPORTING SB.
SIXTY NINE I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
SINCE SALMON ISSUES AND FOR
THREE ISSUE SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE YOU MIGHT
CALL ME A PROFESSIONAL
ENVIRONMENTALISTS THAT'S NEVER
BEEN PAID FOR ANYTHING.
DOZEN ADVISER TO WORKING
FOREST'S PROJECTS SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND ACRES AND MENACING ON
CINEMA COUNTY.
I'M INTIMATELY AWARE OF THE
SCIENCE AND FORCE PRACTICE RULES
AND WATER CODE.
THAT THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
HERE.
I BELIEVE SB SIXTY NINE
REPRESENTS A CRITICAL AND
NECESSARY STEP.
FORWARD IN THE RECOVERY OF
CALIFORNIA'S SALMON BEARING
STREAMS.
WE'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF OUR SALMON
BEARING WATER COURSES ARE
POLLUTED.
FACT EVERYONE IS LISTED AS
POLLUTED UNDER THE STATE'S --
IMPAIRED WATERS LIST SECTION
THREE OF THREE D..
UP OFTEN TO EXTREME LEVELS WITH
THE SETTLEMENT STREAM
TEMPERATURE CONDITIONS.
THAT DO NOT SUPPORT SALMONIDS IN%
THAT IN ALL THEIR ALL THEIR LIFE
CYCLES -- THE CURRENT PRACTICE
FOREST PRACTICE RULES FAIL TO
PROTECT.
SALMON AND THERE'S LOTS OF
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES TO SUPPORT
THE SUBSEQUENT TO THE IMPAIR
LISTING OF CALIFORNIANS SALMON
BEARING STREAMS SAMMY
POPULATIONS HAVE DROPPED THE
PERILOUS.
LEVELS IN OUR STREAMS ARE IN NO
BETTER SHAPE.
NOW THERE'S A COPY OUT THERE
THERE'S THE GARCIA RIVER WHERE
WE'VE BEEN EMPLOYING THE
STANDARDS AND OF SB SIX NINE AND
BETTER.
AND WE'VE SEEN SALMON COMING
BACK FOR AWHILE AND SO YOU CAN
HAVE POSITIVE BENEFITS BY
EMPLOYING THESE STANDARDS.
CLOSE THE **** ECONOMIES THAT
RELY ON SALMON FISHERIES HAVE
BEEN PUSHED TO THE BRINK.
AND THE JOB LOSSES ARE
CONTINUING AS WE SPEAK THIS
MOVIE THE REPAIR AND RECOVERY OF
THE STREAMS IS A VERY VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE AND I'M REALLY
DIFFICULT JOB.
AND IT'S THIS RECOVERY IS
CURRENTLY BEING SUBSIDIZED BY
THE CALIFORNIA CITIZENS.
MEANWHILE THERE'S OTHER
CONNECTED SPECIES THAT SUFFER
WITH THE LOSS OF SALMON -- THAT
FACE EXTINCTION ORCAS NEED
SALMON TO LIVE ON FAIRS NEEDS
THEM IN THE LIVE ON BALD EAGLES
THROUGH AND OTHER RAFTERS.
TO OF WASHINGTON STATE TO SPENT
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS IN
PRESERVING THEIR MAJESTIC.
THESE THIS THEIR SALMON AND
CALIFORNIA MIGHT MAY SOON FIND.
THEM SIMEON THE STATE IN THAT
PLACE OF PUTTING MORE BACKS OUT
TO ACCOMPLISH THIS.
SB SIX ISLAMIC SERVER TAILORED
AND MINOR INFORM CHANGES TO THE
URRENT LOGGING RULES WHILE
ENSURING THAT WE'RE NOT UNDULY
LIMITING HARVEST THE WOOD IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT IS A ESSENTIAL
PRODUCT AND WE NEED.
TO IN FACT THESE RULES WERE
PREVIOUSLY RECOMMENDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
THEN FISHING GAME BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN AND NO A
FISHERIES IN THE TO THE THEY
WERE CALLED THE TWENTY ONE
TWELVE RULES AND THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY.
ADOPTED PART OF THEM IN THEIR
NEW RULE MAKING BUT LEFT OUT
PARK.
TO SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT ENOUGH TREES AND
TREE CANOPY ARE LEFT.
I'M IN THE RIGHT PERIANDER
MANAGEMENT ZONES.
IN NEAR STREAMS ON FOR FIRST
SHADE.
HANNAH OUR WATER TEMPERATURE
CONTROL AND PREVENT EROSION
[inaudible]
WHICH RELATIVE TO LOGGING
OPERATIONS IS IT'S THEIR
PROTECTIVE ZONES THAT.
INCREMENTALLY.
BEING ADJUSTED IN AREAS THAT
WERE IGNORED PREVIOUSLY --
THERE'S A METAL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL AND THEY SOME PLAN
ISSUES BUT I MIGHT LEAVE THAT TO
LATER.
SB SIXTY NINE ADDRESSES THESE
ISSUES AND STATE NON POINT
SOURCE POLICY EMPLOYING STATE
NON POROUS US POLICY.
WHICH IS A BALANCED PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND I'M I HOPE YOU
APPROVE IT HAS I THINK IS THIS
IS THE FAMINES LAST CHANCE.
WE NOW HEAR FROM BY THE FIRST
ONE AND SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA'S ALICIA
ON BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION -- WE WHAT THE
BALLAST WATER IT I ACTUALLY
VESSEL SPEED REDUCTION OUR IS
OUR ISSUE -- FOR THIS BILL ALL
WE AGREE WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT
IT SHOULD BE TIED.
TO HARMONIZE WITH EXISTING
INCENTIVES AND PRACTICES OF FOR
SPEED REDUCTION SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GRAHAM.
WAS THERE ARE.
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
RENDON GARCIA -- HALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT AND SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS VEHICLE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
I A FOLKS WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO OPPOSITION --
THERE'S UP THERE.
I'M JENNIFER APPEAR AT THE STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS ARE WHERE
OPPOSE LESS AMENDED WATER
CONTRACTORS THEY WATER
CONTRACTORS YES TWENTY SEVEN
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES THAT
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE FOR
WATER.
I WERE OPPOSE LESS AMENDED BUT
FOCUSING ON SECTION THREE WE
UNDERSTAND THE BILL'S MEANT TO
IMPROVE HATCHERY MANAGEMENT AND
BENEFIT RECREATIONAL COMMERCIAL
FISHERY.
WE TOTALLY AGREE THE HATCHERY
MANAGEMENT THE STATE NEEDS TO BE
AN IMPROVED -- HOWEVER HAVE TO
DO THIS CAREFULLY BECAUSE
HATCHERY FISH CAN INTERFERE WITH
THE RECOVERY OF NATURALLY
PRODUCED FISH.
AND THE BILL DOESN'T HAVE A LOT
OF DETAIL IN ORDER TO VERIFY
THAT WHAT'S GOING TO BE PROPOSAL
WHAT WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED CAN
ACTUALLY INSURE THAT WERE NOT
IMPACTING NATURALLY PRODUCED
FISH.
WE'VE BEEN MEETING WITH THE BILL
PROPONENTS ON THIS TOPIC.
AND WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT
INSTEAD REFORM SOME SORT OF WORK
GROUP THAT ALLOWS US TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
AND A NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON STUDY THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN DONE HATCHERY
MANAGEMENT.
ACTUALLY MOVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH WILDLIFE INTO A BETTER
HATCHERY MANAGER PLAN FOR THE
STATE.
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS THAT COST
AFFILIATED WITH SECTION THREE
ARE ASSIGNED TO THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AND TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE -- THERE'S NO
CLEAR NEXUS BETWEEN STATE WATER
PROJECT AND THESE STUDIES AND
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT
BECAUSE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
WILDLIFE IS UNDERGOING A MAJOR
BUDGET REVIEW AND THAT THEY
REALLY DON'T HAVE ANY FUNDING
THAT.
THE FUNDING IS NOT THERE TO
IMPLEMENT.
THE SPECIFIC STUDIES THAT ARE
LISTED HERE SO WE'D RATHER WORK
TOGETHER TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
COOK COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESS
HATCHERY MANAGEMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
TIMBER HARVESTING CHANGES THAT
THIS BILL WOULD PROPOSE -- WE'VE
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL WE'VE ASKED FOR THE STUDIES
AND INFORMATION THAT THEY SAY
INDICATE ARE THE NEEDS FOR THE
BILL -- RECEIVE SOME OF THE
INFORMATION LAST WEEK -- WE
ACTUALLY -- DISAGREE WITH THEIR
ASSERTION THAT THE STUDIES PROVE
THEIR POINT IN FACT THE STUDIES
THAT THEY GAVE US GO BACK AS FAR
AS TWENTY TWO YEARS AGO -- AND
THE MOST RECENT STUDY THEY GAVE
WAS FROM TWENTY TEN SO SINCE
THAT TIME THERE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
UPGRADES IN THE FOREST PRACTICE
RULES THROUGH CAL FIRE THROUGH
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY IN THE
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES.
THAT ARE PART OF A MULTI REVIEW
AGENCY.
REVIEW THAT IS SEEK WORK WITH
WANT AND ARE PROCESS UNDER TO
REHEARSING PLANS -- WE FEEL THAT
THIS BILL YOU SERVICE THAT A
THOR THEIR AUTHORITY THAT WE
CURRENTLY GO THROUGH IN ORDER TO
HAVE THAT PROCESS -- IN ADDITION
TO THAT IN THE FOREST PRACTICE
RULES THERE ARE DIFFERENT RULES
BASED UPON THE REGIONS OF THE
STATE IN THE DISTRICT.
THAT THERE IS SO THIS BILL IS A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH AND
APPLIES THAT RULE REGARDLESS OF
THE GEOGRAPHY OR THE AREA OF THE
STATE THAT WE'RE IN --
FURTHERMORE WE FEEL LIKE IF
THERE ARE SPECIAL RULES THAT ARE
NEEDED.
IN PARTICULAR PLACES OF THE
STATE THE FOREST PRACTICE RULES
ALSO ALLOW COUNTIES TO APPLY
SPECIFIC RULES TO THEIR COUNTY
IN SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES THERE
ARE MULTIPLE IT -- COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE THEY DO HAVE AN
IMPLEMENT THESE RULES.
FINALLY WERE CONCERNED THAT
BECAUSE THIS BILL WOULD THEN PUT
THOSE RULES IN STATUTE AS
OPPOSED TO THE FOREST PRACTICE
RULES THAT IT SORT OF LOCKS IN
THOSE RULES GOING FORWARD.
IT PLACES SCIENCE AND A FREEZE
AT THAT MOMENT IN TIME WE HAVE A
COUPLE EXAMPLES -- WITH REGARDS --
TO LARGE WOODY DEBRIS WHICH ONE
OF THE STUDIES POINTS TO IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE.
THIS LARGE WOODY DEBRIS IN WATER
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SHADE
PULLING FOR FISH FOOD SOURCES --
IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO THAT WE
THOUGHT THAT HAVING WOOD IN THE
WATER WAS ACTUALLY A DETRIMENT
AND WE PULLED IT OUT OF THE
WATER NOW SCIENCE IS SAYING NO
NO IT'S GOOD PUT IT BACK IN THE
WATER.
IN ADDITION TO THAT A LONG TIME
AGO WE THOUGHT NORTHERN SPOTTED
OWLS WHICH ARE ENDANGERED
SPECIES THAT THEY COULD ONLY
SURVIVE IN OLD GROWTH FORESTS
WHAT WE'VE COME TO LEARN IS THAT
SPOTTED OWLS WILL OFTENTIMES
MAKE THEIR NESTS IN OLD GROWTH
FORESTS.
BUT THEY ACTUALLY LIKE TO BE
NEAR ARE ON THE EDGE OF WHERE
THEY HAVE HAD.
INNINGS IN THE FOREST BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
GET THEIR FOOD SO LIKE WE HAVE A
KITCHEN AND A FAN AND A BEDROOM
IN OUR HOUSE.
THEY ALSO HAVE THEIR OWN KITCHEN
AND THEIR BEDROOM OLD GROWTH AND
LIKE TO BE NEAR STANDINGS IT'S
BECAUSE OF THIS THAT WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
AND EITHER HAVE THESE PROVISIONS
REMOVED FROM THE BILL OR
POTENTIALLY PROVIDE INCENTIVES
TO LANDOWNERS TO DO ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS -- TO IMPROVE LEGACY
FORCED ISSUES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ROBERT
SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION ALSO REGRETTABLY IN
OPPOSITION SPECIFICALLY TO
PREVENT TO THE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO TIMBER HARVEST AND
FUNDAMENTALLY WITH WITH THIS
LEGISLATION WHAT THE BILL'S
DOING FITS USURPING THE CURRENT
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE NOW WITH
CAL FIRE ACTING AS THE LEAD
AGENCY.
AND THE OTHER AGENCIES INVOLVING
LIKE THE DEPARTMENT OFFISH
WILDLIFE THE REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD AND OTHERS
HAVING A REVIEW PROCESS AS WELL
TO GO THROUGH THAT T. H. P. TO
ENSURE THAT.
THE RESPECTIVE JURISDICTIONS OF
THOSE AGENCIES ARE PROTECTED AS
WELL IF WILDLIFE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSIDERATIONS.
WHAT SB SIXTY NINE DOES THE
PRICE PLACES WATER QUALITY
OBJECTIVES ABOVE EVERYTHING ELSE?
AND WHILE THAT MAY BE WELL
INTENTIONED AND GOOD.
THE PROBLEM IS SPECIFICALLY
RELATES TO SALMON SPECIES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WHEN YOU'RE
REQUIRING.
SPECIFIC CANOPY LEVELS WHICH IN
SECTION TWENTY ONE OF THE BILL
PROVIDES.
BACK CANOPY AXE WHILE NOT MAYBE
NECESSARILY BAD FOR SALMON IN
PARTICULAR IT DOES HAVE OTHER.
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ANOTHER
CANDIDATE SPECIES SUCH AS THE
LIKE A FROG THAT ALSO REPRESENT
A REPRESENTATIVE LIVING HAVE
HABITAT AND SOME OF THESE AREAS.
SO WE THE MULTI AGENCY REVIEW IS
IS VERY CRITICAL TO INSURING A
BALANCED APPROACH TO ALL OF THE
CRITERIA SO SHOULD TO TO TIMBER
HARVEST PROGRAMMER PLAN.
AS WELL AS ALL OF THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED AS PART OF IT AGAIN
FOCUSING ON ONE ISSUE A REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY MIGHT BE FINDING
GOOD FOR ONE SPECIFIC SECTION
ONE SPECIFIC ISSUE.
BUT IT DOESN'T RESOLVE THE OTHER
ISSUES INVOLVING THE MULTI
AGENCY JURISDICTION OF THIS OR
CONCERN OBVIOUSLY LIKE I SAID.
WE ARE ON DOING THAT PROCESS
WERE GIVEN ONE AUTHORITY
ESSENTIALLY.
THE POWER TO VETO THE TIMBER
HARVEST PLAN WE BELIEVE THAT'S
UNNECESSARY GIVEN THE FORCE
PRACTICE ROLE FOR PRACTICE ACT.
AND THE UPDATES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED IN THE LAST LITERALLY
FIVE TO TEN YEARS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AGAIN.
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
OPPOSITION OKAY WE'RE OKAY I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST REMIND THE
FOLKS TESTIFYING THAT THE TIMBER
HARVEST ISSUES IS REALLY A
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER.
ISSUE WORK ENVIRONMENT QUALITY
AND THIS BILL WAS -- I GUESS IS
DOUBLE REFERRED.
IS THAT RIGHT SO I MEAN I'M I'M
HAPPY TO HEAR THOSE COMMENTS BUT
THOSE COMMENTS WERE MOST
APPROPRIATELY -- DIRECTED TOWARD
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
SURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND
CHAIRS A BRIAN WHY DON'T HAVE
THE CALCULATIONS FORCES SO SHE
ASIAN WE ARE THE STATE'S
REGISTER PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS
SO WE ARE ACTUALLY.
LICENSED BY THE STATE THAT YOU
APPROVED AND ROBBERS PLANS SO WE
HAD TO PUT OUR LICENSE ON THE
LINE WE ACTUALLY DO THESE TIMBER
HARVEST PLANTS AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY.
OPPOSE A SENATORS BILL WE'VE
WORKED WITH HIM ON HE PASS ON
VARIOUS BILLS BUT WE WERE GONNA
BE MUST POSE THE FORTY
PROVISIONS.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT YES YOU'RE
RIGHT THIS THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE DID DO WHAT THE TIMBER
HARVEST PLAN FOR PROVISIONS BUT
THIS BILL BLENDS THE ISSUE
BETWEEN WATER QUALITY.
IN THE APPROVAL TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS AND SO THE FACT THAT.
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY APPROVE
THESE PLANS WE WORK WITH ALL THE
OTHER AGENCIES BEFORE THEY CAN
BE SIGNED OFF.
THE NARRATIVE IN THIS BILL ON
THE PREMISES AT BOTH APPROVAL
PLANS HAVE NOT BEEN DONE
CORRECTLY IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS WHICH IS JUST NOT THE CASE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL MULTI
AGENCY AGREEMENTS WITH THE WATER
BOARD PART OFFICIAL WILDLIFE THE
TRYING IMPROVE THE SETTLEMENT
ISSUES BUT THIS BILL TAKES THE
PREMISE A LEAST A FORTY
PROVISIONS TAKES A PREMISE THAT.
NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE IN THE
LAST FIVE TO TEN YEARS THEIR
LEGACY ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
FORTY PROJECTS CORRECT.
BUT THOSE AREN'T CAN'T JUST BE
ASSOCIATE IT WOULD JUST TODAY'S
FORTY PRACTICES WHICH HAVE BEEN
IMPROVED DRAMATICALLY.
RUSSIA PROFESSIONAL FORSTER THEY
TAKE THEIR JOB SERIOUSLY WE
THINK THIS BILL UNFORTUNATELY
TARGETS ONE PARTICULAR INDUSTRY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AS
PREVIOUS COMPANIES THAT THE
FORTY PROVISIONS TAKEN OUT OF
THE BILL AND BE MORE OF A
CONSTRUCTIVE AND AND INCENTIVIZE
BILL RATHER JUST A A MANDATE SO
FOR THOSE REASONS.
WEARABLES AND BECAME.
YES MY NAME'S LAURA CAMP -- I'M
REPRESENTING FOR FLANNER
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A NON AND
NON INDUSTRIAL OWNER SO THOSE
ARE PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
SAWMILLS THERE ARE OWNERSHIP
REYES FROM TEN ACRES TO AS MUCH
AS A HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES BUT
ON THE THE POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE HERE BEFORE -- I WOULD JUST
REITERATE THAT THAT -- THERE IS
A MULTI AGENCY PROCESS -- THE
RULES AND REGULATIONS HAVE BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY REVISED -- SINCE
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND PARTICULAR
THE OF PROTECTION OF AN OUT FROM
ITS SOLEMN SOMEONE IS.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE AND ROADS--
THAT DEAL WITH EROSION WATER
QUALITY AND IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN AND I I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT WE WE
DID I HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE DOCUMENTS -- THEY
WERE PROVIDED BY BY A THE
SENATOR STAFF AND ONE OF THEM
GOES BACK TO NINETEEN NINETY
NINE DEALING WITH SAY SOMEONE IS.
NEARLY ALL THE CONSTITUENCY
GROUPS INTERVIEWS SUPPORT
INCENTIVES TO LANDOWNERS TO
IMPROVE AND MAINTAIN SOMEONE OR
HAMMER.
THE PROGRAM OF ITS CITIES MUST
BE DEVELOPED.
TO ALLOW THE VALUE PERMANENTLY
DESIGNATED STANDING IN DOWN
TREES TO BE DEDUCTED FROM THE
TIMBER OWNERS YOUR OTHER STATE
TAXES.
WHILE THIS WAS AUTHORED IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE FIVE NONE
OF THOSE PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE.
ALL WHAT WE HAVE.
HAVING INSTEAD OF THAT IS.
A SUBSTANTIAL -- REDUCTIONS IN
THE VALE ABILITY OF TIMBER AND
TIMBERLAND -- THROUGH THE ASP
RULES AND SUBSTANTIAL REDUCTIONS
TO ARE THE FINANCIAL INCREASES
IN COST.
ASSOCIATED WITH ROAD RULES GIVE
YOU AN IDEA OF THE MAGNITUDE.
ARM.
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF STREAMS --
THEY'RE COVERED UNDER THE
EXISTING RULES THAT IS.
A ONE MILE WIDE STRIP.
FROM HERE TO LOS ANGELES.
ON A HALF MILE WIDE ON EITHER
SIDE OF INTERSTATE.
FIVE THAT'S HOW MUCH ACREAGE
WERE TALKING ABOUT IT WOULD
PROBABLY DOUBLE OR PERHAPS
TRIPLE.
IF YOUR PROPOSALS IN THIS BILL
ARE PUT FORWARD SO THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU I MAKE I GET THIS IS
A BIG BILL WE WE HAVE TO SO
PLEASE DO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
THINK YOU COULD SAY DID A OR I
YOU KNOW.
SO SEE YOURSELF WITH PREVIOUS
COMMENTS BUT I'M.
YEAH PLEASE MAKE NEW COMMENTS
AND AND KEEP THEM AS FAR AS YOU
CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR AND MEMBERS
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE HAVE A POSITION OF
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED THE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS -- I'D SAY
FOR PURPOSES OF THIS COMMITTEE
OUR CONCERNS CENTER ON THE
DENITRIFICATION PROTOCOLS WHEN.
YOU NOTIFICATION PROTOCOLS IN
THE BILL AND I WOULD JUST
CONCURRENT WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE BY CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SANITATION AGENCIES IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK GRANT THANK YOU.
GEN MEMBERS BY DYLAN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES ALL THE
MAJOR WASTE WATER AGENCIES OUR
CONCERN.
IS WITH SECTION TWENTY TWO AND
WE WOULD REQUEST THE REMOVAL OF
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY STUDIES UP
IN THE BAY AREA IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
OTHER SCIENTIFIC STUDIES
MANAGEMENT PLANS -- FOR
NUTRIENTS INCLUDING A NEW A NEW
TRAFFIC CATION AND
DENITRIFICATION.
AND SO WE THINK WITH THOSE
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY WITH THE
REGIONAL QUALITY CONTROL BOARDS --
THAT THIS PROVISION IS
UNNECESSARY THANK YOU.
DURING GREEN -- CAL AN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICTS AND I WOULD ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH PRIOR COMMENTS -- IN
ADDITION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED POSITION THERE WAS ONE
OTHER SMALL AMENDMENT WE ARE
SEEKING TO SECTION NINETEEN IT
HAS TO DO WITH -- STATE WATER
QUALITY PROTECTION AREAS AND
THERE ARE ALREADY EXISTING
PROCESS PROVISIONS -- LAYING OUT
THE PROCESS AND DETAILED
CRITERIA IN THE CALIFORNIA OCEAN
PLANNED SO WE BELIEVE THAT'S ON
NECESSARY TO INCLUDE IN THE BILL
THANK YOU.
MARGOT.
OF THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION -- WOULD CONCUR WITH
AMENDMENTS UPS ARE WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
MADE -- ON SECTIONS NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO OF THE BELL --
ADDITIONALLY WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BALLAST WATER
PROVISIONS THEIR AMENDMENTS
TAKEN FROM THE LAST COMMITTEE
WHICH I THINK ARE AN IMPROVEMENT.
BUT I THINK AS A COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT -- THERE'S
FEDERAL PREEMPTION IS LOOMING --
IN THE MEANTIME I THINK TO TAKE
AWAY I'M ANY CONSULTING
AUTHORITY FROM STATE LANDS AND
MOVE IT OVER TO THE WATER BOARD.
AT THIS POINT IS UNNECESSARY
STATE LANCE'S BEEN.
HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS AND HAS
BEEN WORKING ON THIS PROGRAM --
FOR YEARS SO IT'S SEEMS A LITTLE
BIT CONFUSING -- AN OUT OF ORDER
AT THIS POINT I'M AND THEN OUR
FINAL COMMENT IS WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
REMOVING THE AUTHORITIES OUT OF
THE REGIONAL WATER UALITY
BOARDS TO THE STATE BOARD. FOR
DISCHARGE -- INTO SENSITIVE
AREAS AND PUTTING THAT THE STATE
FORTY THINK IS.
PERHAPS AONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH ON THE CANADIAN ALICE'S
DOES POINT OUT THAT THERE ARE.
AND THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME
OR SOME OVERLAP IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE EXEMPTIONS
THAT THE BILL OUTLINES OR ALLOWS
FOR ON THE CREATION OF THOSE AND
SO THERE THERE'S AN ISSUE IN.
WHO IS?
IN CHARGE OF THOSE EXCEPTIONS --
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD SO WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION BUT WE HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH AUTHORS STAFF
AND AND THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
IN THIS AREA AND THINK THAT
PERHAPS THIS.
COULD BE NARROWED A LITTLE BIT
MORE -- TO ENSURE THAT IT IS
LIMITED TO PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES --
ARMORS ARE NOT PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES THAT ARE HOLDERS THAT
AND PDS PERMITS AND SO WE'D LIKE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK AND REFINED
THAT ISSUE -- BUT FOR NOW WE ARE
PASSED THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NUMBER TEN FOR THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT I JUST
WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE BALLAST
WATER PROVISIONS.
AND MENTION THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHERS
ON SOME UNRESOLVED ISSUES WE DO
HAVE QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT.
EXPERT REVIEW PANEL AND WHETHER
IT'S REDUNDANT AND CAN BE
SUSTAINED FROM A FISCAL
PERSPECTIVE.
THAT'S WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH EVERYBODY ON THOSE
PROVISIONS -- FOR CALLING.
SO THE BILL.
WHY ARE WE FIND?
THE COMPETITION PLAN IN
CALIFORNIA CLOSE BASS INDUSTRIES
PLAINTIFF DOCKED INCORPORATOR TO
IMPROVE DENITRIFICATION
PROTOCOLS [inaudible]
I'M.
IS IT YOUR WE SURELY.
THERE OUGHT TO BE
DENITRIFICATION PROTOCOLS.
THAT THEY EMPLOYMENT MAYBE YOU
OBJECT TO THE LEVEL OF OF FIVE
SPECIFICITY THAT OR OR ARE YOU
CALLED A ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
APPROACH FURTHER DOWN IN YOUR
LETTER BUT I'M I'M JUST FILLING
IN TODAY MISTER CHAIR BUT MY
UNDERSTAND OUR MAJOR CONCERN IS
THAT THIS THE BLANKET
REQUIREMENT WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY --
WERE ALREADY INVOLVED IN IN THE
BAY AREA IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
WITH THE REGIONAL BOARDS ON ON
THAT TOTAL NUTRIENTS STUDIES
WHICH INCLUDES A DENITRIFICATION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
I GUESS.
IF I CAN DO A FOLLOW UP.
WE HAVE A LOT OF LEGACY IN --
NITRIFICATION THAT EXISTS RIGHT
NOW IS ARE WE DISPUTING THE
CLEAN UP OF THE CURRENT LEGACY
OR ASSISTED THIS NEW DISCHARGED
THAT MAY BE CREATED BY ACTIVITY
WITH DISTRICTS.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE INTENT IS
THAT THERE WOULD BE NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR TREATMENT AT
WASTE WATER TREATMENT FACILITIES
TO REMOVE NITROGEN COMPOUNDS.
RIGHT NOW MOST TREATMENT PLANTS --
DISCHARGING TO THE OCEAN AND I'M
I WOULD ASSUME THE BAY I DON'T
KNOW THAT FOR SURE -- DON'T
NIGER FINDING I DEFY THEIR
AFFLUENT IT -- TO ENERGY
INTENSIVE EXPENSIVE PROCESS TO
ADD DIRECTOR FRED INTO THE
TREATMENT -- FACILITIES OFTEN
YOU END UP DE RATING YOUR
CAPACITY OF YOUR TREATMENT PLANT
BECAUSE OF THE EXTRA TANKS THAT
IT TAKES -- SO IT BECOMES A VERY
EXPENSIVE PROPOSITION RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THERE ARE
MODELS AND STUDIES THAT ARE
GOING ON BOTH IN THE BAY AREA.
AND WITH THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COASTAL WATERS RESEARCH PROJECT
THOSE ARE STILL UNDER WAY AND
HAVE -- A WAYS TO GO SEVERAL
YEARS AGO I BELIEVE -- WE JUST
FEEL THAT THIS IS SORT OF NOT
THE RED PROPIONATE -- DECIDE TO
SORT OF END RUN AROUND THE
SCIENCE THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
NOW TO DETERMINE WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
MR JUST INSTANTLY HAPPENS TO BE
THE I THINK THE WASTE TREATMENT
PLANTS IN OR LIMON IN.
IN SAN LEANDRO MY DISTRICT IS IS
DOING THE WASTE WATER TREATMENT
AND THEY RE READING OF THE BAY --
WITH SOME FANTASTIC.
RESULTS AS FAR AS THE THE
SUCCESS.
YEAH I'M WE HAVE SET WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF TREATMENT PLANTS THAT
DO NOT TO FIND THE NINETY FIVE
THOSE ARE OUR WATER RECLAMATION
PLANS ARE OCEAN DISCHARGE PLANT
DOES NOT IT'S A BIG UNDERTAKING
I DON'T HAVE A A COST ESTIMATE
AT THIS TIME OF HOW MUCH IT
WOULD.
COST OUR STAFF OR ARE LOOKING
INTO IT BUT IT BECAUSE W ARE
INVOLVED IN THIS IN THE MODELING
AND STUDIES GOING ON WE ARE
LOOKING AT IT BUT IT'S IT'S IT
JUST SEEMS PREMATURE TO US AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT I'M.
SENATOR SOME YEARS BEFORE.
YES OKAY A FEW THINGS ON YOUR
I'M I APOLOGIZE JOHN BOTHWELL AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEPER LANCE
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THE
PANEL -- COUPLED POINTS ON
ADDRESS FIRST THAT WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING AHEAD OF THE SCIENCE
WE'VE BEEN IN CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH THE FOLKS THAT ARE DOING
THE RESEARCH AND THE MODELING.
I'M I'M ACTUALLY ON THE ADVISORY
GROUP THAT'S BEEN WATCHING THAT
MOLLY IN SCIENCE GO FORWARD IS
ACTUALLY SUPPOSED TO COME OUT
WITH PRELIMINARY -- CONCLUSIONS
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR THERE'S
BEEN A LITTLE LIKE A SOME OF THE
STUDY BUT THEY ANTICIPATE --
NEXT MONTH TO BE RELEASING
INFORMATION ABOUT IT -- WE HAVE
SHARED THIS BILL WITH THEM ALONG
THE WAY THEY HAVE NOT SHARED ANY
CONCERNS WITH US MOVING FORWARD
WITH THIS -- WE'VE TALKED WITH
OCEAN PROTECT WHO.
THE THE THE RESEARCH AND SCIENCE
SPOKES ARE WORKING WITH WORK ON
THE MODELING -- OF ON THE
MODELING YEAH THE WORKING WITH
YOU [inaudible]
SCORE.
WORKS QUIRK SEC SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COASTAL RESEARCH
PROJECT IS WHAT'S THAT THERE'S A
FEW GUYS YEAH IT'S A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY WITH THE
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION
CURRENTLY CHAIRED BY THE
ASSISTANT JENNA MANTRA MY AGENCY
BUT IT INCLUDES ALL OF THE
REGIONAL BOARDS THE STATE WATER
BOARD USEPA AND THE SANITATION.
FOLKS AND YES AND FOR LARGE
SANITATION AGENCIES ARE. THREE
SHARED IT WITH SCHOOL WORK.
MOVE THOSE GUYS AND HEN AND
THEN WHAT AND WE HAVEN'T -- Và.
IF THE JOINT POWERS AGREEMENT OF
OF WASTE WATER FOLKS AND BUT
THERE'S A IF THIS.
OKAY OKAY OKAY -- RIGHT DO YOU
ONE SECOND OKAY ANSWER THE
QUESTION WHAT WILL -- CLOSE THE
IT'S IT'S A SCIENCE WORKING
GROUP THAT THAT STUDIES VARIOUS
THINGS THROUGHOUT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BIGHT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING THE MODELING PAY THROUGH
FOR WAS WHAT WHAT EFFECT YOU
WHAT.
AM I SENATOR SO WHAT'S HAPPENING
pTHE ROLE WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO CLOSE ON IT
WILL JUST FINISH THE
CONVERSATION.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AND OKAY
THANK YOU SO WILL WILL FINISH
THE CONVERSATION THESE GUYS GO
BACK TO ENERGY.
SO WE'VE SPOKEN WITH THEM WE
SPOKE WITH OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL WHICH HAS BEEN FUNDING
THIS THIS STUDY IN MODEL OF PC
HAS BEEN ON THE FOREFRONT OF
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION LOOKING AT
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION HOTSPOTS --
ALONG WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD
WHO'S BEEN MONITORING THIS AND
ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THIS
AND THE THIS -- A HOT SPOT TO BE
PERFECTLY FRANK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH OR WITHOUT THIS BILL
OF THE STATE BOARD IS MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION OF SETTING A
WATER QUALITY OBJECTIVE.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THESE AWAY
HOT SPOTS AND THEY DO WANT TO
WAIT UNTIL THE SCIENCES THERE
WHICH THEY THINK IS GOING TO BE.
THE PRELIMINARY FINDINGS ALREADY
COMING OUT THERE ALREADY IN
TALKS -- AND WE ARE TALKING WITH
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO PROVIDE
AMENDMENTS AND FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT THE STATE BOARD DOESN'T GET
AHEAD OF THE SITE THE LAST THING
WE WANT TO DO IN THE STATE
BOARDS ARE GOING TO WANT TO DO
THIS EITHER.
OF GET AHEAD OF ITSELF AND SET
SOME WATER QUALITY OBJECTIVE
THAT'S NOT SCIENTIFICALLY AND
LEGALLY DEFENSIBLE.
I WORK AT THE STATE WATER BOARD
CONSTANTLY.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A WATER QUALITY
OBJECTIVE BE ADOPTED.
ANY SHORT OF FIVE YEARS THEY
FIVE TOXICITIES BEEN FIFTEEN
YEARS THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN
TOMORROW THEY'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON THE SIDE STILL BE
SIDE PANELS. TO INFORM WHAT THIS
WATER QUALITY OBJECTIVE IS.
THIS ONLY JUST SETS THE TRIGGER
TO GET THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
MOVE FOR WITH THAT AND AGAIN
WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
LANGUAGE OR WORK WITH STATE
BOARD.
ON TO TO PUT LANGUAGE IN THERE
SO THAT THEY DON'T GET AHEAD OF
THE SITES THAT.
IT MAYBE THE STATE FOR NEED TO
PUT A FINDING IN OF OKAY THE THE
SCIENCE DOES JUSTIFY THESE HOT
SPOTS ARE CURRENT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD.
OKAY.
BUT OKAY I ONE MORE THING ON THE
JUST THE DEAN EDUCATION PIECE.
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS REALLY
FOR THE WASTEWATER FACILITIES TO
MEET THE WATER QUALITY OBJECTIVE
THAT THE STATE BOARD SETS WE
DON'T WANNA BE PRESCRIPTIVE AND
SAY IT HAS TO BE THIS ONE WAY.
OR THE WAY I READ THE LANGUAGE
IT'S NOT PRESCRIPTIVE THE ONE
EXACT WAY -- WE'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH THE BAY AREA FOLKS I'M AS A
P. C. S. FBI.
ON THERE DOING OTHER THINGS
OTHER THAN JUST PURE DEAN
EDUCATION LOOK AT WETLANDS
LOOKING RECYCLED WATER WE WE
THINK THE BILL HAS THE
FLEXIBILITY IN THERE NOW.
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE A FURTHER
LANGUAGE THAT THAT ADDRESSES
THAT.
WE'VE BEEN TINKERING WITH AN
AMENDMENT TO TO REQUIRE THE
STATE BOARD TO CONSIDER REGIONAL
BOARD APPROACHES WHEN THEY'RE
DOING THEIR IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
WHEN WHEN THE SEA PORTS THAT'S A
WATER QUALITY OBJECTIVE THAT
WILL SET THE OBJECTIVE BUT
THERE'S AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
THAT GOES WITH THAT AND THAT'S
REALLY THE HEART OF IT AND THE
MEAT OF IT?
AND THE WATER BOARD'S GOING TO
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO LOOK AT
OTHER REGIONS AND WHAT'S BEEN
GOING ON INCOMPETENT
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT WORKS
TO MEET THAT WATER.
AT THE END.
OKAY WELL ARMED.
INTERESTING I HAVE I THINK
THERE'S A TON MORE WORK TO BE
DONE -- I THINK EVERY RECOGNIZE
THAT WOULD RELATE TO THIS BILL --
BUT I CERTAINLY AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PRIDE INTENDED
THE BILL AND I'M INCLINED TO
GIVE THE THE AUTUMN YOU KNOW
MORE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS BUT IT'S A POOR
LUCKY IN THE IT ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT'S
NOT APPROPRIATIONS.
WHICH IS ALL DIFFERENT YEAH ALL
DIFFERENT DEAL IT'S NOT NATURAL
RESOURCES WERE REALLY FOCUSING
ON THE WATER QUALITY IN AND THAT
THAT CHUNK OF IT -- SO
[inaudible]
WITHOUT.
TIPPING MY HAT ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUESTION THEN THE HOLISTIC JUST
DOING MY JOB HERE IS A MEMBER OF
THE E. Q. I WILL MOVE THE BILL.
CURRENT SIZE A MOVE WE HEARD A
CLOSING FROM THE AUTHOR.
MUCH MORE WORK TO BE SPENT ON
THIS.
ENORMOUS BILL I'M SORRY TO
PLEASE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIXTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE
BATES [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN STONE.
I CASKEY.
I KELSEY I WILL KEEP THAT ON
CALL AND I WILL FIGHT TO THE
DICE A BIG FAN OF OUR STATE
WATER BOARD -- CENTER NIELSEN.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE CENTER WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE I SAY
COME IN A COUPLE TIMES TODAY AND
IT'S BEEN A BARELY DAYS YOU KNOW --
FOR ALL OF US SO.
SEE YOU BEING HERE AND AND YOU
MAY PROCEED BY WITH PRESENTING
SB.
TWO TWO SIX WHEN WHEN WHEN READY.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE HAD
[inaudible]
COMMANDERS [inaudible]
CATACLYSMIC FIRES.
NOT JUST LAST YEAR ALTHOUGH THAT
WAS PROBABLY AT A PEAK YEAR.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN SUSTAINED
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
[inaudible]
THESE FIRES.
I HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON
OUR WATERSHEDS.
IN TERMS OF THE CAPACITY OF
THOSE WATERSHEDS TO RETAIN.
THE STORE WATER.
IN THE WATERSHEDS.
IN TERMS OF EROSION.
THAT SOMETIMES AND FILLS OUR
STREAMS AND RIVERS [inaudible]
SEDIMENTATION [inaudible]
STILL [inaudible]
AND SNAGS [inaudible]
THAT HAS.
REALLY AFFECTED THIS.
AND IT AFFECTS ALL OF OUR
WATERWAYS.
SOMETIMES THESE FIRES REACH SUCH
A TEMPERATURE THAT THE ROUND IS
LITERALLY STERILIZED FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS.
BEFORE ANYTHING COMES BACK.
IT TAKES A SUSTAINED EFFORT. TO
BRING THEM BACK.
DIVIDE THE HABITAT [inaudible]
THE RECREATION.
AND EVEN THE ECONOMIC ABILITY.
THESE WEAKEN TREES.
OFTENTIMES GET INFECTED WITH
VARIOUS INSECTS.
AND DIE.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
WITH THIS MEASURE.
IS TO CREATE A GRANT PROGRAM.
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES TO BE
PROVIDED SOME PHONETIC FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. TO BEGAN. TO RESTORE.
THIS WATERSHED REGION'S.
IN THAT SO MUCH OF THE WATER
TRANSFERS AROUND CALIFORNIA
NORTH SOUTHEAST WEST.
IT'S AN CRITICAL IMPORTANCE.
THAT WE MAINTAIN THESE LANDS.
AND RESTORE THEM [inaudible]
THIS PROVIDES.
SOME FUNDS IN. FOR THAT PURPOSE
[inaudible]
IT'S THE REALLY NOT EVEN CLOSE
TO ENOUGH TO DO THE JOB.
BUT IT IS A START.
IT IS THE FIRST COMMITMENT.
AND NOT BE OUR GOAL.
WE ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
THEY APPEARED TO BE REDUNDANT
ANYWAY.
AND WE WOULD SUBMIT THE BILL TO
YOU.
THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE.
TO PROCEED TO BE ABLE TO DO SOME
THINGS TO RESTORE.
THOSE WATERSHED REGION'S.
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU I JUST TO
CLARIFY I'M.
YEAH THERE WAS A C. WHERE
EXEMPTION.
PROPOSED IN THE BILL -- BUT AS
WE DISCUSS IT WAS UNNECESSARY
BECAUSE THE PROJECTS ARE
EXAMPLES HE QUIT.
AS PROJECT THAT MAINTAIN REPAIR
RESTORE TOMASA REPLACE PROPERTY
FACILITIES DAMAGED OR DESTROYED.
AS A RESULT OF HIS OUSTER AND
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR HAVING
AGREED TO STRIKE THE SEQUEL
EXCEPTION.
AND WITH THAT -- ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL.
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THE
RECENT FIRES THAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING IN CALIFORNIA HAVE SHOWN.
A DISTURBING TREND IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBER OF ACRES BURNED THE
NUMBER OF STRUCTURES DESTROYED
IN THE NUMBER OF LIVES LOST --
THE STUDY HAS INDICATED THAT
WILD FIRES COULD DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF SEDIMENT AND A THIRD
OF THE LARGEST WESTERN
WATERSHEDS BY -- TWENTY FIFTY AS
A RESULT WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GARCIA I'M HAVE A MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY AND ONCE THE RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL OPPOSITION.
OKAY SO AT THE ITEM IS NOW
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE -- MOVE THE
BILL BECAUSE HE'S MOVED THE BILL.
WE DO APPRECIATE IT I'M
[inaudible]
I SO HE I GUESS HAD BEEN OPPOSED
BY SOON WITH THIS.
pSB [inaudible]
A BETTER.
ABOUT IT THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING OKAY OKAY.
THE DUSTING OKAY APPRECIATE THAT
I YEAH I THINK WITH WITH THE
AMEND IT'S A FAIR BILL AND AND
THAT'S THE MOVE BY CENTER WILL
CAST GIVE YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
CENTER BACK TO THE QUESTION I
VOTE OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS ACTIVITIES KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TWO TWO SIX
BY SENATOR NIELSEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES
[inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN.
STONE BY CASKEY.
MAKOWSKI AYE.
OKAY.
SO THAT WE WILL HOLD OPEN FOR
OTHER FOLKS THAT ON THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER FOR YOUR WORK WITH
US AND I'M.
THERE WE ARE NOW LET'S NOT LET'S
LET.
CENTER WILL CASKEY AT ON BECAUSE
YOU MISTER VOTER TO WHEN YOU
WERE OUT.
WE DIDN'T STRUGGLE YEAH
[inaudible]
WE DID.
YEAH I KNOW I KNOW.
IN LEYVA IS APPARENTLY ON OUR
WAY [inaudible]
SO -- OKAY SO THE BILL'S THE
ASSEMBLY TASK IS NOT HAD A
CHANCE TO VOTE ON IT SO THE
FIRST.
ONE IS PROBABLY THE BEST FEEL ON
THE DOCKET THAT CENTER ALLEN'S
SB.
FIFTY NINE I REALLY NAY AV --
THE FORTY ZERO VOTE CURRENTLY.
ACTIVE PLEASE KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB FIFTY NINE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING I FOUR ZERO HILL.
EARN LIKE OWSKI.
MAKOWSKI AYE.
THAT'S FIVE A WE WILL AT THE
OTHER -- WILL KEEP THAT OPEN UP
FOR THE WEATHER'S AT ON THE NEXT
ONE IS JACKSON THIS IS THE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB.
FOUR TWO FOUR JACKSON'S BILL ON
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. SIX A PIECE
KALRA.
NUMBER EIGHT SB FOUR TWO FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CHAIRED VOTING I BASS HEAR NOT
VOTING. TWO ONE HILL.
STERN.
AYE CASKEY.
MY CASKEY AYE OKAY WELL THAT
OPEN TO ALLOW OTHERS TO ADD ON
BUT I DO SEE THIS EARLY VICE
HERE TO LEAVE A YOU MAY APPROACH
THE DIETS NOW ARE YOU STILL AS
SENATE EDUCATION STILL GOING
STRONG.
OKAY SURPRISE SURPRISE HAVING A
FUN DAY TODAY YEAH YOU HAVE A
VERY SIMPLE DOCKET I SEE.
WHAT ELEVEN BILLS BUT?
SOME OF THEM WOULD HAVE TO ONCE
AGAIN WELL WE ALL KNOW THAT
FEELING THIS WEEK.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
AND AND AND YOU MAY PROCEED THIS
IS ITEM TWELVE IS SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR ALAN OF MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND THINKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
IS MUCH APPRECIATED.
MEMBERS SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
REQUIRES DISCLOSURE OF FRAGRANCE
AND FLAVOR INGREDIENTS IN
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THAT
APPEAR ON DESIGNATED AND ALL.
THOR TATUM HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL
THIS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFE COSMETICS PROGRAM.
EASY TO SAY -- SB FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR ONE POWER CONSUMERS TO MAKE
EDUCATED DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH
PRODUCTS TO USE WITH THEIR KIDS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. TO NOTE THIS
BILL DOES NOT BAN ANY PRODUCT
INGREDIENTS OR REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL PRODUCT LABELING.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR ALSO
PROTECTS THE CONFIDENTIAL
BUSINESS INFORMATION INCLUDING
PRODUCT INGREDIENTS FORMULAS
THAT IS NOT IDENTIFIED AS
HARMFUL BY AUTHORITATIVE BODIES.
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA THE PUBLIC
KNOWS MORE ABOUT THE FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENTS IN CLEANING PRODUCTS
THAN THOSE THAT WE USED TO CLEAN
AND PERFORM PERFUME OUR OWN
BODIES.
PUT ANOTHER WAY WE NORMAL MORE
ABOUT THE FLOOR CLEANER AND
DISINFECTANTS THEN WHAT IS IN
OUR SHAMPOOS DEODORANTS AND BODY
SPRAYS.
WE ALSO KNOW VERY LITTLE LITTLE
ABOUT THE FLAVORS IN CHAP STICKS
MOUTHWASH AND LIP GLOSSES AND I
LEFT MY LITTLE LIP GLOSS AS AN
EXAMPLE IN EDUCATION I WAS GOING
TO BRING THAT AS A LITTLE A
LITTLE THING LOOK AT MANY
MARKETED TO CHILDREN.
WITH KRISPY KREME DONUT AND ICE
CREAM FLAVORS ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE RISK OF EXPOSURE TO SECRET
HAZARDOUS.
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR CHEMICALS
AND RELATED HARMFUL CHRONIC
HEALTH CONCERNS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SUCH AS
CHILDREN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND PEGNANT WOMEN.
CURRENTLY NO STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES THE DISCLOSURE OF
FRAGRANT FLAVOR INGREDIENTS TO
CONSUMERS OR REGULATORY AGENCIES.
THIS LOPHOLE ALLOWS CHEMICALS
TO HIDE UNDER THE WORD FRAGRANCE
OR FLAVOR ON THE LABELS OF
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS WITH A LITTLE
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
OF THE SAFETY OF THOSE
INGREDIENTS.
YOU CAN SEE FOR YOURSELF ON THE
LABELS OF THE PRODUCTS THAT YOU
USE EVERY MORNING AND EVERY
NIGHT.
THOUSANDS OF SYNTHETIC CHEMICALS
ARE USED TO CREATE THE
FRAGRANCES AND FLAVORS THAT
COMPRISE THE BEAUTY AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS WE USE EVERY DAY.
THESE PRODUCTS INCLUDE PERFUMES
SHAMPOOS MOISTURIZERS LIPSTICK
AND HAIR STYLING PRODUCTS SOME
OF THESE CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN
LINKED TO NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS.
RANGING FROM ALLERGIC REACTIONS
TO REPRODUCTIVE HARM AN
INCREASED RISK OF BREAST CANCER.
FRAGRANCE CHEMICALS CAN BE FOUND
IN MORE THAN 95%.
OF SHAMPOOS CONDITIONERS HAIR
STYLING PRODUCTS ANTIPERSPIRANT
AND SHAVING PRODUCTS AS WELL AS
FINE FRAGRANCES.
BODY SPRAYS AND LOTIONS I THINK
YOU'RE GETTING THE HINT HERE
THAT IT IS IN EVERYTHING.
IN FACT ONE THIRD OF THE
FRAGRANCE CHEMICALS CURRENTLY IN
USE HAVE BEEN LINKED TO NEGATIVE
HEALTH IMPACTS.
IT IS CURRENTLY LEGAL FOR
COMPANIES TO NOT DISCLOSE THESE
INGREDIENTS HOWEVER.
IN RESPONSE TO GROWING CONSUMER
DEMAND SOME COMPANIES HAVE BEGUN
DISCLOSING FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENTS IN THEIR PRODUCTS
AND BIG RETAILERS ARE BEGINNING
TO DEMAND INGREDIENT DISCLOSURE
AS A CONDITION TO SELLING
PRODUCTS IN THEIR STORES.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WILL BE THE
CATALYST NEEDED TO ENSURE THE
CONSUMERS KNOW THE PRESENCE OF
HARMFUL INGREDIENTS AND ALL OF
THE PERSONAL CARE OPTIONS.
ALL PRODUCTS THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPTION OF BUYING.
WITH THIS BILL WE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT INGREDIENTS ARE IN THEIR
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THAT THE USE DAILY.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WILL ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA IS ONCE AGAIN A
NATIONAL AND GLOBAL LEADER ON
PUBLIC HEALTH.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR REPRESENTS
THE STRONGEST DISCLOSURE LAW IN
THE COUNTRY AND ACROSS THE WORLD
OF HARMFUL FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENTS.
BEFORE TURNING OVER TURNING OVER
TO MY SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT I
WOULD LIKE TO DRESS ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION ARGUMENTS NOTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
OPPOSITION KNOWS THE SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR IS TRYING TO FIX A
PROBLEM THAT DOESN'T EXIST
HOWEVER THEY RELY ON THEIR OWN
INTERNAL INDUSTRY FUNDED STUDIES
AND PANELS. TO COME TO THIS
CONCLUSION.
IF THE PRODUCT INGREDIENTS ARE
INDEED AMONGST THE SAFEST THEN
THEY SHOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM
DISCLOSING THE PRESENCE OF ANY
THAT APPEAR ON THE AUTHORITATIVE
CANDIDATE CHEMICAL LIST.
OPPOSITION NOTES THAT SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR THREATENS TRADE
SECRETS.
GET THE BILL STRENGTHENED BY THE
MEMBERS BEING TAKEN TODAY.
DOES NOT REQUIRE THE DISCLOSURE
OF INGREDIENTS WAIT AMOUNT
COMBINATION OR MANNER IN WHICH
THE INGREDIENTS ARE USED.
THE OPPOSITION NOTES THAT THE
MEASURE RELIES ON TWENTY SEVEN
AIR QUOTE.
AUTHORITATIVE LISTS THAT ARE NOT
GROUNDED IN SOUND SCIENCE
HOWEVER THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY ONLY CONTAINS TRULY
AUTHORITATIVE DTS SEE CANADA
CHEMICAL LISTS.
THAT ARE IDENTICAL TO THOSE
INCLUDED IN THE CLEANING
PRODUCTS BILL.
FINALLY OPPOSITION NOTES THAT SB
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR UNFAIRLY
PUNISHES AN INDUSTRY THAT HAS
LED ON DISCLOSURE YET WE KNOW
MORE ABOUT THE FRAGRANCES AND
CLEANING PRODUCTS THEN WE DO
THAT WE WHAT WE USE TO CLEAN OUR
OWN BODIES.
I DO NOT BELIEVE DISCLOSURE IS A
PUNISHMENT MEMBERS I AM
COMMITTED TO ONGOING GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSIONSWITH INDUSTRY AND
ADVOCATES.
I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE TO THIS POINT AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
IS JANET NEWMAN WITH BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS AND
MARTIN WOLF THE DIRECTOR OF
SUSTAINABILITY AND AUTHENTICITY
AT SEVENTH GENERATION.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I WILL
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
GIVE ME PROCEED.
OKAY YOU GO [inaudible]
IRATE TRAFFIC.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR ALLEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JANET NOODLE MAN AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM AND
POLICY A BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR I AM HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IT IS A IN NYC
CREDIBLY IMPORTANT CONSUMER IN
RIGHT TO KNOW ISSUE THAT'S BEING
ADDRESSED.
A SENATOR LEYVA MENTIONED
FRAGRANCE CHEMICALS CAN BE FOUND
IN THE MAJORITY OF HAIR CARE
PRODUCTS PERSONAL HYGIENE
PRODUCTS FINE FRAGRANCES BODY
SPRAY LOTIONS.
AS WELL AS MORE AND MORE MAKE UP
LITERALLY ANY OF THE PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS YOU USE DAILY THAT
SMELL GOOD.
AND FLAVOR CHEMICALS CAN BE
FOUND IN THE MAJORITY OF
TOOTHPASTES MOUTHWASHES LIP
GLOSSES AND CHAPS DECKS.
YET NO FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THE
DISCLOSURE OF THESE INGREDIENTS
TO CONSUMERS TO MANUFACTURERS OR
EVEN TO THE FDA OR OTHER
REGULATORY AGENCIES.
THIS LABELING LOOPHOLE ALLOWS
DOZEN SOMETIMES EVEN HUNDREDS OF
CHEMICALS MANY OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN LINKED TO CANCER.
BIRTH DEFECTS ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTION ANOTHER HARMFUL
HEALTH EFFECTS TO HIDE UNDER THE
WORDFRAGRANCE OR FLAVOR ON
PRODUCT LABELS WITH NO
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
BY ANY STATE NATIONAL OR GLOBAL
ENTITY REGARDING THE SAFETY OF
THESE INGREDIENTS.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WOULD CLOSE
THIS LABELING LOOPHOLE BY GIVING
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED. TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
CUSTOMERS FROM UNSAFE CHEMICAL
EXPOSURES AND SERIOUS ALLERGIC
REACTIONS.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR ENJOYS
BROAD BASED SUPPORT FROM ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS. EIGHTY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND HEALTH
ASSOCIATIONS AND THIRTY FIVE
COSMETIC COMPANIES.
DESPITE THE OVERWHELMING POPULAR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HOWEVER
OPPONENTS ARE ATTEMPTING TO
PAINT THIS COMMONSENSE PROPOSAL.
AS AN UNWARRANTED.
UNWANTED OVER REACH AN OVER
REGULATION OF A VERY SAFE CORNER
OF THE MARKET.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT SB FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR THREATENS CONFIDENTIAL
BUSINESS INFORMATION.
AND I KNOW SENATO LEYVA I'M
JUST TALKED ABOUT THIS A LITTLE
BIT BUT THIS IS REALLY THE
CORNERSTONE OF OF WHAT THE
BILL'S ALL ABOUT.
IN FACT SB SEVEN FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR DOESN'T THREATEN THE
COMPETITIVE EDGE OF A COMPANY'S
FRAGRANCE FORMULATION OR FORCE
THEM TO GIVE AWAY THEIR SECRET
SAUCE.
THE BILL ONLY REQUIRES A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE THOUSANDS OF
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR CHEMICALS
CURRENTLY BEING USED TO BE
PUBLICLY.
TO DISCLOSED LITERALLY LESS THAN
3% OF THE FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
CHEMICALS IN USE TODAY.
AND ONLY THOSE FRAGRANCE AND
FLAVOR CHEMICALS THAT APPEAR ON
A DESIGNATED LIST.
FURTHERMORE THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO DISCLOSE THE WEIGHT OR AMOUNT
OF ANY INGREDIENT EVEN FOR
REPORTABLE INGREDIENTS.
WITH THIS LIMITED INFORMATION IT
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR A
COMPETITOR TO REPLICATE THE
FRAGRANCE OR A FLAVOR
FORMULATION.
THE MARKETPLACE HAS RESPONDED TO
THE INCREASED CONSUMER DEMAND
FOR MORE INGREDIENT TRANSPARENCY
WITH STRICTER LABELING
REQUIREMENTS FOR FOOD FOR
CLEANING PRODUCTS AND FOR
COSMETICS.
NOW MANY HUNDREDS OF COSMETIC
COMPANIES ARE VOLUNTARILY FULLY
DISCLOSING FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS
RETAILERS TO ARE BECOMING PART
OF THE SOLUTION.
IN FACT TARGET WILL BE REQUIRING
THE NATIONAL BRANDS THAT THEY
CARRY TO DISCLOSE THEIR
FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY EVERYONE IS AT
RISK FROM HARMFUL CHEMICAL
CONCERNS AND SERIOUS ALLERGIC
REACTIONS FROM SECRET FLAVOR AND
FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS.
ON BEHALF OF SB FIVE SEVENTY
FOURS BILL SPONSORS BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS AND WOMEN'S
VOICES FOR THE EARTH.
WE URGE YOU TO GIVE CONSUMERS
AND WORKERS THE INFORMATION THEY
WANT THEY NEED AND THEY DESERVE
BY SUPPORTING SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU BY
THE WAY I'M JUST BEFORE YOU MOVE
ON TO THE YOU MISSION PERSONAL
HYGIENE -- I I SENT I SENT THE
WELL MY WIFE AND SHE'S EXCITED
ABOUT WHICH I GUESS IS BAD NEWS
FOR THE OPPOSITION.
BUT THAT BUT SHE DID ASK ABOUT --
TAMPONS ARE THEY COVERED UNDER
THE AND WHY NOT.
THERE YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY REGULATED AS
MEDICAL DEVICES F. FROM IF YOU
CAN BELIEVE THAT THEIR AND
THEY'RE UNDER A DIFFERENT AREA
OF REGULATION BY THAT BY THE FDA.
SO THEY'RE NOT CAPTURED WITHIN
WITHIN THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE'RE ONLY WERE
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING COSMETIC
PRODUCTS WHICH INCLUDES PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS BUT NOT TAMPONS
WHICH IS KIND OF COUNTER
INTUITIVE OKAY WOULD YOU I MEAN
YOU SAID THAT THE WORK ON THAT
FOR THEIR CENTER [inaudible]
ALL THE YEAH [inaudible]
IT IS.
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER.
YEAH.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. FOR YOU TO TAKE
THE LEAD ON THAT THE ME BUT MY
WIFE WILL BE VERY HAPPY.
THAT'S THE KEY AND TO OKAY ALL
RIGHT GOOD ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH YES SIR.
FIRST SENATOR ALLEN PLEASES FREE
WIFE THAT SEVENTH GENERATION
WHICH IS A MANUFACTURER WE
NINETEEN PROBABLY BY YOUR
DIAPERS ADVOCATING FOR SUCH
DISCLOSURE THANK YOU.
CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARTIN
WOLF ON THE DIRECTOR OF
SUSTAINABILITY AND AUTHENTICITY
FOR SEVENTH GENERATION.
AND ON BEHALF OF SEVENTH
GENERATION UNILEVER AND MEMBERS
OF THE AMERICAN SUSTAINABLE
BUSINESS COUNCIL.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR BECAUSE MEDIC
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR INGREDIENT.
RIGHT TO KNOW ACT.
TWENTY NINETEEN SEVENTH
GENERATION IS THE NATION'S
LEADING BRAND OF HOUSEHOLD AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS DESIGNED
TO HELP PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH.
AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
OUR COMPANY DISTRIBUTES PRODUCTS
FROM NATURAL FOOD RETAILERS
SUPERMARKETS MASS MERCHANTS AND
ONLINE RETAILERS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES AND IN MORE THAN
TWENTY COUNTRIES.
IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTH GENERATION WAS ACQUIRED
BY UNILEVER.
A GLOBAL MANUFACTURER OF
CONSUMER PRODUCTS DEDICATED TO
MAKING SUSTAINABLE LIVING COMMON
PLACE.
UNILEVER ONE OF THE LARGEST
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COMPANIES IN THE WORLD
EMPLOYEES OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
AND HAS SALES IN EXCESS OF SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
UNILEVER IS A MEMBER OF THE
PERSONAL ON UP.
EXCUSE ME PC PC THE PERSONAL
CARE OF PRODUCTS COUNCIL.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THOUGH
AT THIS TIME PC PC DOES NOT
[inaudible]
I AM.
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF SEVENTH
GENERATION.
UNILEVER AND MEMBERS OF A S. BC
ALL OF WHOM HAVE A STRONG
PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
MANUFACTURING WAREHOUSING
DISTRIBUTION HEAD QUARTER AND
OTHER OFFICE FACILITIES.
IN PRESENTING THIS TESTMONY.
I COME BEFORE YOU AS A SENIOR
EMPLOYEE OF THE SUCCESSFUL
SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE BUSINESS
THAT IS GROWING AT DOUBLE DIGIT
RATES THEN INDUSTRY WHOSE SALES
ARE ESSENTIALLY FLAT.
I COME BEFORE YOU AS A CHEMIST
WHICH SCIENCE I HAVE STUDIED AND
PRACTICED MOST OF MY ADULT LIFE.
AND I COME BEFORE YOU AS A
FATHER WHO VALUES THE HEALTH OF
HIS CHILDREN.
AND BELIEVES WE DO NOT HAVE TO
SACRIFICE THE HEALTH OF OUR
FAMILIES TO MAINTAIN OUR
ECONOMIC VITALITY.
NOR DO WE HAVE TO SACRIFICE OUR
ECONOMIC ABOUT VITALITY TO MEAN
THE WHOLE MAINTAIN THE HEALTH OF
OUR FAMILIES.
IF WE ACT WISELY WE CAN HAVE
BOTH.
AS STIPULATED IN SECTION ONE OF
THIS BILL.
THERE ARE ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND
FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS OF USED
TODAY.
THESE INGREDIENTS INCLUDE
CARCINOGENS REPRODUCTIVE
TOXICANTS AS MAGICIANS
NEUROTOXINS ALLERGENS AND OTHER
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN.
DESPITE THIS THERE ARE CURRENTLY
NO STATE OR FEDERAL FEDERALLY
MANDATED FRAGRANCE INGREDIENT
DISCLOSURE.
REQUIREMENTS FOR BEAUTY OR
PERSONAL GOAL PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS.
THIS LACK OF FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENT DISCLOSURE CREATES AN
UNFAIR BURDEN FOR CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS WANTING TO AVOID
EXPOSURE. TO CHEMICALS THAT THEY
DEEM UNSAFE.
IN CORRECTING THIS PROBLEM THIS
BILL WOULD NOT PLACE AN UNDUE
BURDEN ON INDUSTRY.
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
COMPANIES IN CLEANING PRODUCT
COMPANIES HAVE MUCH IN COMMON
WHEN IT COMES TO FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENTS.
THE CHEMICALS USED TO FRAGRANCE
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COME FROM THE SAME LIST
OF FOUR THOUSAND CHEMICALS
TYPICALLY USED TO FRAGRANCE
CLEANING PRODUCTS.
CORRECT CORRECT CASSIE JUST WRAP
IT UP [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
SORRY SIR.
THAT IS QUITE ALRIGHT.
SEVENTH GENERATION HAS BEEN
DISCLOSING ALL INGREDIENTS
pIN ITS PRODUCTS.
THIS IS PART OF WHO WE ARE AND
IT HAS CONTRIBUTED TO OUR DOUBLE
DIGIT SUCCESS.
AND TO CUSTOMER TRUST IN OUR
BRANDS WE HAVE BEEN JOINED BY
MANY OTHER COMPANIES.
INCLUDING BEAUTY COUNTER
CALIFORNIA BABY HONEST METHOD
AND UNILEVER ONE OF THE LARGEST
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
COMPANIES IN THE WORLD.
IN SUMMARY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY TO ADVANCE THE HEALTH
OF CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS BILL DOES NOT PLACE AN
UNDUE BURDEN TO BUSINESSES
ACTING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I ASK THAT.
ON BEHALF OF SEVENTH GENERATION
UNILEVER AND MEMBERS OF THE A
SPC THANK YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR DISSENSION IN
CONSIDERATION MISSION THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND AS I SAY WE I LIKE
A LOT OF YOUR PRODUCTS.
OKAY I OF OTHER FOLKS WENT OUT
ON SUPPORT.
CURRENT SEASON LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP ALSO.
A ON BEHALF OF CALPERS US PER
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL
PLASTIC POLLUTION COALITION.
I JUST WANT TO STATE THAT THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL ARISES OUT OF
THE ATONISHING REALITY THAT
THIS L'INDUSTRIE IS LARGELY SELF
REGULATED.
THAT THE FDA DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO EITHER.
REQUIRE RECALLS OF PRODUCTS THAT
ARE PROBLEMATIC OR TO REQUIRE
SAFETY TESTING OF THESE PRODUCTS
AND IN THE ABSENCE OF THESE
CONSUMER OF NEEDED CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
AT THE MINIMUM WE CAN ASK FOR
DISCLOSURE AND TRANSPARENCY
THANK YOU THE TERM.
RANDAZZO SERICA CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
HI I'M POLY MARSHALL FROM BREAST
CANCER OVER TIME WE'RE AN
ORGANIZATION.
OF BREAST CANCER SURVIVORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND FRIENDS I'M
I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS.
IN CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING FIVE
THOUSAND BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIANS STATEWIDE THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION.
ABLE DIFFERENTLY ALLIANCE OF
NURSES FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASTHMA A
COLLABORATIVE AND THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR.
AS I SAID MY GROUP IS PRIMARILY
IS BREAST CANCER SURVIVORS ONE
IN EIGHT WOMEN IN THE UNITED
STATES WILL CONTRACT BREAST
CANCER IN HER LIFETIME SO IT'S
NOT A SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
FOR US IN SHORT THIS IS NOT JUST.
A RIGHT TO KNOW PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS REALLY A RIGHT TO
PROTECT OURSELVES -- AS PEOPLE
OF A HIGH RISK AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN ON WHO ARE ALSO AT
HIGHER RISK BECAUSE THEY ARE.
CHILDREN OF MOTHERS WITH BREAST
CANCER -- AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SPARE OUR KIDS IN THE HALL NEXT
GENERATION FROM THE PAIN OF
GOING TO THE JOURNEY WE'VE GONE
THROUGH SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I JUST ASK THAT YOU TO
THE EXTENT THAT.
IF IF YOU WANT TO AGREE WITH
PREVIOUS COMMENTS THAT'S GREAT --
MOST IMPORTANT INFLATION.
HI MY NAME IS SAM AT THE TIRES
AND A MASTERS IN PUBLIC HEALTH
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND FRANCISCO
STATE ND A STUDY COORDINATOR OF
BREAST CANCER OVER TIME -- AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I ALSO
EXPRESSED THE SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA HELP COALITION
ADVOCACY HEALTH CARE WITHOUT
HARM BURNING DISABILITIES
ASSOCIATION OF GEORGIA ILLINOIS
IOWA MAINE.
NEW JERSEY OKLAHOMA SOUTH
CAROLINA TENNESSEE TEXAS AND
UTAH PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES.
AND RMP REGIONAL ASTHMA
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR COMING IN
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
RENTS SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT THAT.
THREE IS THE BROKERAGE I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR A
COUPLE GROUPS AS YOU SO CITIZENS
OF CHORE FOR CHOICE CLEAN WATER
ACTION COMING CLEAN.
COURAGE CAMPAIGN ECOLOGY CENTER
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH STRATEGIES
AND FRIENDS OF THE EARTH
NONTOXIC REVOLUTION OR GET A
BUYER MENTAL COUNCIL FINDS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH NETWORK AND
LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC POLICY
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS TELETRACK AND HERE
ON BEHALF OF BLACK WIMP WELLNESS.
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS
IMPORTANT IRATE SNOW LEGISLATION
OR DRIVE A I AM ALSO HERE.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
HEALTHY AND GREEN ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COALITION ON
OCCUPATIONAL SALT -- SAFETY AND
HEALTH.
WILLING COALITION FOR GREEN
SCHOOLS WORK SAVE AND CALIFORNIA
LEAVE CONSERVATION VOTERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU CRITICIZED.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL NATIONAL STORAGE OF
ACTING COUNCIL THE POINT YOU.
OKAY OUR FOLKS IN OPPOSITION --
SOME OF A OKAY YEAH.
NIKITA CRIED WITH A NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT ALTER ALSO REGISTRY
SUPPORT.
FOR THE FOR STATE AND THE SAVVY
WOMEN'S ALLIANCE THANK YOU SAVVY
WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
I WANT TO MEET THEM [inaudible]
OKAY.
HELLO HELLO PAL FROM BREAST
CANCER ACTION HERE IN SUPPORT
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF ALASKA
COMMUNITY ACTION ON TOXINS
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE.
CAMPAIGN FOR HEALTHIER SOLUTIONS
JUST TRANSITION ALLIANCE.
CALIFORNIA PAD ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES AGAINST TOXINS
CALIFORNIA FOR A HEALTHY AND
GREEN ECONOMY.
CAUGHT COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT.
CENTER ON REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
AND JUSTICE AT UC BERKELEY LAW.
AND UCLA CENTER FOR STUDY OF
WOMEN THANK YOU.
HELLO BRINGING UP THE REAR OF
THE SET THEM FLEET BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS WOMEN'S
VOICES FOR THE EARTH AND SIERRA
CLUB AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
DERMATOLOGISTS AND A NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES. 100% PURE BEAUTY
COUNTER CALIFORNIA BABY COATED.
THE CREDO BEAUTY CRUNCHY DENNIS
BIRTH MAMA ORGANIC ECO PLUM
EIGHTY TWO DEGREES ELEVEN WHEN
THE SOLUTIONS EO PRODUCTS THE
FINANCIAL SKIN CARE GODDESS
GARDEN HAND SKIN CARE COSMETICS
HAPPY PRETTY YOU RICKY SALON SPA.
IN HARMONY NATURALS INNER SENSE
ORGANIC BEAUTY INTELLIGENT
NUTRIENTS JUICE BEAUTY JUST THE
GOODS MINDFUL MINERALS OHSAA
ALSO NATURALS.
SKIN ANIL SPROUT F. S. SAN
FRANCISCO SON INTEGRITY SKIN
CARE SALON SO STAY NATURAL
SCHISMS ORGANIC SO LONG TEN OVER
TEN STORE A BIO COSMETICS AND
THE HOLISTIC HEALTH COMPANY.
GO [inaudible]
ROOM.
SET OFF FAST YOU'RE REALLY
PILING ON CENTER THIS IS.
QUITE A LIST OKAY.
ALL RIGHTS ANYMORE SUPPORT NOPE
YEP.
OKAY OPPOSITION FOLKS WANNA
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHER MEMBERS
MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
WERE TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING.
HUNDREDS OF BEAUTY AND PERSONAL
CARE COMPANIES MANY OF THEM
LOCATED RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND SOME IN YOUR DISTRICT MISTER
CHAIR -- I WANNA FIRST OFF START
OFF BY SAYING.
THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND WITH THE
SPONSORS AND WE APPRECIATE THE
FORM IN WHICH THE BILL IS IN
RIGHT NOW AND I ALL THAT SAID I
THINK WE HAVE.
TO WE HAVE REMAINING CONCERNS ON
THE BILL AND ALL SPEND A PART OF
MY TESTIMONY TALKING ABOUT THOSE
CONCERNS.
BUT AT THE HEART OF OUR
OPPOSITION IS REALLY THIS ISSUE
OVER AND THE INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY OF OUR PRODUCTS --
NAMELY WITH RESPECT TO THE
FRAGRANCES AND FLAVORS OF OUR
PRODUCTS.
IF YOU WALK DOWN AN AISLE OF A
STORE AND YOU LOOK AT A CONSUMER
TESTING OUT A PRODUCT BEFORE HE
OR SHE IS BUYING T.
YOU'LL USUALLY SEE THAT PERSON
TAKING THE PRODUCT PUTTING IN
HIS -- HAND SMELLING IT.
FRAGRANCES AND FLAVORS ARE A
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
PRODUCTS.
AND SO -- REALLY BALANCING THE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY IN THE
PRESERVATION OF TRADE SECRET
WITH RESPECT TO THESE PRODUCTS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO US.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT COCA COLA AND
JUST AS AN EXAMPLE AND TE
MANNER IN WHICH THEY BEEN ABLE
TO KEEP THEIR SECRET RECIPE
SECRET -- FOR THE LAST ONE
HUNDRED YEARS CONSIDER IF THAT
RECIPE WAS MADE PUBLIC AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COUNTERFEIT IF
IT WERE MADE PUBLIC -- THAT IS
PRECISELY THE CONCERN HERE AND I
THINK THAT THE PUBLIC POLICY
QUESTION THAT WE NEED A WAY HERE.
IS BALANCING A CONSUMERS RIGHT
TO KNOW WITH BALANCING A
COMPANIES RIGHT TO PRESERVE ITS
TRADE SECRET TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE WITH RESPECT TO ITS
PRODUCTS.
I'M WE'VE HEARD A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE CLEANING PRODUCTS
RIGHT TO KNOW ACT WHICH WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR BY THIS BODY
AND IT'S BEEN REFERENCE MANY
TIMES WITH RESPECT TO THIS BILL --
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT CLEANING
PRODUCTS ARE DIFFERENT THAN
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS WHICH ARE DIFFERENT
THAN FIND FRAGRANCES.
AND SO I THINK THAT THOUGHT OF
KNOWLEDGE MINT IS VERY IMPORTANT
AS YOU LOOK AT THIS BILL AND
THINK THROUGH THAT FRAME.
I WITH ALL THAT SAID OUR
INDUSTRY IS VERY PROGRESSIVE
WITH RESPECT TO DISCLOSURE WE'VE
BEEN DISCLOSING OUR INGREDIENTS
IN OUR PRODUCTS SINCE THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES -- AND I
THINK THERE IS A PATH TO THIS
BILL AND I THINK I FEEL LIKE
WE'RE CLOSE -- WITH ALL THAT
SAID I DO WANT TO RUN THROUGH
VERY QUICKLY ARE REMAINING
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL -- WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE OVER THE
COUNTER COSMETICS EXEMPTED FROM
THE BILL IN PART BECAUSE AS IT
KNOWLEDGE BY THE SUPPORTERS IT
IS REGULATED BY THE FDA.
VERY RIGOROUSLY REGULATED BY THE
FDA SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE --
TC'S TAKEN OUT FROM THE BILL --
AND BECAUSE THIS BILL REQUIRES
DISCLOSURE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DATABASE AND
BECAUSE THERE ARE TWENTY SOME
ODD LISTS DESIGNATED LISTS THAT
WOULD PROMPT DISCLOSURE UNDER
THE BILL WE WOULD LIKE FOR DPH.
TO REGULARLY UPDATE THOSE LESS
ON THE DECK DPH WEBSITE WHICH I
THINK IS AN AGREEABLE THING
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR COMPANIES
ESPECIALLY THE SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZE COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP UP WITH THOSE LESS AS
INGREDIENTS ARE UPDATED AS A
REMOVED OR ADDED X. ADDRESS --
UNIFORMITY IS ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT SO PART OF OUR ****
PREEMPION.
IF WE ARE SABOTAGING STATEWIDE
POLICY WE WOULD LIKE FOR THIS TO
BE THE STATEWIDE POLICY.
AND ALONG THOSE LINES WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE ALIGNMENT
WITH EXISTING DEFINITIONS THAT
ARE READY AN EXISTING LAW.
THERE IS A DIFFERENT DEFINITION
OF INGREDIENT A DIFFERENT
DEFINITION FOR COSMETIC
PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC AND TRADE
SECRET THAN IS ALREADY FOUND IN
EXISTING LAW.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE
ALIGNED WITH EXISTING
DEFINITIONS [inaudible]
I'M.
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION PROTECTION IS STILL
REMAINING CONCERN OF OURS.
WE APPRECIATE WHAT IS IN THE
LANGUAGE HOWEVER DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH UNDER THEIR
EXISTING AUTHORITY HAS THE
INVESTIGATIVE AUTHORITY TO ****
FOR FULL FORMULATION.
AND WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY LIKE
TO HAVE SOME PROTECTIONS AROUND
THAT TO SAY THAT IF WE DO REVEAL
OUR FULL FORMULATION THAT.
THAT INFORMATION IS -- WILL BE
MADE OUT TO THE PUBLIC AND
FINALLY -- WE WOULD REALLY LIKE --
MORE OF A QUESTION THAT WE LKE
TO POSE A COMMITTEE SINCE THIS
IS A CONSUMERS RIGHT TO KNOW
BILL -- WITH THIS BILL DOES
REQUIRE US TO DISCLOSE THESE
INGREDIENTS ON TO IT DPH WEBSITE.
AND ONE THAT WE BELIEVE IS NOT
OFTEN USED BY CONSUMERS AND IF
THE GOAL REALLY IS TO DISCLOSE
TO CONSUMERS SIMILAR TO THE
CLEANING PRODUCTS RIGHT TO KNOW
CT BILL WHICH YOU GUYS PASSED
LAST YEAR -- THAT BILL REQUIRES
DISCLOSURE OF INGREDIENT
INFORMATION ON TO THE
MANUFACTURER'S WEBSITE AND WE
THINK THAT THAT IS THE MOST
LOGICAL PLACE FOR INGREDIENT THE
SOLDIER TO TAKE PLACE WITH
RESPECT TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
WE GIVE OUT OKAY MOSQUE ABOUT
THAT.
THIS ROOM RIGHT NOW COOKING
UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE FRAGRANCE
CREATORS ASSOCIATION WHERE THE
PRINCIPAL TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE FRAGRANCE INDUSTRY IN THE
UNITED STATES AND WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE LOS AMENDED POSITION ON
SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR OUR MEMBERS
CREATE MANUFACTURE FRAGRANCES
INCENSE FOR PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS AS WELL AS HOME CARE
PRODUCTS -- WE ALSO REPRESENT
FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS SUPPLIERS
AND FINISHED PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS OF FRAGRANCE
CONTAINING PRODUCTS.
THE INDUSTRY IS FIRST AND
FOREMOST COMMITTED TO THE SAETY
OF OUR PRODUCT THE END WE'VE
ESTABLISHED THE RESEARCH
INSTITUTE A FRAGRANCE MATERIALS
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX AND THE
ORGANIZATION CONTINUALLY
EVALUATE THE FRAGRANCE PALETTE
OF INGREDIENTS AND PLACES
RESTRICTIONS ON INGREDIENTS AND
HAS EVEN BANNED INGREDIENTS WHEN
SCIENCE SUPPORTED THE NEED TO DO
SO EVEN IN THE ABSENCE OF FORMAL
GOVERNMENT'S REQUIRING US.
WE ALSO TAKING GREETING
COMMUNICATION OF THE MATERIALS
WE USE VERY SERIOUSLY WE ARE
RESPONDING TO THE INCREASED
DESIRE OF CONSUMERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS IN THE
PRODUCTS THEY USE EVERY DAY.
IN OUR MEMBERS STRIVE TO HELP
THEIR CUSTOMERS WHO ARE THE
CAUSE MEDIC MANUFACTURERS TO
DELIVER THAT INFORMATION TO
CONSUMERS WHILE ALSO PRESERVING
THE UNIQUENESS.
OF THESE PROPRIETARY BLENDS
WHICH IS THE ARTISTRY OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BUILT THEIR
BUSINESSES AROUND.
WE HOPE WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT
BOUNCE IN SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR IN ADDITION TO
THE COMMENTS MENTIONED BY THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNSEL I
JUST WANNA QUICKLY ODD.
ARE MENTION A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE LEADING --
THE FRAGRANCE ALLERGEN LESS FROM
THE DESIGNATED LESS WE BELIEVE --
THIS MAKES IT VERY CLEAR TO THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY HOW TO
COMPLY WITH THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON THOSE ALLERGENS.
ALSO IN REGARDS TO TIME LINES
AND DPH MAINTAINING THE LIST OF
LISTS IF YOU WELL -- AS WAS
MENTIONED IN MANDY'S COMMENTS WE
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE REFERENCE
IN THE ANALYSIS -- SUGGESTION
THAT THE AUTHORS AND SPONSORS
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
WE LOOK FORWARD TO DOING THAT --
AND LASTLY I DO WANT TO TOUCH ON
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT LANGUAGES
IN THE BILL WE HAVE PROVIDED
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS -- TO MAKE
SURE THE LANGUAGE ACCURATELY
REFLECTS FRAGRANCE MATERIALS AND
THE POTENTIAL HAZARDS THAT CAN
BE ASSOCIATED TO THESE
INGREDIENTS FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE
UNAWARE OF FRAGRANCE ALLERGENS
THAT COULD BE LIFE THREATENING
AS THAT LANGUAGE SUGGEST.
AND I KNOW OFTEN THE LEGISLATIVE
FINDINGS AND DECLARATION CAN
TAKE A BACKSEAT TO THE ACTUAL
STATUTE BUT THESE DECLARATIONS
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND THEY
SHOULD BE ACCURATE.
THE WERE STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING A CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOGUE ON HOW BEST TO
COMMUNICATE FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENTS AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORED
THANK YOU.
I'M OKAY YES FOLKS WANNA WIN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR EMBERS TRANSMIT ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
WICCANS WHICH CONSISTS OF THE
MANUFACTURERS OF OVER THE
COUNTER DRUGS AND MEDICINES.
AND WERE CONCERNED THAT THE
DEFINITION OF COSMETIC PRODUCTS
MAIN CAMPUS -- EITHER
INTENTIONALLY OR UNINTENTIONALLY --
SOME OF THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY
MANUFACTURED [inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ON CAP CAME ACU CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO AND
OPPOSE UNLESS I'M IN A POSITION
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAM REGULAR
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
I SO THAT IS FOR THE COMMITTEE
SO I'M.
MAYBE ARE FOR HIM [inaudible]
WELL.
MACOMBER ONE A ADVOCATES UP AND
THEN WE CAN HAVE KIND OF BACKING
FOR THAT ARE WHO IS THE LEAD
[inaudible]
I'M.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO I'VE THROUGH THE
PROPONENTS CAN YOU.
I MEAN I HEARD A NUMBER OF
ISSUES AND THE LIST OF LESS
THERE IS A WEBSITE.
I'M CAN YOU CAN I MEAN SOUNDS
LIKE THERE'S GOOD MOVEMENT ON
THE CONVERSATION BUT CAN YOU
GIVE US A SENSE OF YOUR RESPONSE
TO THE THE THEIR ISSUES RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION I MEAN YOU
KNOW WE OBVIOUSLY WANT TO MAKE
THIS.
WORK YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO I WOULD
FIRST SAY THAT WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS IN EACH COMMITTEE
IT'S BEEN HEARD FROM SO AS THE
OPPOSITION BRINGS UP -- THEIR
CONCERNS WEHAVE TRIED TO AMEND
THE BILL TO RELIEVE THEIR AND
THEIR CONCERNS ARE THEIR
OPPOSITION.
AT SOME POINT IF YOU TAKE TOO
MANY AMENDMENTS THE BILL ISN'T
WORTH DOING A TWO THINGS
SPECIFICALLY THAT I WOULD LIKE --
TO TO ADDRESS ARE ACTUALLY ONE
TO KNOW -- TO WE ARE NOT
REQUIRING THE RECIPE TO BE MADE
PUBLIC AND ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE JUST TOOK IN YOUR
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR.
IS THE CHANGES TO TRADE SECRET
DEFINITION TO MAKE SURE THAT
STATE WILL NOT RELEASE FULL
PRODUCT FORMULATION INFORMATION
TO THE PUBLIC.
PROTECTING THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
CHANEL RECIPE OR ANY OTHER
RECIPE.
SECONDLY WITH BIG WITHOUT REGARD
TO THE FDA.
JUST BECAUSE IT'S FDA APPROVED
DOES NOT MEAN WE KNOW WHAT IS IN
THE FLAVOR OR THE THE PERFUME.
FTA DOES NOT NOTE NOR DOES ANY
OTHER GOVERNMENT ENTITY REQUIRE
DISCLOSURE OF THE FRAGRANCE FOR
FLAVOR INGREDIENTS EVEN IN
APPROVED PRODUCTS SO JUST
BECAUSE IT'S FDA APPROVED DOES
NOT MEAN THAT THEY ARE GOING
AFTER WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN
THIS BILL.
SO I WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRY
AND WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION BUT
AGAIN AT SOME POINT YOU GET TO A
POINT WHERE YOU HAVE TO HOLD ON
TO SOMETHING ARE YOU DON'T EVEN
HAVE A BILL.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS A NEW
ONE YEAH THERE'S THERE'S A
COUPLE OF THINGS.
I'D LOVE I'D LOVE TO ADDRESS --
ONE IS AROUND THE EXEMPTION OF
OF OTC PRODUCTS -- WHAT THAT
REFERS TO OUR COSMETIC PRODUCTS
THAT MAKE A MEDICAL CLAIM WE
THINK OF THEM AS BECAUSE MASUDA
COLES AND THEY ARE REGULATED
DIFFERENTLY BY THE FDA -- AND
THEY INCLUDE THINGS LIKE ANTI
PERSPIRANT SUNSCREENS --
TOOTHPASTES WITH -- THAT FIGHT
GINGIVITIS I MEAN ANYTHING
ANYTHING THAT MAKES A MEDICAL
CLAIM.
IS REGULATED DIFFERENTLY BY THE
FDA BUT BUT TWO THINGS ONE THIS
BILL ISN'T ABOUT REGULATION IT'S
ABOUT DISCLOSURE.
SO THAT PART IS IRRELEVANT AND
THE OTHER PART IS THAT THE SAFE
COSMETICS PROGRAM IN CONSUMERS
DON'T DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
KOSMOS ARTICLES AND COSMETICS
CURRENTLY.
BECAUSE MISTER NICHOLS ARE BEING
REPORTED TO THE SAFE COSMETICS
PROGRAM IF THEY CONTAIN A PROP
SIXTY FIVE CHEMICAL.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF BECAUSE
MISTER NICHOLS CURRENTLY IN THE
SAFE COSMETICS DATABASE AND
CONSUMERS.
IF THEY'RE USING AN ANTI
PERSPIRANT OR DEODORANT THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT ONE IS AN OTC
REGULATED PRODUCT AND THE OTHER
IS SO.
THAT TO ME FEELS A LITTLE BIT
LIKE A RED HERRING.
I'M.
SHOULD I GO ON QUESTION -- LET'S
LET'S THANK YOU THANK YOU I I I
I I YEAH THIRTY BULLETS HERE
FROM MINE FROM SUMMER HOUSE HE I
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE ANY ODD
QUESTION SITE.
OKAY -- WELL IT'S TEMPTING TO
GET INTO A TRADE SECRET
DISCUSSION WE'RE NOT INTO THE
ISSUE WE ARE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY SO I'M GOING TO CONTROL
MYSELF -- YOU CAN TRY SEVEN
JUDICIARY IS WELL I JUST WHAT
I'M THERE I'M THERE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT -- LOOK I I I I
APPRECIATE THE FACT YOU CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER AND I MEAN I
UNDERSTAND YOU YOU WANT -- TO
YOU KNOW I WILL SAY ON THINGS
LIKE.
BUT HE'S UP ON A WEBSITE THEY
MAY NOT BE USED BY FOLKS MAYBE
THERE'S A BETTER WAY I DON'T
KNOW.
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT I'M.
LOOKING FOR DID SEEM TO WORK OUT
BUT I DO THINK ESSENTIALLY WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT AND I'M.
AS YOU SAY TO DISCLOSURE BILL
ALLOWS CONSUMERS OR THE MORE
INFORMATION AS TO WHAT.
FACTOR BUT NOT THEIR FACES IN
OUR BODIES AND IN THEIR BODIES
ITS ADDRESS SO -- I UNDERSTAND
THIS IS BILLS GOT A LONG WAY TO
GO AND JUST A LOT MORE WORK TO
BE DONE -- BUT I'M CERTAINLY --
ONE SUPPORTED TODAY TO TO TO
MOVE THE CONVERSATION FOR TO
MOVE THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE -- FOR
ITSELF WITHOUT ENTERTAIN A
MOTION OKAY SO IT'S REMOVED IF
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A AS YOU
RIGHTLY SAID IT IS A DISCLOSURE
BILL IT IS NOT A LABELING BILL
WERE NODDING AND WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR ANY LABELING TO
HAPPEN WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR THEM
TO BE. TO BAN ANY OF THE
PRODUCTS THEY USE YOU KNOW AS A
SOCIETY WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GET
BETTER.
AND AS WE MOVE ALONG AND WE
REALIZE THAT THERE COULD BE
THINGS OUT THERE THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IN OUR ON OUR BODIES THE
COULD BE CART CAUSING US HARM.
PEOPLE JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT
YEAH I WANT TO KNOW THAT WHEN
THE OPPOSITION ASKED ME WHY DID
THE BILL I SAID YOU KNOW I SAID.
PART OF THE REASON IS BECAUSE
WHEN I WAS ELECTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE DAY AFTER
I WAS ELECTED WE FOUND OUT MY
FIFTY YEAR OLD HUSBAND.
WHO'S IN GREAT HEALTH GREAT
SHAPE RARELY EXERCISES HAD
KIDNEY CANCER NO CLUE WHERE THAT
COULD HAVE COME FROM WE WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT I'M NOT SAYING
ANYTHING HE USES GAVE HIM THAT.
BUT MORE MORE PEOPLE HAVE CANCER
MORE MORE PEOPLE HAVE ALLERGIES
PEOPLE JUST HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE PUTTING IN AND ON
THEIR BODIES.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT TO THE ITEM IS BàN --
MOVED BY CINEMA CASKEY -- SECTOR
PLEASE KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE SEVEN
FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA THE
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES
[inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
WHY CASKEY LIKE OWSKI I?
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I THANK YOU
FOR THE SENATE VERSION THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
TINA [inaudible]
HE COMPARISON [inaudible]
BILL STILL [inaudible]
WHAT?
WE'D LIKE YOU STERN YEAH.
YES CENTER STERN ONCE YOU.
KAMALA DíAS IN.
WILL HAVE YOU START WITH THE SB.
SIX THIRTEEN THIS ITEM THIRTEEN
AND YOUR I DON'T KNOW I'M SORRY
I WAS SERVICE ITEM.
TEN IS SB FOUR SIXTY THREE
NATURAL GAS STORAGE WELLS
MONITORING AND REPORTING
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ON WE GO.
SORRY FOR THE DELAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
THIS IS A PRETTY STRAIGHT FOR
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE.
THE THE RULES THAT APPLY.
TO THE FRACKING INDUSTRY WHICH
WE SET OUT A FEW YEARS BACK WHEN
WE REALIZED WE HAD NO IDEA WHAT
CHEMICALS.
THE INDUSTRY WAS USING TO
EXTRACT IN -- YEAH -- USE OUR
OIL AND GAS RESOURCES -- DO NOT
CURRENTLY APPLY TO NATURAL GAS
STORAGE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S BEEN A
HUGE PROBLEM FOR US AFTER THE
ONLY SO CANYON DISASTER.
WHERE WE HAD?
BUT TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE GET
PUSHED OUT OF THEIR HOMES FOR
THE LARGEST GHASTLY CAN US
HISTORY AND A LOT OF THEM GOT
SICK AND ARE STILL SICK AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WHY [inaudible]
AND WE HAVE FOUND OUT IN RECENT
MONTHS THAT.
WELL THE WHOLE THERE WAS STILL
OIL IN THAT FORMATION.
AS WELL AS HEAVY METALS AND
OTHER CARCINOGENIC MATERIALS
THAT AT THE TIME THE GAS COMPANY
DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE WERE.
PUSHED INTO THE AIR AND WE FOUND
OUT THROUGH SOUTH COAST RECORDS.
FROM EARLIER DISCLOSURE THAT
LONG HOLD PEOPLE WORK GETTING
SICK BECAUSE THERE'S BARIUM IN
PEOPLE'S COUCHES OR THEY WERE
DEALING WITH BENZENE BECAUSE
THERE WAS OIL IN THERE WHAT WE
NEED TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
PUTTING IN.
THAT STORAGE FACILITY OTHER
STORAGE FACILITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THIS
BILL MOVED.
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT LAST
YEAR WITH A PORT FOR BECAUSE OF
PROCEDURAL ISSUES OR JUST WILL
BRING IT BACK THIS YEAR AND THIS
IS THE VERY LEAST.
IN MY VIEW THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING ON NATURAL GAS STORAGE IN
THE STATE I THINK THERE'S
ACTUALLY A LOT MORE CONCERNED.
ABOUT HOW CLOSE THEY ARE TO
COMMUNITIES BUT I'VE I FIGURED
WE SHOULD AT LEAST STARTWITH
THIS BASIC STEP OF A RIGHT TO
KNOW -- I KNOW YOU GUYS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT TRANSPARENCY OTHER
CONTEXT BUT HERE I THINK IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE.
SO WITH THAT RESPECT AS RIVAL A
BILL ELLIOT IS HERE -- WITH
ENVIRONMENT WORKING.
THIS BILL ELIA ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP.
I'M WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING
INTO THESE NATURAL GAS STORAGE
AREAS AND WHAT COULD COME OUT
THE UNFORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCE
THAT WAS.
THE LEAST SO CANYON THING WAS A
DRASTIC RESULTS FOR THE
NEIGHBORS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
AND IF IT HAPPENS AGAIN WE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT'SIN THEIR THEIR
NATURAL GAS STORAGE OCCURS IN.
LARGE BASINS SCATTERED AROUND
THE STATE THERE WAS ONE PROPOSED
FOR SOUTH SACRAMENTO UNDER
RESIDENTIAL AREA THAT WAS.
NOT APPROVED EVENTUALLY IN A
MATTER WHERE THEY ARE EITHER
EXISTING LONG TERM HISTORICAL
THEIR SUMMER VERY OLD NOW.
OR WHETHER WE HAVE TO PROPOSE
NEW ONES -- WE SHOULD KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT'S OING IN AND AND
HAVE A US SYSTEMATIC APPROACH --
TO INVENTORYING THAT BOTH THE AN
IMPOSSIBLE OUT THANK YOU.
TRANSPORT REMEMBERS NIKITA
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD DISCLOSURE
TRANSPARENCY BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HERNANDEZ WAS THE A CAPPELLA
FORTY IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
HOW MANY ORGANIZATIONS?
YOU KNOW IF ANYONE THIS TIME AT
LISETTE BENTLEY BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS THANK YOU IN
SUPPORT.
MIKE MATTER CONSUMER WATCHDOG IN
OKAY ZERO SEVEN SUPPORT AND YOUR
BILL.
IT'S GOOD OKAY SO I'M YEAH THIS
ONE ARE LIKE HOPEFULLY ALL OF
THEM WHO KNOWS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S FIND OUT SO WILL --
NOW WHERE FROM FOLKS WHO WANT TO
RAISE OPPOSITION.
AND UNITS GOT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
OKAY.
SO THE BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
COMMENTS FROM ANYBODY NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION.
NOT YET MISTER MEREDITH WE HAVE
A DIRECTION OF WHERE WE THINK
THE LEAD AGENCIES GOING TO BE ON
THIS.
IT SAID THAT THE STAFF REPORT
TALKS ABOUT.
WE MIGHT WANNA [inaudible]
PICK.
ONE YES WHAT DO YOU SAY
[inaudible]
THAT.
OF MY ABLE CONSULTANT HERE IS
SAYING THAT WE THINK IT'LL TAY
WITH DOGGER BUT THAT THE AIRPORT
IS GOING TO BE.
GETTING MORE DIRECTLY INVOLVED.
I SUPPOSE THAT'S WHERE IT'S
GOING I AND THE DRIVERS BEEN
THROUGH A SERIES OF REFORMS BUT
HOW SOLID THEY'LL BE -- REMAINS
TO BE SEEN THEY'RE NOT A PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCY BY DESIGN SO.
WE CERTAINLY FELL DOWN ON THE
JOB DURING THE LEAK I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE --
REPORTING ON THE CHEMICALS AND
ENHANCE.
UNDER ENHANCE RECOVERY IN OIL
YOU YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR CHEMICALS
ARE VIEW YOU COULD YOU CREATE
THEM YOU PUT THE MEN.
THEN YOU WHEN YOU PRODUCE THE
OIL YOU PULL THEM OUT AND YOU
HAVE YOU HAVE THAT LEFTOVERS AND
YOU CAN DO THE ANALYSIS.
HOW IF YOU PUT THE?
ENHANCE CHEMICALS IN WITH THE
NATURAL GAS YOU SHOULD KNOW WHO
THEY ARE WHAT THEY ARE BUT IF IT
LEAKS OUT HOW WOULD YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT WAS -- BECAUSE YOU'RE
SOME NATURAL OCCURRING CANNELLA
EVERYBODY AGREES WITH THAT.
THIS S AN EMPTY OIL FIELD -- SO
THERE'S THERE'S LEFTOVER DEPOSIT
THAT MIGHT BE DISTINGUISHED FROM
THE CHEMICALS THEY USED ACTUALLY.
BRAK.
FOR RAIN OR EXTRACT -- SO I
GUESS YOU'D HAVE TO DO SOME KIND
OF DEDUCTION BASED ON WHAT THE
UP FRONT DISCLOSURE IS RIGHT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO DISCLOSURE IN
ADVANCE.
THAT'S THE EASY PART I THINK ANY.
WELL I THINK IT SHOULD BE AND
I'M AND I'VE HEARD AND I
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE CONFIRMATION
ON THIS AND WE LOVE EACH USE
HELP AND SUPPORT GOING FOR TO DO
MORE INVESTIGATION HERE WE HAVE
TO DO SOME OVERSIGHT HEARINGS
FRANKLY BUT BUT THE CONTINUOUS
AIR MONITORING.
I'VE HEARD IS NOT STILL
OCCURRING AT ALL THE WELL HEADS --
I'D I DON'T HAVE THAT. FOR SURE
<c.green>UT I THINK IT SHOULD BE</c>
CONTINUES AIR MONITORING ON ALL
OIL AND GAS WELLS RANKLY
ANYWHERE WITHIN A A COMMUNITY
THAT'S IMPACTED SO THAT SEEMS
LIKE THE ONLY REASONABLE WAY TO
FIGURE OUT -- IF WHAT WINNING IS
ALSO WHAT'S COMING OUT.
I'M NOT MANAGING YOUR BILL BUT
THAT'S A BIG PRICE TAG JUST ONE
ON THAT CONTINUOUS MANNER WHAT
IS FOR HIM.
I MEAN [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
IT'S A COMPLETELY VALID QUESTION.
I MISTER CHAIR I RECOGNIZE THIS
IS A WORK IN PROGRESS -- BUT I'M
WILLING TO MOVE TO BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
BILLS TO MOVE I AND AND YOU KNOW
THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD JOINT
HEARING FOR OUR TO COMMITTEE
YEAH I AGREE I AGREE WE'RE GONNA
LEAN ON IT AND WE WANT TO KEEP
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS THING
AS IT DEVELOPS SO.
WHERE THERE?
ALL RIGHT OF GO QUESTION
COMMITTEE.
BILLS REMOVED I FEEL LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER.
THAT THIS RABBLE OKAY SO SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO MOVE BY
SENATOR CASKEY.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AS BEFORE SIXTY
THREE THE MATH THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN AYE STERN AYE STONE.
WHY CASKEY?
MAKOWSKI AYE ALL RIGHT DID YOU
OF THAT WILL NOW TURN TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN IN YOUR AGENDA
MEMBERS THIS IS -- SB SIX THIRTY
SIX THIRTEEN IS A MAGICAL NUMBER
AND JEWISH FAITH BECAUSE IT'S
THE NUMBER OF OF COMMANDMENTS.
IN THE BIBLE [inaudible]
SO -- WITH THAT WITH THAT
WEIGHTY RESPONSIBILITY ASSOCIATE
WITH THIS NUMBER.
IN MIND.
I CANNOT PROMISE -- ANY DIVINE
INTERVENTIONS WITH THIS MEASURE --
BUT I CAN PROMISE SOME MODEST
PROGRESS -- WE CURRENTLY.
PURCHASE AND CONSUME MANY GOODS
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGH PROCUREMENT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A ANNUAL STATE AGENCY
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION REPORT
CARD.
THAT WE THINK IT'S BEEN REALLY
EFFECTIVE FOR TRACKING HOW
AGENCIES.
OUR STATE AGENCIES ARE ARE
UNDERTAKEN THEIR CLIMATE
COMMITMENTS FOR INSTANCE -- THE
LIGHTING IN THIS BUILDING OR THE
COMMUTES BEING UNDERTAKEN BY
STATE EMPLOYEES OR WHAT KIND OF
POWER SOURCES WERE RELYING ON OR
THE THE USE OF SAY PAPER OR
COMPOSTABLE MATERIALS FOR THE
FOOD SYSTEMS THAT YOU'VE LEAD ON
THIS ISSUE MISTER CHAIR IN THE
PAST -- WERE SAYING HERE THAT
THEY SHOULD ALSO APPLY TO THE TO
THE FOOD BEING PURCHASED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE THINK
IT'S IT COULD ACTUALLY BE A
REALLY EXCITING OPPORTUNITY NOT
JUST. FOR FOR THOSE WHO CARE
ABOUT THE CARBON FOOTPRINT OF
WHAT WE'RE CONSUMING THE STATE
BUT ALSO -- FOR IN STATE --
GROWERS OF OF FOOD WE THINK THAT.
UNDERSTANDING BETTER THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT OF THE FOOD SYSTEM
THAT THE STATE'S PROCURING FROM
COULD ACTUALLY GIVE -- SOME
VALUE TO THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY BECAUSE AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S I COMMUNITY IS THE
MOST ADVANCED I WOULD SAY IN THE
NATION IF NOT THE WORLD.
THE EFFICIENCIES WERE ASKING
THEM TO UNDERGO GREENHOUSE GAS.
REDUCTION TECHNIQUES UNDERGOING
IN HEALTHY SOILS ALTERNATE MANY
OR MANAGEMENT ALL KINDS OF
SECTOR SO WE ACTUALLY TINK
THERE'S AN INTERESTING WHEN WHEN
TO BE HAD HERE BUT THIS IS A
MODEST START THAT WOULD EXPAND
THAT INVENTORY TO APPLY THE FOOD
SECTOR SO THAT'S THE LONG AND
SHORT OF IT -- SO WITH THAT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE NO REAL REWRITE THAT.
THANK YOU SIR I ANYONE WANTS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AND YOU ARE YOUR AVAILABLE IN
SUPPORT.
GREAT.
I THANK YOU I ANYONE ELSE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION --
IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL.
THE NUMBER I WAS FOR THE
COMMITTEE THOUGHT QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE NOW YES.
MAYBE WE CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION
THERE'S NO BRIDGE OPPOSITION.
YES AN AGGRESSION THAT I WOULD
HAVE IT WE'RE IN SCOPE THREE ON
THE I SCOOPFREE ONIONS ON THE
OTHER EMISSIONS AND THESE ARE
THE INDIRECT ANTHROPOLOGICAL --
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
ARE YOU BIFURCATING.
A THE FOOD.
EMISSIONS OR FOOD PROCESSING FEE
FROM THIS.
AND AT FIRST AS ALL THE OTHER
WASTE DISPOSAL.
AB BUSINESS TRAVEL EMPLOYEE
COMMUTING ALL THE OTHER.
BITS AND IF YOU ARE.
WHY WHY WOULDYOU JUST THOUGHT
YOU ALL OF SCOPE?
THREE I'M HERE AT THE THE ONLY
REAL A REQUIREMENT THIS BILL IS
A IS A METHOD A METHODOLOGY IN
ESTIMATES I DON'T THINK IT.
PRE DECIDES THAT -- HOW IT'S
GONNA BE INTEGRATED EITHER
ENDOSCOPE THREE OR ON SOME
SEPARATE TRACK I THINK YOU'VE
GOT TO DO SOME -- SOME ORIGINAL
WORK IN TERMS OF HELP WORKING
WITH THE AG COMMUNITY ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND ALL THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS THAT ARE
OCCURRING BOTH HERE AND WHAT
MAYBE NOT.
WAS NOT OCCURRING ABROAD BUT I'M
OPEN TO INTEGRATION AND SO IT
WAS SORT OF FITS INTO THAT
BROADER ASSESSMENT OF THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT I JUST I JUST KNOW
THIS PIECE IS MISSING RIGHT NOW
SO.
I DON'T I'M I'M NOT -- OKAY
RELIGIOUS ABOUT -- EXACTLY HOW
IT GETS ANYWAY THAT'S YOUR
QUESTION DOES IT GO IN DISCO
THREE ONCE THEY DEVELOP THIS
METHODOLOGY AND AND AND GET THE
REPORT.
MORE.
COMPREHENSIVE IS A FLOW BACK TO
SCOPE THREE OR IS IT'S ON SOME
STEPS SEPARATE TRACK IS NOT
WHITE I KNOW I ASSUME THAT IT'S
IN SCOPE THREE MAYBE I'M MAYBE
I'M WRONG ACT.
I GOT THE DIRECT ANSWER LOGIC
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THE
INDIRECT ONES AND ALL THE OTHER
SO I ASSUME THAT THIS IS ALL THE
OTHER.
AND RIGHT.
WITH A SEPARATE CATEGORY OF
INDIRECT IS GO TO RIGHT NOW YOU
AS WELL MY MY OLD GREENHOUSE GAS
REPORTING KNOWLEDGE HERE BUT TWO
IS ALSO INDIRECT.
BUT THREE IS.
THINGS LIKE INDIRECT LAND USE IN
OTHER COUNTRIES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
SO FOR BUYING THE FROM.
BRAZIL OR AUSTRALIA THAT'S GONNA
HAVE BIGGER SCOPE THREE
EMISSIONS VERSES.
BUYING BEEF IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT.
WE HAVE BETTER DATA ON NOW THE
ONE NO I MEAN I I THINK AS IF
I'M READING THE STAFF REPORT
CORRECTLY.
THESE REPORT CARDS A KELPIE HAIR
ONLY CONTAINED IN SCOPE ONE
SCOPE TO EMISSIONS SO YOU JUST
LOOKING FOR SCOPE TO EMISSIONS
FOR FOOD.
PRODUCTION OR IS IS THIS.
JUST SO THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE DOING I'M NOT I'M
CONFUSED.
IF YOU SEE THAT INDIRECT THEN
THEY WOULD NORMALLY THEY'RE
WORKING ON THE SCOPE TO
EMISSIONS IN THE NORMAL COURSE
OF BUSINESS RIGHT.
I THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE THREE
BUT MAYBE I'M WRONG.
YES TO THAT QUESTION WITHOUT --
LOOKING AT I'M TRYING TO MY
NAVIGATE THIS.
THE CHART RIGHT NOW AND
UNDERSTAND WHETHER IT WOULD FALL
IN THE SCOPE TWO OR THREE BUT
YOU WENT ON A STAMPER --
CERTAINLY THERE.
SINCE IN ART ARE IN OUR
CONSULTANT IS PRETTY -- CLEAR ON
THE FACT THAT THEY WOULD BE
SCOPE THREE OKAY THE MISSION.
OKAY WELL THEN I GREW THE
CONSULTANT.
DO YOU DO YOU LIKE THAT DO NOT
LIKE THAT I'M I'M STRUCTURE I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT YOU
KNOW I CAN ARE YOU GOING HERE I
WILL USE.
THE IN THE NORMAL COURSE OF
BUSINESS THEY WOULD DO ALL
PRODUCTS YOU'RE THIS BILL SAYS
LOOK AT FOOD PRODUCE PRODUCTS
YOU'RE SORT OF SAYING BY FOR
KATE.
ARE IF THIS BILL PASSCODE SIGNED
INTO LAW BY FOR CAPE SCOPE THREE
DO THE FOOD PRODUCTS INSTEAD OF
DOING ALL THE LIKE BUSINESS
TRAVEL AND YEAH.
EMPLOYEE COMMUTING AND USE OF OF
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES SOLD WASTE
DISPOSAL AND ALL THESE OTHER
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION THINKS
pOUT.
I'M OPEN EXT YOU'RE SAYING JUST
TO ADD TO MAKE IT A FULLY
COMPREHENSIVE SCOPE THREE FOUR
DELVING INTO THAT WORLD SHOULD
WHY SHOULD WE COVER EVERYTHING.
WELL YOU MIGHT CHECK WITH THE
AGENCY I MEAN I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE WHAT THE GAME PLAN IS AND
HOW THE ROLLING OUT.
OUT THE STUFF I JUST THAT'S MY
QUESTION I WAS JUST OF WELL I I
WOULD THE GAME TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO FLESH THAT OUT.
FIGURE OUT OF IT MAKES MORE
SENSE TO HAVE A MORE EXPANSIVE
LOOK AT IT.
A LOOK AT INPUT FROM CAL RECYCLE --
I THINK THERE'S COULD ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP IN A
STAFF REPORT SO I APPRECIATE
DRILLING DOWN ON THAT AND I'M.
VERY OPEN TO IT I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO FIX THAT TODAY -- BUT YEAH WE
WE'VE BEEN JUST TRYING TO GET
OUR HEADS WRAPPED AROUND THE
FOOD SECTOR FOR A LONG TIME AND
IT'S AN EASY ONE TO KICK DOWN
THE ROAD IT'S VERY.
IT'S IT'S A LOT EASIER TO GET
YOUR HEAD WRAPPED AROUND SOME OF
THESE OTHER EMISSIONS SECTORS
BUT WITH ALL THE EFFORTS GOING
ON IN AGRICULTURE IN THIS STATE
WE AT LEAST ONE FOR THE STATE
PORTION THAT WERE BUYING TO BE --
RECOGNIZING ALL THE GOOD
ACTIVITIES GOING ON IN IN THE
STATE SO THE SEEM LIKE THE RIGHT
METHOD.
I KNOW THIS IS A BIT OF A LIKE A
LATE GUNMEN -- NO.
NOW THE THING IS THAT WE HAVE
GOTTEN MEN WASN'T [inaudible]
OKAY WELL.
IT'S BEEN PRINT REGARDLESS -- I
WHY DON'T WE I DID YOU WANT TO
MAKE MAYBE.
I CAN COMMIT TO WORK WITH BUT I
WANT TO OWN A MOVE THE BILL LONG
YEAH NO NO I I THINK WE'RE FINE
WITH THAT -- BUT THE LET'S LET'S
WORK TOGETHER.
HI.
LET'S WORK TOGETHER TO THE TO
KIND OF OWNING MY REVENGE
[inaudible]
ON WHO IS RUNNING POINT -- STAFF
ON THIS.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT OKAY
OKAY ALL RIGHT THE NOVEL IDEA
OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY WE'LL WE'LL
WE'LL WORK WITH YOU I'M MOVING
FORWARD ON THIS AND THEN.
GET OUT OKAY SO WITH THAT THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED I FEEL LIKE
THIS CLOSE.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DILIGENCE.
pYOU RAISE SOME GOOD POINTS ABOUT.
IF WE'RE GONNA SCOPE IT SCOPE IT
ACCURATELY -- AND AND
INTEGRATING POWER CYCLE MAKES
SOME SENSE HERE SO GAME TO KEEP
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE IN
WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK.
OKAY AREN'T [inaudible]
I BILLS REMOVED BY SUMMER CASKEY
CENTERPIECE CORAL.
I REMEMBER THIRTEEN SB SIX ONE
THREE BY SENATOR STERN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES NO HILL.
SKINNER.
STERN RIGHT STERN AYE STONE AYE
CASKEY.
MAKOWSKI AYE OKAY WILL BE VOTE
OPENED -- FOR OTHER FOLKS TO ADD
ON BUT IT'S WELL ON ITS WAY.
ALL RIGHT -- SHE WITH THIS GUY
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
HE'S STILL MY PLACE THE GF.
OKAY.
WILL NOW TURN TO US SINCE SINCE
US SENATE HOST HERE WE IT'S NOW
NOW TIME FOR STERN THE BOTTLE
BILL.
ARE ONE OF WINTERS CENTER HILLS
FAVORITE ISSUES.
AND DONE THIS IS ITEM TWENTY
THIS IS SB.
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR IN YOUR
AGENDAS MEMBERS [inaudible]
AND THIRTY MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS SB SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
SIX PROVIDE SHORT TERM
STABILIZATION TO THE BOTTOM THE
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED BACK IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX AND SOMEHOW
TO START CHIPPING AWAY AT THE
LONGEVITY OF A BROADER STATE
COMMITMENT. TO NOT JUST
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY BUT TO OUR
BROADER WASTE REDUCTION GOALS I
DON'T WANT TO OVER PROMISE WITH
THIS BILL IS.
IT IS NOT -- THE FINAL ANSWER TO
SOLVING THE IMPASSE WE FACE BUT
WE KNOW THAT.
WHEN IT COMES?
TO CURBSIDE RECYCLING EFFORTS
THEY'RE THEY'RE FALLING DOWN AND
WE'VE WE'VE NOT DONE A GOOD-ENOUGH JOB THERE WE KNOW THAT --
**** ESPECIALLY OUR SMALL
GROCERS ARE NOW.
FACED WITH A SITUATION WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE AREAS AND
ARE BEING FORCED INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THEY HAVE TO BE.
EITHER FIND OR ADD IN SOME NEW
COSTLY INTAKE.
MECHANISM SO WE'RE TRYING TO
BOTH STIMULATE THE MARKET BOTH
ON ADVANCE RECYCLING IN THE
PLASTICS AREA CURBSIDE BUT ALSO
TO TRY TO FIND [inaudible]
SOME.
NEW APPROACH AT LEAST NINE THE
GROUNDWORK FOR A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TAKE ON HOW WE RECYCLE
IN THE STATE I KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE CONCERNS EXPRESSED
BY.
SOME OF THOSE NHà OPPOSITION I
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO CONSUMER
WATCHDOG ABOUT A REPORT THEY
JUST PUT OUT SAYING WE NEED TO
FOCUS.
MORE ON GETTING MORE PEOPLE TO
GET THEIR BOTTLES BACK TO THE
STORES -- V. IN AND GET YOUR
MONEY BACK -- I DON'T COMPLETELY
DISAGREE BUT I ALSO THINK THAT --
THE FUTURE MAY LOOK A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN IT HAS IN THE
PAST AND THIS MODEL BEING ABLE
GOOD ON YOUR MOM AND POP GROCERY
STORE A LIQUOR STORE DOWN THE
STREET AND MAKE THAT.
THE WAY YOU OBTAIN YOUR
REDEMPTION.
MAYBE I'M TO MILLENNIAL BUT I
DON'T I I DON'T ANTICIPATE
DRIVING AROUND TOWN.
LOOKING FOR PLACES TO DROP OFF
MY RECYCLING AND GET SOME
REDEMPTION BACK I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO COME UP WITH
SMARTER DISTRIBUTED STRATEGIES.
IMPROVE YOUR GAME ON CURBSIDE
IMPROVING SOME OF THE PLASTIC
RECYCLING TECHNOLOGY SO THIS
PUTTING A LITTLE BIT OF NEAR
TERM SUPPORT INTO WHAT REALLY
OUGHT TO BE A LONG TERM FIX AND
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
CHAIR EMERITUS OF PUT HIS
SHOULDER TO THE MUCH BIGGER
WE'LL LAST YEAR AND YEARS BEFORE
THAT.
AND I DON'T WANNA IN P. THAT
EFFORT IN ANY WAY.
YEAH I KNOW IT SHOWS.
THAT HE DID NOT DISLOCATED
THOUGH.
STILL ON SO.
WHAT WE NEED TO SOLVE THE BIGGER
PROBLEM BUT WE THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP -- AND THAT
SORT OF MODEST NEAR TERM FIX I
MOVED GOT A INTERESTING
COALITION HERE SO LET ME JUST
START BY ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
OTE -- BUT PASSING OVER TO MARK
MURRAY WITH CALIFORNIANS WASTE
AND THEN -- MISTER KENNEDY FROM
THE A ROPE COUNTY I GOT THAT
RIGHT YES.%
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE SUN
YEAH MARK MURRAY WITH THE REBEL
GROUP CALIFORNIA'S GUESS WASTE --
I WANT TO START OFF BY SAYING --
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF
SUMMARIZING THE PROBLEM IN
IDENTIFYING WHAT THIS BILL DOES
AS AS NOTED THIS IS NOT -- THE
COMPREHENSIVE LONG TERM FIX THIS
IS A SHORT TERM BUT REALLY
NECESSARY IMMEDIATE FIX TO
REINSTATE FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN
FUND THE RICH IN RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S LEFT AND
AND PROVIDE A OF FUNDING PROMISE.
TO THE RECYCLERS THAT HAVE
CLOSED THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE RECYCLING CENTERS
THAT HAVE CLOSED IN THE STATE SO
THAT WE CAN OPEN THOSE CENTERS
BACK UP.
AND JUST FUN FACT ON THOSE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
RECYCLING CENTERS THAT HAVE
CLOSED IN THE STATE.
ONLY HALF OF THOSE WERE
SUPERMARKET CONVENIENCE ON
RECYCLING CENTERS HALF OF THE
RECYCLING CENTERS THAT HAVE.
CLOSED WERE WHAT WE CALL OLD
LINE RECYCLERS ON THAT BOARD
SUPERMARKET PARKING LOT
RECYCLING CENTERS -- SO THERE IS
A MIX OF OPERATIONS.
THAT WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS AS
WELL AS AS CURBSIDE RECYCLING.
ARM ONE UP -- APOLOGIZE ON
BEHALF OF A ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR RICHARD BY A WHO WAS
HERE THIS MORNING AND AND
THROUGH LUNCH BUT WAS NOT ABLE
TO STICK AROUND.
TO HAVE THIS BILL HEARD AND HE
IS HE'S PREPARED SOME EXCELLENT.
TESTIMONY HERE -- THAT HE ASKED
ME TO READ I I WON'T READ ALL
THAT TESTIMONY BUT HE'S HE DOES
HAVE A VERY POWERFUL CONCLUSION
HERE THAT I WANTED TO REFERENCE
AND HE SO.
RICHARD OR SUPERVISOR OF BY A IN
ADDITION TO BEING AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL HE RUNS A NONPROFIT
RECYCLING CENTER THAT DOES BOTH
BUYBACK RECYCLING IN THE EAST
BAY AS WELL AS CURBSIDE
RECYCLING.
AND HIS OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN
VERY AFFECTED BY THIS DROP IN
FUNDING -- SO WE'RE WE'RE IN
THIS CRISIS BECAUSE OF A A DROP
IN SCRAP VALUE FUNDING BUT ALSO
BECAUSE THE PROCESSING PAYMENT
MECHANISMS IN THE LAW.
FAILED TO COME UP WITH THE BILL
TO COVER THE NET COST RECYCLING
PRECISELY WHEN WE NEEDED THEM TO
AND CAL RECYCLE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
AND THEY HAVE THE SURPLUS THAT'S
GROWING BECAUSE THEY CAN'T SPEND
THE MONEY THAT THEY HAVE THE OF
THREE MILLION DOLLARS S HE SAYS
PLEASE.
FOCUS ON FIXING WHAT'S BROKEN IN
THE USE SURPLUS PROGRAM REVENUE
TO RETURN RECYCLING CENTER
FUNDING TO THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
LEVELS.
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO
RE OPEN CLOSE RECYCLING CENTERS
IN RURAL AND OTHER UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE STATE.
ARM AND PLEASE DIRECT CAL
RECYCLE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON LONGER TERM
FIXES TO EXPAND RECYCLING.
IN TO ENSURE FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES THOSE THREE THINGS.
ARM.
I'M YOU KNOW AGAIN THE ANALYSIS.
DESCRIBES THE PROBLEM -- I'M HAD
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE -- IN ADDITION URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU MARK
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN KENNEDY WITH
THE RURAL COUNTIES.
IT WAS HAS BEEN REFERENCED A
RELATIVELY RECENT CLOSURE OF ALL
THOSE RECYCLING CENTERS HAS HAD
A REAL REALLY DEBILITATING
IMPACT ON CONSUMERS I'M ONE OF
THOSE CONSUMERS WHO HAS DRIVEN
AROUND MY LOCAL CITY LOOKING FOR
RECYCLING CENTERS.
AND CAN SPEAK TO THE FRUSTRATION.
IT CAN BE DIFFICULT TO FIND A
WAY TO GET YOUR MONEY BACK AND
WITHOUT CONVENIENT COLLECTION OR
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES THE
BOTTLE BILL OFTEN BECOMES A
REGRESSIVE TAX.
IT'S IN NO ONE'S BEST INTEREST
SO WE REALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AS A STOPGAP SOLUTION TO HELP
SUSTAIN HE EXISTING RECYCLING
CENTERS THAT ARE OUT THERE TO
PREVENT MORE FROM CLOSING.
AND WE THINK IT CAN REALLY HELP
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE IN RURAL AREAS WE HAVE
SOME RURAL COUNTIES THAT HAVE NO
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES OR OF
HAD NO REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR PERIODS OF TIME AND THAT'S
JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE -- FOR
CONSUMERS OUT THERE SO IN THE
ABSENCE OF A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION WE THINK THIS IS
APPROPRIATE AND DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU.
I SHOULD JUST THAT I'M SURE I
SHOULD MENTION IN MY OPENING BUT
WE DID WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AND ACCEPTED THERE'S A THERE'S A
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT THAT
SUGGESTS.
STRIKING SUBDIVISION H. WHICH
WOULD.
WHICH WOULD WOULD HAVE PROPOSED
A ONE MILE RADIUS INCREASE --
BUT WE'RE WILLING TO THE STRIKE
THAT'S WE APPRECIATE THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION ONE EXCEPT THAT
MEMBERS THIS IS AT THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE.
NINE AND THE US STAFF REPORT
THANK YOU. FOR THE CLARIFICATION
[inaudible]
JOHN.
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF A
SB SEVEN TWENTY FOUR THESE
COMPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE MARBLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEELS AND CONVENIENCE
ALLIANCES WELLS RECOLOGY IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL DAFT WITH REPUBLIC
SERVICES IN SUPPORT. FIFTY FAN
OF HAVE RE PLANET AS PART.
IT'S LIKE IT US HERE WE HAVE
ALWAYS ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA IN SUPPORT.
HELLO I'M CHEN ABIT I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR PROTECT YOUR
BE WHERE A TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THOSE SMALL INDEPENDENT
RECYCLERS.
I AGREE WITH MUCH OF WHAT HAS
BEEN SAID HERE TODAY.
CURBSIDE IS DIFFERENT FROM
REDEMPTION REDEMPTION.
CONSUMERS GET THEIR MONEY BACK.
BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
WE NEED THE RELIEF.
JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT.
GARCIA CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
A CONSERVATION CHORUS IN SUPPORT.
LARA FRONTERA BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
AMARILLO MAP THE COMPANY GROW
SENSATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S HEAR
FROM OPPOSITION.
PLEASE REMEMBER MIKE MATIC
CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND FIRST I
WANT THANK US SENATORS OR STERN.
FOR MESSING UP MY A SPEECH YEARS
SORRY TOOK ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS
SO I HAVE TO JUST QUICKLY -- THE
AGAIN.
I JUST LIKE TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
TO OUTLINE THE PROBLEM THEN
ANOTHER MINUTE TO OFFER A COUPLE.
SOLUTIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA EVERYONE'S PAYS
DEPOSITS FOR THE VETERANS AS
THEY BY AND WE ARE ENTITLED TO
GET OUR OUR NICHOLS BACK OR SEE
THEM USED TO IMPROVE RECYCLING
AND TAKE CARE OF OUR ENVIRONMENT.
INSTEAD CONSUMERS ARE FORFEITING
ALMOST HALF OF EVERY NICKEL
RECYCLING CENTERS ARE CLOSING
RIGHT AND LEFT.
AND THE QUALITY OF RECYCLING IS
DROPPING.
CALIFORNIA RECYCLING REQUIRE
SUBSTANTIAL RESTRUCTURING -- AND
THAT WE CAN AGREE ONE I'M NO
WHERE NEAR MILLENNIAL BUT I
AGREE WITH SENATOR STERN ON THE
LONG TERM FIX IS DEFINITELY
NECESSARY [inaudible]
I'M.
CALIFORNIA'S LAW IS BROKEN AND
BOTH CONSUMERS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT ARE PAYING A HUGE
PRICE I THINK SENATOR STERN'S
BILL.
MAY BE THE VEHICLE TO JUMP START
A REAL FIX MOVING FORWARD -- THE
BOTTLE BILL OBLIGATES GROCERIES
DRUGS IN CONVENIENCE STORES AND
OTHER BEVERAGE DEALERS. TO TO
RECYCLE INTO CONTAINERS AND PAY
CONSUMERS IF NO RECYCLING CENTER
EXISTS IN THAT HALF A MILE NOW
WE'RE GONNA KEEP.
AROUND THE MAJOR SUPERMARKET
JUST WHEN RECYCLING CENTERS ARE
AN ECONOMIC CRISIS AND 40% OF
CLOSEDRECENT YEARS.
GROCERY STORES ARE REFUSING TO
FOLLOW THE LAW.
CONSUMER WATCHDOG RECENTLY
CONDUCTED A THREE MONTH STUDY
HERE IT IS.
YOU GUYS HAVE IT OR NOT USING IT
AS COASTERS I CAN PASS OUT SOME
MORE ON THE WAY OUT -- THE
PRIMARY REASON IS BECAUSE THE
STATE RECYCLING SYSTEM LEAVES
CONSUMERS YOUR OPTIONS EVERY
YEAR WHERE TO REDEEM.
THEIR ANTES WHILE LEADING THE
GROCERY CHANGE.
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS AND TRASH
HAULERS TO GET RICH AT THE
CONSUMERS EXPENSE.
ACCORDING THE LA OWES TWENTY
SEIZE TWENTY SEVENTEEN REVIEW OF
THE STATE'S NO OTHER STATE.
HAS EXPERIENCED THE SAME
PRECIPITOUS LOSS IN THE NUMBER
OF RECYCLING CENTERS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S KIND OF ALARMING FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES OF
LOS TWO THIRDS.
OTHER CENTERS IN JUST FIVE YEARS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AS LOSS OF COURSE THE MOST.
ABOUT A HUNDRED NAY.
AND CURRENTLY RETAIL CHAINS
INCLUDING SOME OF THE BUSINESS
WALLS MARK SAM'S CLUB SAFE WAY
ALBERTSONS VONS PAVILIONS ARE
SERVING ABOUT 64%.
OF THE CONVENIENCE ZONES.
SO AS TO THE ENFORCEMENT ISSUE.
LET'S JUST GIVE ONE EXAMPLE.
CAL RECYCLE FOUND THAT WALMART
HAD UNDER REPORTED SIX POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
DEPOSITS.
DESPITE REPEATEDLY BEING CAUGHT
UNDER COUNTING DEPOSITS BUT THE
STATE CAL REESE'S CAL RECYCLE
NEVER FIND WALMART.
THEY WERE NEVER THEY WERE TOLD
NEARLY TO REPAY WHAT THEY OWED
ANYWAY THAT'S NOT REALLY A MUCH
OF A AN INCENTIVE TO FOLLOW THE
LAW.
SO AS TO THE SOLUTION WE WOULD
OFFER -- I WILL TAKE SOLUTION
ONE NOW WHICH WAS THE HALF A
MILE.
THANK YOU CENTER STERLING AND
REQUIRE HOW BIG STORES SELLING
BEVERAGES INCLUDING CHAINS
CONVENIENCE BIG BOX AND GROCERY
STORES GROSSING MORE THAN TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. TO OFFER
REDEMPTION SERVICES.
SECOND HAVE CARL RECYCLE PERFORM
FREQUENT SURPRISE INSPECTIONS
AND IMPOSE SUBSTANTIAL FINES
AGAINST STORES THAT TURN
CONSUMERS AWAY IN VIOLATE THE
LAW [inaudible]
PRETTY SIMPLE.
IN CLOSING WE NEED TO MAKE
RECYCLING EASIER FOR CONSUMERS
NOT HARDER OTHERWISE BOTH
CONSUMERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT --
GONNA LOSE.
NOW WHAT THAT'S GOING TO LOOK
LIKE WHETHER IT LOOKS LIKE A
EUROPEAN MODEL A NOR WHERE WHERE
WE HAVE VENDING MACHINE TYPE
WITH PLATFORMS AND DROPPING THEM
AND THAT'S IT LOTS IT'S A GREAT
IDEA AND IT.
IS CLEAN THE AND ARE RECYCLING
MATERIALS A DONE AND IT'S EASY
TO FIND YOU CAN STICK THEM
ANYWHERE.
WHATEVER THAT'S GOING TO BE.
THAT'S THE LONG TERM APPROACH
THAT SENATOR STERN MASSES HOW
IT'S ACTUALLY GONNA LOOK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO WORKING UP IT HAS
TO BE DONE.
SO WE WILL -- WE LIKE A SHORT
TERM FIX TO GO THROUGH.
WE WOULD LIKE IT TO BE
CONSIDERED AND WE LOOK FORWARD --
TO HAVING A COMPLETE OVERHAUL OF
OUR RECYCLING SYSTEM BY THE
LEGISLATOR AND LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION ASK INVOLVED
TOO SO.
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION MY NAME IS
LEONARD LYING I'M FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND I'VE CONSULTED WITH --
RECYCLERS FOR YEARS I'VE BEEN IN
THE PROGRAM SINCE THE BEGINNING.
I AM AN EXPERT [inaudible]
UP.
I'M HERE BECAUSE THERE ARE
SERIOUS ERRORS OF FACT IN.
BOTH THE CONSUMER WATCHDOG
REPORT.
AND IN THE ANALYSIS FOR THIS
BILL AND I THINK IF THOSE WERE
CLARIFIED WE COME UP WITH MUCH
BETTER BILL I AM OPPOSED TO THE
BILL UNLESS AMENDED.
AND I'VE SUBMITTED A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS TO FIX THIS
PROGRAM.
THE KEY IS THE CLOSURES ARE
BASED UPON ONE COMPANY CLOSING
HUNDREDS.
THE NEXT ISSUE OF CLOSURES ARE
REVOCATIONS BY CAL RECYCLE SUCH
AS IN AMADOR COUNTY RECENTLY
FORTUNATELY THAT WE FIX THAT --
THEY WANTED TO REMOVE ONE OF
THREE RECYCLERS WITHIN THE
COUNTY.
OF THE NEXT IS.
CALORIE CYCLE HAS DENIED
APPLICATIONS TO REFILL THESE ON
AND THEN CITIES HAVE BEEN
WORKING AGAINST RECYCLING. TO
REMOVE RECYCLERS BECAUSE OF
HOMELESS ISSUES.
THE REAL QUESTION HERE IS HOW
MANY UNSUBSIDIZED RECYCLERS HAVE
GONE OUT OF BUSINESS THAT'S THE
NUMBER YOU NEED TO KNOW AND THIS
BILL DOESN'T DO ANYTHING TO HELP
THEM.
THIS AYE YEAH. THREE FALSE
ALARMS THIS WITH A CALL YOU TO
GO TO THE COMMITTEE AND THEN
ANOTHER AUTHORS THERE AND IT'S
LIKE.
UNION LEADER ON COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WELL.
SO I DON'T KNOW I WAS TRYING TO
GET THE CLIFF'S NOTES ON YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT I OTHER FOLKS
WANTED. ONE IT YEAH RIGHT I AREA
I'M.
ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO RAISE
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL.
OKAY I MIGHT MAKE MUCH ABOUT
MARK AND THEN WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION DEBATE I KNOW THIS IS
THIS IS AN ISSUE IT ETCETERA
CASKEY ESPECIALES WORKED ON
PRETTY INTENSELY FOR A LONG TIME --
SO LET'S LET'S OPEN UP THE FLOOR.
TO THE TO THE COMMITTEE TO
DEBATE DISCUSS AND OUR CENTER
WITH DISLOCATED SHOULDER -- IF
WELL.
YOU STILL BEYOND THE NOT THE
DISLOCATED.
I'M SO ANY ANY QUESTIONS OR
THOUGHTS DISCUSSION.
NO I GET I GUESS YOU KNOW I DID
NOT.
EMBRACE THE BANDAID TECHNIQUE.
BUT LAST YEAR AND THOUGHT THAT
WE SHOULD DO SOMETHING.
BETTER BUT I ACKNOWLEDGE THE
FACT THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM OUT
IN THE STREET WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING I'M THERE'S NOTHING.
AT WITH THE WITH THE AMENDMENTS --
OBVIOUSLY THE OPPOSITION HAS
WOULD LIKE MORE AMENDMENTS TO OF
WHICH DANCE.
AB TWO OUT OUTRAGEOUS -- I JUST
AS YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT TO
CONSIDERED CONTINUED HAVE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE LARGER
REFORM I MEAN IT SAYS WE'LL BE
BACK HERE IN TWO YEARS TALK
ABOUT THE SAME PROBLEMS.
I SAID THIS IS A THREE YEAR
THREE YEAR SORT OF THAT'S LET
THE ADMINISTRATION COME TOGETHER
AND YOU KNOW I'M.
WE'LL DO MY WORK IN.
THIS IS A TWO YEAR SESSION
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
LEAVE IT AT THAT.
IF YOU HAVE A I JUST GOT CENTER
HOW I'M OF THE BILL.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD MY COMMENTS
TO SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE'S AN
IMMEDIATE AND APPLAUD HIS GREAT
EFFORTS -- AND THE STRUGGLES
THAT THE TO DEAL WITH THIS THIS
IS ONGOING PROBLEM AND I
APPRECIATE.
OF THE AUTHOR'S ABILITY AND
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE IT ON I DO I
RECOGNIZE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN AND I
THINK IS.
pWOULD BE NICE TO HAVE A FIX THAT
WE CAN DEPEND ON RELY ON AND
MOVE FORWARD WITH -- I I DON'T
KNOW IF.
THIS IS WILL GET US THERE IN
THIS SHORT TIME FRAME SO I HOPE.
THAT IS BECAUSE TO ME YOU COULD
BE THIS COULD BE IN THE WHOLE
THING COULD BE DONE IF IF YOU.
CAN WORK AT IT AND AND NOW I'M
CERTAIN WANTED SUPPORTED KEEP IT
GOING.
BUT HOPEFULLY YOU CAN KIND OF
WORK ON SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED -- BECAUSE I THINK
THAT COULD BE IMPORTANT IN
GETTING US TO THAT [inaudible]
SPECIAL SPOT.
CHOOSE UP IN THE THAT WOULD.
WOULD WORK.
THAT WOULD WORK.
THE SPECIALS FIVE LIVE SPECIALS
BY.
AND I'LL JUST SAY I I DON'T.
BETWEEN CENTER SKINNER WHO WAS
WORKING ON WASTE.
YOU KNOW BEFORE WE EVEN CALL THE
WAYS I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT YOU
CALL THAT.
BACK WHEN YOU WORKED ON THE
FIRST STYROFOAM BAND AND CENTER
ALLEN ON PLASTICS.
FIRST 50% SO.
I'M YOU KNOW I'M A LITTLE -- OUT
RANKED HERE IN TERMS OF
EXPERTISE BETWEEN.
THE CENTER Y. CASKEY.
BUT I'LL JUST COMMIT MYSELF TO
DOING THAT WORK AND NOT JUST TRY
TO SAY A BANDAIDS GONNA SELL
BECAUSE I I REALLY THE THIS
ISN'T THE TOTAL ANSWER WE'VE GOT
TO GET THROUGH THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS THOUGH OR AT LEAST THIS
YEAR.
AND TRY TO FIND SOME NEAR TERM
WAY TO DEAL WITH NATIONAL STORED
RE STIMULATE THE MARKET IN SOME
MEANINGFUL WAY BUT I DON'T WANT
TO GET IN THE WAY THAT BIGGER
PROGRESS IN FACT AYE AYE SIR TO
CONSIDER THIS BILL.
AN IMPLICIT COMMITMENT TO HELP
SOLVE THAT BIGGER PROBLEM SO ON
THEIR ON THEIR AND I CANNOT WAIT
TILL NEXT SESSION CENTER WE CAST
YOU CENTER SKINNER.
I'M.
THE INTERESTING THING IS THE
VETO MESSAGE ON GLAZERS BILL
WHICH WAS VERY COMPARABLE TO
THIS LAST YEAR HAD TO DO WITH.
THE PROBLEM OF THE BUDGET.
MEANING THE IN OUR ACCOUNTS OR
OUR RESOURCE FUND IS AN
ADEQUATELY FUNDED.
BUT IN FACT.
THE ONE OF THE ISSUES IN YOUR
FINDINGS ARE YOUR ARGUMENTS --
DESCRIBED AS ONE OF THE ISSUES
IS THAT WITH THE COLLAPSE OF THE
COLLAPSE WITH HE UNWILLINGNESS
OF COUNTRIES IN ASIA TO BUY WHAT
WE NO LONGER CONSIDER VALUABLE.
WHICH IS OUR WHOLE RECYCLING
PROGRAM WAS BASED ON THEIR
BUYING OUR JUNK.
AND I NOW THAT THEY PRODUCE
THEIR OWN BECAUSE EVERYBODY
TALKS NATIONALS WORK BUT RIGHT
REALLY IS GOING ON WASTE IS A
VERB IT IS NOT A NOUN SOMETHING
IS NOTWASTE UNTIL IT IS WASTED.
WE WASTE MANY MORE THINGS.
BASICALLY POOR COUNTRIES DON'T
WASTE AS MUCH WHEN THEY GET
RICHER THEY BECOME LIKE US SO
THEY GOT THEIR OWN JUNK.
SO NOW WE HAVE ALL THIS STUFF
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH [inaudible]
BUT WE ALSO HAVE.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY WE'VE DECIDED
TO DO CURBSIDE IN MOST PLACES
NOT MY CITY.
WE MIX EVERYTHING AND IT BECOMES
CONTAMINATED SO THE ONLY THING.
I AM NOT A I DO NOT OPPOSE THE
BILL BUT I DO THINK THAT.
UNTIL WE HAVE OUR OWN MARKETS WE
DO YOU NEED TO TRY TO EXPAND AND
STRENGTHEN.
THOSE PLACES WHERE THIS MATERIAL
CAN BE RECEIVED.
UNCONTAMINATED BECAUSE THE C. R.
V. STREAM.
IS A STREAM THAT CHINA IS STILL
BUYING.
IT IS OUR CURBSIDE THAT THEY'RE
NOT BUYING SO IT.
THIS IS.
I WILL NOT IS ANY KIND OF INSULT
BUT IT ISN'T IN ELEGANT FIX
THOUGH IT IS UNNECESSARY FIX FOR
THIS MOMENT BUT WE HAVE TO GET
THAT THE FIX THAT ALLOWS US TO
BOTH HAVE A STREAM.
AND CREATE SOME MARKETS CLEAN
STREAM IN SOME MARKETS.
YEAH I MEAN A I AGREE AND I I
THINK ALSO WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
AS WE GO AND COMPLETELY TRY TO
RELY ON CURBSIDE RECYCLING FOR
EVERYTHING AND YET THEY'RE
INADEQUATE.
THEN YOU BASICALLY THROW
EVERYTHING IN THE LANDFILL
ANYWAY BECAUSE AS THE REPORT
POINTED OUT.
YOU ARE AT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
RATE IS AT WITH THE AVERAGE
1010102020% THERE WAS THE NUMBER
IN THERE.
SO IT'S MILLION LESS YOUR
CHANCES GO OR BERKELEY WHERE
PEOPLE ARE UPSTREAM CONSUMERS
THEMSELVES ARE BEING EXTRA
DILIGENT ON THE FRONT AND PAYING
FOR THE CURB THE STILL SEPARATE
SO ARE.
YEAH OUR PROCESSING FACILITY.
IS RIGHT NOW HAVING LESS PROBLEM
WITH THE PURCHASE BECAUSE OUT
YOUR ARMOR BECAUSE WE HAVE CLEAN
LOADS NOT A 100% BUT AND NOT A
LOT OF OTHER COMMUNITIES DO.
COMPLETELY AGREE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO.
LOT MORE WORK TO DO.
I THE BILL I THINK IS TO MOVE BY
CINEMA CASKEY -- WITH THAT WELL
IF YOU CLOSE CENTER [inaudible]
YOU -- THE QUICK LOOK WE'VE
WE'VE TRIED IT WE TRIED TO BE
RESPONSIVE AND AND AND THERE IS
SOME OF THAT IMPROVE COLLECTION
BEING ADDRESSED HERE THERE IS
SOME INCENTIVE FOR THE
INNOVATIVE RECYCLING TECHNIQUES
IN TRYING TO RE STIMULATE THE
MARK I THINK YOU.
THAT IS IN HERE IS IT ENOUGH NO.
IS IT IS IT THAT FIX THAT THAT
LONGER TERM SOLUTION NOTE SO
AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO OVER
PROMISE BUT I THINK JUST
RESTORING RECYCLING INCENTIVE TO
GET BACK TO AT LEAST TWENTY
FIFTEEN LEVELS.
AND TRYING TO REFOCUS THE CAL
RECYCLE RESOURCES ON TO GETTING
TO THESE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
IS A POSITIVE STEP -- SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN PROMISE AT
LEAST IN THIS YEAR THAT WILL
HAVE IF IF FOR THE NEXT YEAR IF
THIS BILL PASSES WILL BE ABLE.
TO RESTORE SOME RECYCLING MARKET
PLACE BUT I DON'T THINK IS
ENOUGH TO COMPETE WITH NATIONAL
SOARED -- IT'S GOING TO TAKE
MORE THAN THAT AND I'M GONNA
MAKE SOME OF THOSE HARD
DECISIONS TO DO THAT SO IF THIS
ENDS UP BEING IF THE STARS
ALIGNED COVER CYCLE IN THIS
GOVERNOR ENGAGES IN WE ACTUALLY
A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION.
I'M ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO TO BRING
THAT IN BUT YEAH I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE TODAY
IN LOOKING AT HOW -- TO DEAL
WITH A VERY AWKWARD CURRENT
SITUATION -- OF IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS INCREDIBLY LANDMARK
PROGRAM SO THAT ESPECIALLY
ESCRIBIR.
THANK YOU OKAY I THINK TO PLEASE
CALL.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SB SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR STERN THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BATES.
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
I STERN STERN AYE STONE.
WHITE HOUSE GAME.
I CASKEY I AWESOME ALL RIGHT
WELL THAT WE WILL LEAVE OPEN FOR
OTHER FOLKS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION I KNOW THE CENTER
WILL CONTINUE WORKING --
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S NEXT YEAR FROM CENTER
SKINNER WHO'S HERE TO PRESENT SB
FORTY NINE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE IN YOUR AGENDAS MEMBERS.
INOCULATED TO ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
YEAH AND SO CENTERS CAN YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
SB [inaudible]
FORTY NINE A WE'RE GONNA MY
TEEPEES NO LIKE ALRIGHT HOW DO I
JUST EXPLAIN THIS BILL SIMPLY.
OUR ARMED ENERGY COMMISSION HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO SET ENERGY
EFFICIENCY TO TO MAKE A POINT
STANDARDS BASED ON ENERGY
EFFICIENCY ENERGY EFFICIENCY IS
ABSOLUTELY STOOD STILL BE OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY BECAUSE IT
REFLECTS NEGA WHAT'S.
BUT AS WE EXPAND NOW TO
RENEWABLES.
AND AS WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE.
OUR DEMAND ON OUR ELECTRICITY
SYSTEM.
IS VERY BOLD DURING HE DAY WE
HAVE THESE PEAK TIMES.
IT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE CAPACITY.
TO HAVE [inaudible]
SMART APPLIANCES THAT IF OUR
ENERGY COMMISSION WAS EMPOWERED
TO SET STANDARDS FOR THOSE
APPLIANCES TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO DEMAND MANAGEMENT.
THEN THEY COULD BE SET TO BE
USED DURING TIMES THAT ARE PEAK
OR DURING TIMES WHEN RENEWABLES
ARE GENERATING THE HIGHEST.
AND UTILIZE OUR ELECTRICAL
RESOURCES BETTER SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IT'S A KIND OF FUNNY.
IT ALLOWS THE ENERGY COMMISSION
TO FACTOR THAT DEMAND MANAGEMENT
IN AND IT DOES SO THROUGH USING
THE LANDS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW.
ALL THE ONLY LENDS THEY CAN USE
IS INCREASING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
SO THAT'S IN EFFECT WHAT THE
BILL DOES.
AND I HAVE SOME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU I MY NAME IS
LILLIAN MARVIS I AM A GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER AT HOME CAN ACT
WERE OF RESIDENTIAL A DEMAND
RESPONSE OFFER COMPANY.
DOWN IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO SHARE THAT OWN
CONNECTS THE PORTS SB.
FORTY NINE AS CALIFORNIA STRIVES
TO MEET ITS SB ONE HUNDRED GOALS
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE DEMAND OF
ELECTRICITY MATCHES WHEN THAT
SUPPLIES CLEANEST ME THAT THERE
IS HIGH PENETRATION OF THE
NOBLES ON THE GRADE.
UNDER SB FORTY NINE WE'LL SEE
HOME DEVICES TRANSFORM FROM JUST
BEING ON OFF YOU KNOW TURN ON
AND USE IT WHENEVER YOU NEED AT
TO BECOMING SMARTER AND GREAT
CONNECTED TO THAT THOSE DEVICES
RESPOND TO GRADE CONDITIONS.
THOSE CAN GRADE CONDITIONS ARE
NOT ONLY REFLECTIVE OF WHEN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS ARE LOW
BUT THEY CAN ALSO BE INDICATIVE
OF REAL TIME PRICING SELLING
PRICES ARE LOW AS WELL.
WHERE OWN CONNECT IS MOST
EXCITED ABOUT SB FORTY NINE IS
THAT IT ALLOWS?
EVERYDAY CONSUMERS OF
ELECTRICITY SO EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM TO BE A PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION SO THE DEVICES IN OUR
HOME CAN ACTUALLY INTEGRATE
RENEWABLES AND FACILITATE THAT
PROCESS.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
I ACTUALLY HAVE TO RUN AND CATCH
THE TRAIN BUT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS PLEASE FOLLOW UP WITH
ME AND I'LL GET BACK TO YOU AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
THANKS.
NEXT AT FIFTY PHÃN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY
INTERIM MANAGEMENT COUNCIL WE
ARE STATEWIDE TRADE ASSOCIATION
OF COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND A MAN RESPONSE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES -- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
FORTY NINE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
SB.
FORTY NINE I GET THE LEGACY OF
KINGS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ENERGY STORAGE ALLIANCES SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OUR WINNERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIECKOWSKI
CHASE AND I OCCURRED WITH
THAT'LL STING GILBERT ROPES AND
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION.
SEE ANYWAY HAS NO POSITION ON
THIS BILL BUT WANTED TO JUST
QUICKLY THANK AT THE SENATOR AND
HER STAFF FOR THE GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD AND
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO TAKE.
THE AMENDMENT THAT'S NOTED ON
PAGE FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS.
WHICH IS A GOOD CURE FOR A
LITTLE BIT OF HARPER AND WE HAD
WITH THE TERM LOAD MANAGEMENT
THANK YOU.
AND IT IS AN AUTHORS MEMBERS
SEWER.
OKAY YOU'RE TAKING AT THAT JUST
CLARIFY THAT FOR MEMBERS.
OPPOSITION TO SB [inaudible]
FORTY NINE IT'S HERE.
ART WAS CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
BRING BACK TODAY'S QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR.
THE BILL THERE'S A MOTION BY
SENDER STERN.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AND I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FORTY NINE
BY SENATOR SKINNER MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN [inaudible]
BATES.
HILL.
I STERN STERN AYE STONE WHY
CASKEY AYE CASKEY AYE I WILL
KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT WE FINISH THE
CALENDAR.
SO WHAT I WOULD PROPOSE IS THAT
WE GO BACK TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IF THE CLERK COULD CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS NUMBER
SEVEN NUMBER FIFTEEN NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE HILL [inaudible]
HILL I STERN.
STERN AYE AYE CASKEY HI.
HI THE VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO WILL
CLOSE THE THE CALENDAR ON THE
CONSENT.
NOW LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
HAS BEEN PULLED -- BY.
SB FOR BERMAN CHOIR SO LET'S GO.
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FORTY
EIGHT BY WINNER PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AM.
CHAIR VOTING I TWO ZERO BATES.
HELLO.
HILL AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE STONE.
I WILL LEAVE THAT MATTER OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT -- THAT WAS NO
WINNER.
I'M SORRY I GOT IT -- TO PLEASE
LOCAL CLOSER I WOULD I WANT TO
HOLD OFF ON THAT -- I CAN'T NOW.
YEAH.
AGAIN I DON'T KNOW THAT -- YEAH.
YOU'RE NOT IN A OKAY.
LET'S GET THIS. FORTY NOW.
YEAH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LET'S.
CONTINUE ONE TO ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR WITH ALAN THIS IS A. B..
OR SB FIFTY NINE ON THOMAS
VEHICLES PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
A ITEM NUMBER FOUR CHAIR VOTING
I BY SERVING I IT'S FIVE ZERO
HILL.
HILL AYE STERN.
SORRY ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR WHAT ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR IS A THOMAS VEHICLES BY HI
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I HE SAID HI YES I HAD IN HIM I
THIS.
AND THAT SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
WILL CLOSE TO ROLL ON I NUMBER
FOUR ITEM NUMBER THREE OCEAN
RESILIENCY ACTIVE. TWENTY
NINETEEN BY SENATOR WINNER THIS
IS SB SIXTY NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE SB SIXTY NINE BY A SENATOR
WIENER -- ALLEN I'M SORRY CHAIR
VOTING I HILL.
NO I SKINNER.
I STERN STERN AYE STONE.
I WILL KEEP THE MATTER OPEN FOR
THOSE -- ABSENT MEMBERS I AND
NUMBER SIX NIELSEN'S.
OUR WATERSHED RESTORATION SB TWO
TWO SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
M. S. S. ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TWO
TWO SIX CHAIR VOTING I BATES.
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE.
OKAY THAT MATTER OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
JACKSON'S SP FOUR TWENTY FOUR ON
TOBACCO PRODUCTS SINGLE USE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND I'M NUMBER EIGHT SB FOUR TWO
FOUR CHAIR VOTING AYE.
AYE SIR VOTING NOT VOTING.
AT THREE ONE HILL.
HILL AYE STERN.
STERN I FIVE ONE AND BATES THE
WAS NOT VOTING.
SO WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON AN
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT OF FIVE ONE
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB FOUR FIVE
EIGHT BY TO RUSSELL ON FOR FOR
FOR REFERS. FOR A FULL SIZE FOSS.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB.
FOUR FIVE EIGHT AS CHAIR OF I'M
SORRY CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO HILL.
HILL AYE AYE CASKEY.
BY NOW SKI I I WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE THAT'S FIVE TO TO ITEM
NUMBER.
TEN STERN AS A NATURAL GAS
STORAGE AS BEFORE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND NUMBER TEN AS BEFORE SIX
THREE CHAIR VOTING I VESTER
VOTING I HILL.
NO I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE.
I WILL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN.
S. ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA GLOBAL WARMING SACKED
SOLUTIONS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX COPING PLAN BY MORE LOCK --
AS AMENDED.
SB THREE OR FIVE THREE FIVE
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND I'M NUMBER ELEVEN SB FIVE
THREE FIVE CHAIR VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING I FOUR ZERO
HILL.
HILL AYE STERN.
STERN I WAKE OWSKI.
BY A SKI HI.
SEVEN I I UNDERSTAND THAT CENTER
STONE WILL NOT BE COMING BACK.
SO WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING IF IF
HE REMAINS SENATOR BATES WILL
COME BACK.
COME BACK BATES ALL RIGHT.
WHAT WAS THE VOTE ON I?
OKAY THAT MATTERS.
WE'LL CLOSE TO ROLL ON ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE SB SEVEN ARE FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR LEYVA THE COSMETIC
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR INGREDIENT
RIGHT TO KNOW ACT.
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND A NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE
SEVEN FOUR CHAIR VOTING HI.
BATES.
HILL.
NOW I SKINNER.
SKINNER I STONE.
I WILL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN --
FOR CENTER BATES.
ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN SB AS SIX THIRTEEN
BYTES STERN AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REPORT CARD PLEASE
CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS AND
NUMBER THIRTEEN SB.
SIX ONE THREE CHAIR VOTING I'D.
BY STIRRING NOW HILL.
NO I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE.
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE VOTE IS.
FIVE TO TO THAT MATTERS.
OUT ITEM NUMBER -- FOURTEEN SB.
ONE OF FIVE TWO ONE SKIS ME.
I'M NUMBER FOURTEEN SB S. SIX
THREE TWO BY GALGIANI -- THE
VEGETATION TREATMENT -- PROJECTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND I'M NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SIX
THIRTY TO THE CHAIR VOTING I BY
SERVING AYE HILL.
NOW I STERN.
STERN I Y. CASKEY.
HI I CASKEY HI.
ALL RIGHT THE MATTERS AT WILL
CLOSE TO ROLAND ON THAT MATTER.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN MITCHELL SB.
SIX FOUR SEVEN ON A MIDDLE
CONTAINING JEWELLERY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND I'M NUMBER SIXTEEN SB.
SIX FOUR SEVEN CHAIR VOTING I'VE
BY STERLING AYE HILL.
HILL AYE STERN.
STERN IOWA CASKEY.
HI A SKI I OKAY -- I AM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN SB SIX FIFTY NINE BY
WERE JUST THE INFILL HOUSING --
SEE WHAT ATTORNEY FEES THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS OFFERED IN
COMMITTEE ARE AS FOLLOWS -- SB.
SIX FIVE FOUR WITH AUTHORIZED TOCOURT TO AWARD ATTORNEY FEES TO
THE PREVAILING PARTY THAT IS A
RESPONDED ORDER PARTY REAL PARTY
IN INTEREST WHEN THE COURT FINDS
THE PETITIONER USED ACTIONS.
TACTICS.
FOR THE WORD CLAIMS MADE ON AN
RECENTLY OR IN BAD FAITH THAT
ARE FRIVOLOUS ARE INTENDED TO
CAUSE UNNECESSARY DELAYS THIS
LANGUAGE WE PROVIDED. FOR
DIFFERENT STANDARD OF AWARDING
ATTORNEY FEES FOR THOSE INFILL
HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
[inaudible]
THAT WOULD.
THEN WOULD -- THAN WHAT IS
CURRENTLY PROVIDE AN EXISTING
LAW.
THERE WAS A DISCUSSION ON
UNREASONABLE AND UNNECESSARY AND
AND THE ADDITION OF CLAIMS.
THAT'S AND NOTICED EVERYBODY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN SB.
SIX FIVE NINE CHAIR VOTING I AM.
BY SERVANT. NINE FOUR ZERO HILL.
NO I STERN.
WACO SKI DON'T.
ASK YOU KNOW.
I AM NUMBER -- EIGHTY CLOSE THE
ROLE.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN QUIZ
THOSE.
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FACILITIES FOR GREEN.
GREEN.
HOUSE GASES SB SIX SIX SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN SB SIX SIX
SEVEN SHEPHERDING AYE AYE BY SIR
VOTING I FOUR ZERO HILL.
NOW I STERN.
STERN AYE WHY KELSEY HI.
HI. SEVEN ZERO THAT MATTERS OUT
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN SB SIX NINE
OH BY THE WAY SO ON HE WON THE
RIVER THESE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND I'M NUMBER NINETEEN
SB SIX NINETY CHAIR VOTING I
BASED YOU'RE VOTING AYE. FIVE
ZERO HILL.
HILL AYE STERN.
STERN I WAS THE ROLE THE MATTERS
APPROVED SEVEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SB -- SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
BY STERN ON BEVERAGE CALIFORNIA
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SB SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR CHAIR VOTING I BATES.
BATES AYE STONE [inaudible]
YEAH HELLO [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH OKAY WILL CLOSE ROLLED VOTE
IS SIX ZERO THAT MATTERS OUT.
AND FINALLY ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWO SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR LIKE HAVE
A GYRO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR CHAIR VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING I FOUR ZERO
AND HILL [inaudible]
NO I AND STERN.
I CASKEY NO.
CLOSE ROLE.
THAT WHAT MATTERS APPROVED.
FIVE ONE I MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
HERE THANK YOU YOUR EXCUSE.
LET'S GO BACK.
TO THE MATTER SAID IF THE THE
SYSTEM CAN YOU CALL THE MATTERS
IT'S A CENTER BATES WAS NOT HERE.
ADD A MEMBER TO SB.
FORTY EIGHT MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
BATES.
BATES NO STONE.
I WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THE MARRIAGE BROUGH FIVE ONE
NEXT BILL -- ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB FORTY NINE YOU PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN
[inaudible]
BATES.
BATES NOSE DOWN.
WE HAVE FOUR ONE OKAY WILL KEEP
ITEM NUMBER THREE OPEN -- FOR
CHAIR ALAN NEXT BILL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIXTY NINE
ED TO PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN AYE BATES.
NOT VOTING STONE.
CLOSE THE ROLE THE VOTE IS. FIVE
ZERO MATTERS APPROVED NEXT BILL --
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TWO TWO SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING HI.
WICKS.
BATES AYE STONE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE.
MATT VOTE IS SIX ZERO MATTERS
APPROVED.
NEXT BILL.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR AB DO PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING I THANK.
WICKS NO STONE CLOSE TO ROLL.
FIVE ONE MATTERS OF PROOF.
WE'RE GOOD OKAY SO WE HAVE ONE
BILL THAT IS SEND CALL IT'S ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB FORTY NINE BY
SKINNER. FOR JUST FOR CHAIR
[inaudible]
NO
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE WILL RECESS FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES.
ON BEFORE WE HAVE THE FINAL
[inaudible]
CLOSURE
.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ONE THING CLEAR --
FIVE AT THE SURGERY IT RIDLEY
MENTIONED THAT SB.
FORTY EIGHT WAS FIVE ONE IT'S
NOT FIVE JOINT AFFORDED TO VOTE.
THAT IS STILL -- ADEQUATE TO GET
THE BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE.
I WE'RE GOING TO OPEN AND CLOSE
THE ROLE ON SB -- FORTY NINE SEC
SHOULD BE KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FORTY NINE
M. MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
A VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. FOUR TO
ONE ALAN AYE ALLEN HI.
OKAY THAT'S FIVE ONE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THAT.
AND THEN THE FINAL THING.
RIGHT OKAY SO WE HAVE TO CLOSE
THE ROLE ON SB -- FOUR SIXTY
THREE CENTER STONE IS AWARE --
BUT HE'S IT CHAIRING THE WILD.
VACCINE HEARING RIGHT NOW BUT
HEALTH SO -- HE'S OKAY WITH US
CLOSE THE ROLE FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING.
SO WE'RE WITHOUT WITHOUT WITHOUT
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON ALL OF
THE ITEMS -- WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL DECLARE
THIS HEARING OF THE BERMAN
QUALITY COMMITTEE ADJOURNED